you are what you consistently think
about whether you think you'll win or
lose you're right it's a challenge I
think a lot of us face we are stuck in
our head in our mind telling ourselves
why we can't do something why we're not
good enough we're born in the wrong
country we have the wrong skin color
we're the wrong gender we had the wrong
family we're the wrong education and we
just keep replaying these same stories
over and over and over and over and over
again and you don't win because you
believe that you can't win that's what
the great rewiring has to take place
inside all of us because that's why I
think that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem I'm on a mission to
solve the world's number one problem
people do not believe in themselves to
create amazing things I think everybody
has Michael Jordan level genius at
something that you are the greatest in
the world at something and it's probably
not what you went to school for and it's
probably not what your parents did for a
living it's something totally different
and a challenge in being able to go and
Chase down something that's totally
different is the belief that it's
possible
because when you are around people who
are not living their life who are
complaining who are negative who may not
be toxic but who are stuck
people who are stuck
the easiest thing to do is to get stuck
yourself and to have the thought
patterns that keep you stuck this is why
I create all my channels
because I need it for me because I want
to be around people who challenge me who
when I see what they're doing it forces
me to think different to think bigger to
want to do more to want to be a better
Evan Carmichael whatever that means
right to just feel like I'm I want to
grow and do more because I'm around the
people who are doing that
where if you stay stuck with the people
that you're in right now you stay stuck
in the environment that you're
participating in right now then you will
likely stay there and not grow and not
improve and not learn and not get better
now
that doesn't mean that you stop caring
it doesn't mean that you stop giving
that doesn't mean that you stop
contributing it in fact it's the
opposite
you if you're watching this video you're
on a journey you're on a growth curve
and you want to go here right you want
to climb you want to get better you're
you're you want to go over there and
there may be people who are who are even
pulling you back actively saying not to
do that don't do that you can't do that
the goal isn't even necessarily to leave
these people behind
the goal could be to come back and help
them
but how can you help them and how can
you pour even more into them well by
learning more and improving yourself
more that every time that you learn
something and you get better at
something you can come back and pour it
into other people that when you're
taking your growth curve you're stepping
you're climbing you're improving you're
getting better every step that you take
you know if you now you move to step
number four you can help others other
people get the step number three you can
reach back and help them climb up
another step
so it doesn't mean that you stop being
optimistic and positive and helpful for
the people around you that's that's your
light that's your gift that's what you
are so amazing at
but it does mean that you need to
inject newness into your environment
because your environment is crafting
your thoughts and your thoughts are
keeping you stuck
you might have these moments where you
feel bold and brave and you can do
something else but
those aren't consistent and because the
boldness in thought is not consistent
the boldness and action is not
consistent and so you stay stuck doing
the same thing knowing that you're
capable of more we're not doing the
thing and this is a game for everybody
this is this is for myself this is for
you this is for the people who are ahead
of you on their growth curve you never
want to stop there's always a new level
of of self-talk and self-belief to get
you to the next thing that's possible
so it's why I do what I do because I
need it for me I need to be around
people who inspire me every day so that
I can continue to organize for kindness
right Martin Luther King had a great
quote about organizing for kindness that
people organized for negativity to
organize uh looting and the organized
violence and their organized Wars and
their organized negativity well who's
organizing for kindness right that's
what we need to do but you need to have
the inspired environment to create the
inspired thoughts to allow the inspired
action to come out so you can organize
for kindness too
so let's break down how do you actually
start doing it how do you actually start
to change that self-talk to be a more
positive one so that you can actually
follow through on the great ideas that
you have for yourself
number one
is to be around your Heroes who are your
Heroes who have done the thing that you
love doing either the actual work itself
like they're in your industry and they
have done the thing if you know my story
you know I looked up to Bill Gates he
had a software company I had a software
company I learned from him to build my
company I haven't met him but yet but uh
his strategy save my company and then I
also learned from someone like Oprah
Winfrey or Kanye West or people who are
not in my industry but I just like for
some reason I'm gonna go and learn from
them so who are your Heroes either in
your industry or people that you just
look up to for some reason
and force yourself to spend more time
with them
be around them more put their pictures
up on the wall behind you my favorite
entrepreneur of all time is AP giannini
who started Bank of America put their
pictures on the wall behind you
subscribe to their YouTube channels if
they have it follow them on social media
read their books listen to their
podcasts like have them be in your
environment as much as possible because
they will transport you to another world
they will help you change that self-talk
in your head because the people who have
done the thing that you want to do your
Heroes the people you look up to likely
have done it with less than what you
have right now
the the resources that you have right
now the heart that you have right now
the the mental capacity that you have
right now the tools at your disposal you
know you have the internet you've got a
lot of tools at your disposal get a lot
of Technology at your disposal that your
Heroes didn't have as much access to if
any and they went off and won
so yes it might be difficult but if they
can do it you can do it too the question
is who you're going to listen to you
know the voice that says it's too hard
I'm never going to do it or the voice
that says well they can do it I can do
it too
so you have to be around you want to
change that self-talk you have to be
around your mentors Your Heroes because
they will pull you to a different place
set number two is to create a calendar
that has your habits in there your goals
that you've set for yourself needs to be
reflected in the habits because goals
don't accomplish themselves goals will
happen when you put time on your
calendar to go and make it happen I'm
making this video because it's in my
calendar this block of time right now to
go make videos right what do you need to
put in your calendar so that it's not
just a hope a dream a goal but it
actually becomes something that's in
reality and then to start to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your own calendar you want to start
to change yourself belief yourself talk
your that voice inside your head you
have to teach yourself that you follow
through on the things that you say
you're gonna do have fewer goals have
fewer things that you write down in your
calendar
but when they're in there they get done
because here's what happens every time
you set a goal every time you put
something in your calendar and you don't
do it you're training yourself that the
next time you put something in your
calendar that's not going to get done
too you're losing credibility with
yourself not even somebody else saying
you can't do it it's you your own voice
saying you can't do it because you
haven't done the last thing that you
said you were going to do or the thing
before that
so the rate is start to rewire that is
to when you put something in your
calendar it's going to get done to even
lower the barrier lower the standard for
what has to get done for you to get the
check mark that you accomplished this
thing that when it gets put in your
calendar you are going to be the person
who actually follows through that starts
to shift identity
that starts to help you believe more in
yourself that the next thing that you
add in your calendar you're also going
to get done
so how do we start to change that
self-talk right that criticism or or
compassionate voice in our head how do
we how do we shift towards belief one be
around our mentors and our heroes the
people who Inspire us to do it to create
a calendar that reflects our goals our
actions have to map to our Ambitions
right has to be in your calendar and
teach yourself that you do the things
that are in your calendar and step
number three would be to collect good
people
I'm a huge fan of collecting good people
if you believe like I believe that your
environment is keeping you stuck and
keeping you where you are okay a shift
can be to be around your Heroes but you
never you may never meet them
good people when you're around the right
people
who fill you up as opposed to you
filling others up all the time it
changes everything you're a giver you're
caring you've got a big heart it's why
you're part of this community I love you
for that and keep going keep doing it
don't stop pointing to others
but who's pointing to you
when you walk away from a conversation
how often do you feel better about
yourself how often you have more energy
as opposed to well that was draining to
me you need to start to inject the
people who make you feel better who give
you more energy
and you may know some of them they may
not be the closest of friends to you yet
but whenever you meet somebody if it's
at an event or a conference or group or
in the comments section or on a Discord
and they just make you feel better
fight to try to find a way to spend more
time with them the way I'll often do it
is through businesses I end up setting
companies with them because I love them
so much it's a way to spend more time
with them
but it can be awkward at the beginning
like you don't know what you're gonna do
but you'll be the person to reach out to
say hey I'd love to have a coffee with
you next week or maybe we can schedule a
a monthly Mastermind with us and maybe a
couple other people like you reach out
to find a way to collect good people and
fight to spend more time with them
because when you're around actual humans
who are in front of you who make you
feel better about yourself and give you
the energy that you're pouring in other
people
it gives you more hope more momentum and
increases the chance of you actually
following through so get into the
practice of collecting good people
lack of belief is the single biggest
problem in the world you
have Michael Jordan level genie says
something you are the greatest in the
world at something
it's just your belief my belief too and
the ability to actually go and Chase it
down that will make the difference
between the life that you have right now
and the life that you know you're
capable of living let's solve that
together hard work is your ticket in
hard work doesn't guarantee your success
but it's your ticket in there's nobody
who you look up to who you respect who
you want to be like who did not work
incredibly hard to get to where they're
at now people say work smart work smart
work yes there's lots of people who work
hard and never get anywhere close to
their goals there's lots of people who
work incredibly hard who who stay
earning minimum wage their entire life
because they didn't work smart they were
only working hard but there's nobody who
just works smart and doesn't work hard
even if they're fooling you with their
pictures on Instagram it's that
combination of working hard plus working
smart I've covered
most of these people I've hung out with
a lot of these people I see the
incredible smarts that they have and the
activities that they choose but also
just the work ethic they have the show
up every day and stay consistent on
their goals
so in this video I'm gonna try to give
you some tips and steps on how to
actually do it like how do you stay
consistent how do you figure out how to
work hard but also work smart on
accomplishing your mission so
let's get it started first off you have
to actually love the thing right I mean
how many times have you started a
business because you thought it was
going to make you a lot of money
be honest I've done it too you started
business because you think it's going to
make you money
and then you quickly get bored of it you
quickly realize it's not making you
money and you don't want to do it
anymore
and you close it down and move on to the
next thing and so many people are just
opportunity hopping
jump to the next thing the next thing
and the next thing the next thing the
next thing without ever actually loving
any of the things and so you never you
never actually win you might make a
little bit of money here and there you
know you might be able to pay some of
your bills off it's great but you're not
living the life that you want
because you're just opportunity hopping
instead of actually finding the thing
that you love doing where the number one
rule for Success if you watch any of my
videos we've covered so many people take
my word for it or go do your own
research the number one number one guys
number one rule for success is that you
have to love what you're doing you have
to love the process the actual work that
you're doing
it doesn't feel like work because you
like it so much making videos doesn't
feel like work because I like it because
I like the process I like making it I I
like making this video more than
getting something like this right it's
great hey a million subscribers awesome
or the other channel is great
but I like I like the feeling of making
this video and knowing that you right
now are watching it
means something to me I like it that's
why I keep going otherwise it's crazy
you know
10 000 videos plus later why like how do
you keep going because I like it doesn't
feel like work to me I talk about it
when I do interviews you know how people
ask me how have you not burnt out
already like so many people are burning
out on YouTube well it's not just
YouTube It's entrepreneurship people
burn out of Entrepreneurship not just
having a YouTube channel why do you burn
out of Entrepreneurship because you stop
actually liking it's too much of the
work that you're doing you don't like it
anymore
right there's too much of the work that
you're doing you might still love the
vision for where you're going if you
don't know the vision you got to get out
ASAP
but you might still love the vision but
you're just taking on too much activity
that you don't like doing anymore
so when I'm talking to somebody on their
podcast I like I like doing interviews
it makes me happy it brings me joy to
try to
hit somebody else's audience right they
try to spread believe to an even wider
net
and so if I'm talking to somebody say
well what is this work for you because
in talking to you this doesn't work for
me
this is fine
I'm Gonna Leave This interview with more
energy than I came in that's a sign that
you're doing the right thing so I like
this thank you you're you're giving me
you know I'm giving you content and
exposure for your channel but you're
giving me a gift because
this is fun you're giving me more energy
it doesn't feel like work
the second it starts to feel like work
you have to adjust and it might be it
might be a big adjustment maybe you
shouldn't be doing your business anymore
period because you just opportunity
hopping you don't actually love the
thing
or maybe you just need to make a minor
adjustment and realize okay this makes
sense as a strategy but it's just not
the right strategy for me I need to move
on and do something else even though it
works with some other people it's not me
I don't want to do it
so that's where we start transitioning
to working smart right so working hard
is you showing up every day working
towards your goals but that your purpose
means something to you and that the work
you do you actually enjoy and having fun
in they're working smart is then
figuring out
there's so many different ways to win
inside your industry there's so many
different ways to win there's so many
people who have won
and there's not just one path this is
where we get locked up is feeling like I
have to do it this way but you don't
actually love doing it that way
and the second you start taking things
on because you think it's the smart
thing to do but you have no interest in
doing it you will never win you will
never win doing work that you hate it's
not going to happen you will never win
doing work that you hate you'll say that
you'll do whatever it takes you won't
you'll quit you'll give up on it because
you don't like it
chasing the goal alone is not enough you
have to actually enjoy the process of
getting to the goal that the process
becomes more important than the goal
gives you more satisfaction and
happiness and pleasure than hitting the
goal how many times have you hit a goal
and then been disappointed after right
he's like oh what's next sometimes
borderline depression right
Ted Turner's dad had a goal to hit a
million dollars he did and then he
killed himself because he thought things
were going to change but he realized his
life was still the same
so having goals are really good and
important but more important than the
goal is the process of accomplishing the
goal you have to actually like the work
so how do you be smart well you have to
you have to do things that bring value
to people that you also enjoy
so in the course of my career on YouTube
at least said
got a bunch of great compliments
um the two that stand out in this
context are garyvee and Ed mylett where
garyvee said I'm the content DJ that
inspires people and said hey you watch
so many videos and then DJ it to inspire
people and Ed mylett said
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
that Napoleon Hills the the greatest
person in person development history and
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
now when they both sat down like
I'm still working on receiving
compliments so I was kind of Blown Away
by both of them and then I asked hey
well can I use that in my in my bio or
my profiles but what what I do is
I love I love modeling success you know
it's why I make all this content it's
why it's why I have all these people you
know behind me on the wall you know we
got we got Steve Jobs and apie janini
and my parents and Howard Schultz and
Kanye West like I love modeling success
and I want to share my own voice my own
thoughts my own opinions my own
learnings my own stories my own lessons
and somewhere in that mix is now Evan
Carmichael
where some people are if you look at
Gary or Ed or whoever else they're
they're just sharing their own thoughts
for the most part they might have guests
on the interviews they might
occasionally have a quote from somebody
else but it's it's their own views and
opinions
I never needed to be the guy you know I
like sharing other people's stuff I like
sharing what I learned from their story
and and I've reluctantly kind of stepped
forward to share my own I used to think
nobody would care about my story or
what I had to say or why would you care
about me when I'm showcasing Elon Musk
like who am I but people kept asking for
my story where I came from so I started
sharing it more and so in that mix
became Evan Carmichael that's how I'm
different than everybody else same thing
for you
know what do you love doing that then
can also bring value to other people and
what combinations of things can you
bring together instead of thinking I can
do this or I can do this in the mix is
your next great opportunity
when you can take two or three of your
interests and not do them as the or
right instead of thinking or you think
and
instead of or or you think and but not
three different businesses this is where
people get tripped up it's not three
different businesses it's one business
that does all three of those things
combined in a way that nobody else has
done it before
because nobody can replicate that
the thing that you love doing or the
things that you love doing smoosh
together that don't make sense for
anybody else is and that is how you're
going to end up winning that's how
you're going to win
[Music]
James alticher calls it idea sex so you
have one idea and another idea and they
have sex and it out comes your your
great idea
I like it
that's how you start working smart
so working hard as you take it in
working hard if you're not willing to
work hard you're just not ever going to
win period how do you work hard well you
actually have the life the works it
doesn't feel like work that Jerry
Seinfeld calls it the torture you can
endure that is torture for other people
but for you he's like this is I like
this this is fun this doesn't feel like
torture yeah if making the idea of
making 10 000 videos 12 000 videos
whatever
that would be torture for a lot of
people it's like okay that's cool I like
it let's go let's make another ten
thousand let's keep going and then
inside of that is what do you love doing
that can bring value to other people in
a way that only you can do it by mixing
some of the things your passions your
interests together that have never been
mixed before together in that unique way
that's how you're going to win instead
of saying that that's not practical
instead of saying that
um they're two different businesses
instead of saying nobody's gonna care no
no no that's how you're gonna win
you mix those things together
focus on how you can use that mix to
bring value to your customers
and now nobody can touch you for people
who say people message me and say hey
Evan this person is copying you this
person is also doing top 10 rules of
success this person is like I don't care
like I spend zero time thinking about
that because if you
are just trying to be Evan Carmichael
you're never going to be here from
Carmichael right the most you're going
to be is an Evan Carmichael Jr
instead of trying to be an Elvis
impersonator go make your own music
right so anybody who's just trying to
copy me I don't I don't care about it
it's the people who are creating new
Innovative things that I consider to be
the real competition
hard work is your ticket in
you have to love what you're doing that
allows you to keep going
then you have to figure out inside of
what you love how can you combine your
interests your passions your special
things that make you a special unique
Snowflake and bring value to people
and when you figure that out that's the
unique angle of working hard plus
working smart that won't even feel like
you're
working hard or even working that smart
you're just doing you
and helping people
and that's how you win that negative
voice inside your head that's telling
you that you suck and you can't do it
that's not your voice
that's not actually your voice that's
not you telling yourself that you suck
that voice was planted there that voice
was put there by somebody else in your
life and probably early on growing up
telling you that you can't do something
you were not born you didn't come out of
the womb and say I suck I can't do
anything no you're playing you're
experimenting you're finding Joy you're
laughing you're you're doing it and then
along the way people tell you that you
can't do it that you should stop that
you should quit that it's not gonna work
out that you can't do it and we've been
so conditioned around that that we take
it on and we think it's our voice
when you come up with an idea right
just Workshop this you come up with an
idea it's like I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I'm gonna write a book I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel I'm gonna launch his
business I'm going to whatever you come
with your your bucket list your your
dream life your vision boards you come
with a list of ideas things that you
think that you want to do things that
you
feel confident that you'd love to create
for yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day
it's not even telling our friends you
know I think we we blame our friends and
say wow we tell our friends and they're
going to be negative and and they they
crap on our idea and so we don't do it
well before that happens we crap on our
own ideas right you look at that list
the next day and say I can't do that I
who was I yesterday as a crazy person
that I used to be yesterday who thought
I could do that
it's ourselves telling ourselves that we
suck but the problem is we've taken on
that voice and we think that it's us
that's not your voice that is not your
voice telling you that you suck that is
somebody else's voice that was planted
in your head that has been conditioned
to be there that we're so used to being
there that we have taken on as our voice
it has become your identity but it was
not your voice it was put there it was a
seed that was planted that has been
grown over time and you need to rip that
weed out
that is not your voice
do not think that you suck
it's other people with low expectations
who hate their own lives who at some
point went and tried something that did
not work out for their life and now
nobody around them can have success
because it makes them look and feel bad
and so they spend their time ripping
other people down and apart
that's who planted that weed in your
head that might hit pretty hard I hope
it does because when that happened when
if you can actually
digest that
what ends up happening is you think oh
who whose voice is that who's whose
voice is in my head and that's great
awareness to know that it's not your
voice and then to identify whose voice
it is who told you these things who made
you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating
but then two do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life
if you don't want their life then you
definitely don't want their voice in
your head anymore hopefully that creates
an aha moment for you that starts to
actually shift things because
we've been so conditioned to listen to
that voice that we don't recognize that
we actually have a choice to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice
so that's step one step two then is
whatever you want more of in your life
you need to be surrounded by it more you
need to change the environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you where you are
and if you're watching this video I love
you thank you for being here you are
probably the happiest most optimistic
most positive most caring most pouring
into other people that's in your
environment if you think about you and
your friends and your family you're
you're the most optimistic person in
your family you're the most positive
person in your family you're the most
ambitious person in your family you're
the one who wants to care and serve the
most in your family right but
you know you're capable of way way more
right you know you can do way more than
what you're doing right now
and so you end up being this big fish in
a really tiny pond where you're serving
others and pouring into others and you
wish they could do more and that's
amazing don't stop caring for others but
you need more of a push yourself you
need to be around the people who are
doing things that you want to do on a
higher level
so the environment really matters in
your environment right now is is good
it's it's not terrible maybe it is
terrible but it's not great
most likely it's just good
and it keeps you stuck and it keeps you
in slow growth mode and it prevents you
from becoming the person that you
actually want to be
so how do you start to shift that will
you shift your environment
and you may say well Evan I don't know
people who are super accomplished and
are living the life that I want to live
I don't have any of those friends if I
did I wouldn't be still stuck here and I
hear you I get it so the fastest way to
do it isn't through actually trying to
make those friends it's
through what I call aspirational mentors
it's by watching videos like this you
may never meet me you may never meet Mel
Robbins you may never meet whoever your
heroes are but you can learn from it
through these videos whoever you want
more of whoever you you respect and
maybe you're even jealous of that they
can think that way and live that way be
around them more
look at who you subscribe to on YouTube
look at who you subscribe to and follow
on Instagram look at the books you read
in the podcast you listen to and the
shows that you watch are they from the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and give you hope inspiration
and courage to go Live Your Dream and if
not then switch it out
switch it out
if you are watching YouTube when you
just found that you you wasted the last
three hours of your life
it's not YouTube's fault
it's your fault
you're subscribed and watching the wrong
videos
because there's a lot of positivity out
there if you close a YouTube session you
feel worse about yourself then you
subscribe to the wrong channels if
you're watching this video and feel
worse about yourself one I sincerely
apologize and two you should unfollow me
and go follow somebody that that makes
you feel more hopeful and Alive because
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel hopeful alive bold
confident powerful things are possible
your life will change
but we need that external stimulus you
are a product of your environment you
have to have those people around you you
can have Elon Musk and Mel Robbins and
Tony Robbins and whoever pushing you
every day you can have them pushing you
every day
by consuming their content we just
happen to be enslaved
by
the things that are around us that we
haven't designed with intention that's
all you know YouTube the algorithm is so
addictive
so addictive you you get one video that
then takes you down another path and
another path and now all of a sudden
you've just watched three hours of
videos on something that doesn't make
your life better you don't actually
really care about you just got sucked
into the drama of a certain storyline
has that ever happened to you
remember I watched the Michael Jordan
tribute the last dance and I went to
research
one of the story lines of Scottie Pippen
and Michael Jordan to see kind of what
the 2022 updated version was and all of
a sudden I got down this Rabbit Hole of
Scottie Pippen versus Michael Jordan and
three hours later there's still other
videos to watch like what am I doing
this is a waste of time I don't even
care that much about these guys I
watched the last dance it was a great
documentary and and I learned from it
and I love the drive and tenacity and
hustle but I don't care about the drama
between Michael Jordan and Scottie
Pippen and so we will easily default
back into that Comfort mode and back
into consuming drama
you have to with intention try to bring
that back
so here's a grid
homework assignment go look at your
YouTube homepage and see what's being
recommended to you and how many of those
videos whether it's my Channel or other
channels how many of those how many
videos on your home page right now will
make you a better human will make you
feel more proud of yourself we'll make
you feeling hopeful confident courageous
ready to take some action on some of
your goals and how many of them are
drama how many of them are pure
entertainment how many of them you know
will lead to some giant rabbit hole that
you don't want to go down if you
actually set out your calendar and say
how do I want to spend my day with
intention how many of these videos would
actually lead you towards that path
right and for too many people it's it's
not a it's not a pretty picture
we're listening to the wrong people and
so you can change that
you know you could change that if we
Circle back you recognize that the
negative voice in your head is not your
voice it was planted there by somebody
else who hates their life and you don't
want their life
then you switch it to say okay well
whose life do I want and ultimately you
want your best version of your life but
to get there you're taking different
pieces from different people's lives
like oh I like how he does that and she
does that and and she does this and
you're pulling different people
different things from different people
and then you start to surround yourself
with that
and the shift doesn't happen overnight
but if you're constantly pouring these
people into you if you're constantly
pouring Evan Carmichael into you you're
gonna start to believe more on yourself
and if you're constantly pouring other
people into you you're gonna start
thinking like them behaving like them
taking on their mindsets and their
beliefs
and if those are beliefs that you want
and the mindset that you want amazing
you get to choose now
you're in control
you've been a product of your
environment your early environment with
negativity your ongoing environment with
probably just mediocrity keeping you
where you are and now you can change it
you can shift it you can decide to be in
a different spot one year from today
and the most important step you can do
is to start choosing and carefully
decide with intention who you want to be
around
so that in one year from now you are in
a different spot not just for you but so
you can serve others and lift them up to
catch up as well there is no work-life
balance there's just life
the fact that we are separating work
from life
I think is a big problem I think that's
why most people hate their life
because we don't see work as a part of
life your work is a part of life your
work should fuel your life your work
should give you purpose and meaning we
all want to wake up and feel like we
matter and we're going to do something
today in our work that's going to create
some kind of positive impact right on
the days when you wake up and you feel
like today is gonna matter I'm gonna
make something that is going to matter
to another human being maybe a million
people maybe one person but today is
gonna matter those are the days that you
love your life and you feel amazing and
you feel like you're contributing and
you feel like this is yes this is why I
do what I do
and on the days when you feel like it
doesn't matter nobody cares if you show
up you're not making anything meaningful
there is no contribution those are the
days where you hate your life
there is no work-like balance guys it's
just life
when I'm on podcasts and people ask me
this question like what does work-life
balance mean to you or they ask me some
variation of it like how many hours a
day do you work or what is your work
calendar look like it's like well what
what's work to you is my usual response
now I'm sitting here on your show I'm
having a great time we're doing this
podcast together
is this work for you
like does this count as work because I
don't see this as work
this isn't work this is fun
this is fun for me this is my life I
like this when I see this podcast in my
calendar I'm excited by it I don't look
at it as work
making these videos I don't see it as
work that's why I've been able to stay
so consistent
right how do I not burn out it's another
question of gasoline how do you not burn
out how do you make so many videos how
do you not burn out
a lot of people burn out
no we're even close to the number of
videos that that I've done over
how many years 13 years
a lot of years guys it's been a lot of
years of showing up and making
over 10 000 videos crazy how why well
because it doesn't feel like work this
this is part of my life
it's a it's this is what a purposeful
life looks like if I saw it as work I
would have quit and given up
years ago I mean a decade plus ago there
are some pieces of
what I do that feels like work you know
doing accounting stuff feels like work I
hate that stuff doing administrative
stuff paperwork legal stuff that feels
like work I burn out very quickly I
don't want to spend I want to spend the
least amount of time as possible on that
I want to hire people I have a great
lawyer have a great accountant have a
great bookkeeper have people help me
with that stuff because I do not enjoy
it it feels like work and if my calendar
was just filled with that stuff I would
hate my life
so I I don't I don't believe in
work-life Balance I I reject the the
premise
of the entire question
it's just life
how do you want to spend your life and
this is one of the greatest things that
we have as entrepreneurs you get to
decide what your life is you get to pick
the business you go into you don't have
a boss besides the customers but you
still also get to pick which customers
that you work with
and your your work
should be something that is a source of
joy for you and a source of energy for
you because when you love what you're
doing every day it will bring you a lot
more happiness and satisfaction in your
life
so it's all just life
one of the great things I think that you
can do
is look at your calendar see what's
coming up in the next couple weeks
couple months and are you excited to buy
the things that are in your calendar
and I I put everything in my calendar I
love living by my calendar
um
I don't know if it's because I don't
remember what I'm doing you know
tomorrow or I'm so present focused that
I don't know what's I don't know what
I'm supposed to be doing tomorrow so I
have it in my calendar and it I think it
also reduces anxiety for me to know that
I've got days for things so making
videos I don't worry during the week
about making videos because I know on
Tuesday it's my video day and I'll get
it all done and if I get an idea for
video I'll email myself and I'll look at
that on Tuesday so it's in my calendar
so I have I have a spot for everything
so I'm not constantly worried before I
had a calendar I'd be worried and
anxious about oh what am I going to get
this done when do I have time to do this
and that would stress me out we're now
like okay I know I'm I'm gonna do that
on Tuesday when am I going to have time
to Mentor my team okay I'm gonna all
right Monday we're gonna time to have
you know
um clean up the condo and and do grocery
shopping whatever okay that's Sunday
right so it's all in the calendar so
at least for me having a calendar has
been life-changing
but what ends up happening is we we
don't put everything in our calendar we
just put our meetings in our calendar
where I put everything I put I put time
with Nina my calendar time with my son
and my calendar uh time
playing League of Legends and Minecraft
is in my calendar you know stuff is it's
in my calendar so I have I have time to
get everything I want out of life done
you have time
this this reason I've I don't have time
like if if I was to step into your life
and see what you were doing every day
there's a lot of wasted time
it's a lot of unintentional time
so the whole idea of having a calendar
is to be more intentional be more
intentional with how you're spending
your time
and if you do that then
you can look at your week ahead your
month ahead and are you excited this is
all life right forget where like balance
is all life so you look at your life
what's in your calendar are you excited
by the things that are in there
are you excited by the projects you're
working on are you excited by the people
you're going to be connecting with are
you excited by the amount of time you're
spending just to yourself whether that's
meditation or yoga or working out or
swimming or walking or whatever are you
spending enough time just for you
are you excited about the life that is
in your calendar and if not then change
it what are we doing here this is why
you became an entrepreneur
if you want to live somebody else's
version of your life go get a job where
you're told what to do you're told when
to show up you're told what you have to
work on that's that's a job that's why
most people hate their lives because
they're being told what to do constantly
all the time they have no freedom
if you want to be an entrepreneur and
have ultimate freedom
then let's take control of our calendar
because we're not most entrepreneurs
that I meet are feel out of control
are wasting a ton of time feel like
they're not spending their time being
intentional know they're capable of so
much more know they can be a lot more
efficient a lot more productive a lot
more purposeful
with how they're spending their time
so if there's nothing in your calendar
that's exciting you
then you you do not like your life
because your calendar is reflection of
how you're spending your life
so change it now maybe that's a drastic
change
or maybe that's a minor change
and this is an ongoing evolution
whenever I feel
unhappy uh not like depressed because
that doesn't really happen but when I'm
feeling
when I'm feeling that the Energy's off
probably a better way to put it whenever
I feel like the energy is off for one
day not the end of the world right for
one day
just go do the thing that's in your
calendar because you said you were going
to do it right but if this happening for
a couple days in a row or if it's
happening for Tuesdays is my filming day
for example if I had two or three
Tuesdays in a row where I feel the
energy is really off
and I'm not enjoying making videos
then I need to Pivot and it's either I
need to
make different kinds of videos
or I need you to stop making videos
that may happen I'm willing to drop
things if it doesn't bring me joy
anymore
and we as humans stay in things for far
too long like there are things that
you're holding on to that you should
have dropped maybe years ago and you're
still doing it why because it's a habit
a routine or or it's sunk cost like you
had this goal five years ago that
doesn't even matter to you anymore but
you've built your self-identity around
it be willing to let go of things sooner
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate
and so there may come a day where I just
dropped my YouTube channel all of them
because it doesn't fill me with joy
anymore now I don't think that's gonna
happen anytime soon because I still love
doing this stuff
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there the key to experimenting is
expecting to suck just expect to suck
expect it not to work out expect it to
be a total disaster expect to suck
which gives yourself the permission to
go and try we're holding ourselves back
from trying because you may not expect
to be great we'd expect to be pretty
good I think this is a problem for a lot
of entrepreneurs is you have an idea you
have a dream you don't think you're
going to be the next Jeff Bezos maybe
yes but maybe no you're gonna make your
own YouTube channel you're not going to
be great on camera but you expect to be
pretty good
you know you don't expect to be Bezos
but you expect to be pretty good in your
business and what ends up happening is
you start and you realize oh my gosh I'm
not only
not Bezos level I'm I'm terrible
I see it all the time people who are
starting their YouTube channels they
don't expect to be terrible on camera
they don't expect to be whoever you
think is a great on-camera personality
and then they record themselves and if
they thought they'd be like an 8 out of
10 they don't expect to be 10 they think
they'd be eight
and then they watch it back like oh my
gosh I'm a two
I'm a two out of ten and then they stop
and they never release the video they
never try the next thing because they're
convinced that they just suck that they
suck as a human
and that they'll never get the skills
well how do you get the skills by
practicing by doing just because you
were two out of 10 now doesn't mean you
can't become an eight or a nine or a 10.
how do you get there how do you go from
a two to an eight or nine or ten at the
thing that you want to be great at by
practicing by learning by doing not just
by researching and studying it and
watching other people you have to get
into the trenches and start to create
and start to make that's how you move
but people are too afraid to fail that
they don't even try
you're so afraid to fail that you don't
even try
and the way through it is expecting to
suck
I am right now learning about nfts
and now I know enough to be dangerous
about nfts but two months ago I didn't I
knew nothing I didn't know what it's
what it stood for non-fungible I don't
even know what a fungible token not
until I nothing made sense I didn't
understand what wag me meant I didn't
understand what lfg meant I didn't
understand what hoddle meant I didn't
know the difference between Bitcoin or
ethereum I didn't know what a metamask
wallet was all of this stuff zero idea
and the more I I just looked at it from
the outside the more I got
stressed out confused overwhelmed I
don't understand any of this stuff I
feel like a total beginner and so I'm
not going to learn it
and I want to be the person who jumps on
things who learns things it doesn't
accept scary difficult or hard as good
enough reasons for me not to do it so I
dove in
and I asked all of those stupid
questions and I learned not just by
reading about it but by launching my own
nft projects putting it out there and
starting to work with people I went into
the different discords and Twitter I
didn't even know what Discord was I
wasn't using Discord
nft land is Discord and Twitter I had to
install Discord and get active on it I
had to reignite my Twitter account like
you guys use Twitter I haven't used
Twitter for years but Twitter is where
the game is at so I'm picking up my
Twitter game again and I'm asking what
seems to be stupid questions I'm asking
all the beginner questions and I'm
launching my own nft project to learn to
understand and now I know enough to be
dangerous I'm not an expert at it but I
know enough to be dangerous
and that happened in a relatively short
amount of time because I was willing to
experiment and I was willing to expect a
sec at the beginning I'm gonna go in be
a total Noob right total total newbie
total beginner ask the questions and
then I'm gonna learn through that
process and get better at it you can
surprise yourself with how much you can
learn
learn at the beginning if you're just
willing to detach yourself that just
because you suck at a skill doesn't mean
that you suck as a human
this is where we get stuck it's like oh
I suck at that therefore I suck and I'm
never gonna get better so I'm going to
stop and go do something else that makes
me feel good
and said to know I suck at this skill
and I feel good for trying and I'm going
to keep getting better at this so that I
can I can improve my skill from a two to
a two and a half to three to a five to
an eight to a ten right
so how do we start to do it how do we
start to give ourselves more permission
to experiment give ourselves permission
to fail give ourselves permission to
suck how do we do it
step number one trust your ideas
trusted the ideas that come to you are
good trusted that idea that you're
thinking about right now is good just do
a quick gut check is are you trying to
rip people off are you trying to serve
and try to help are you trying to just
take their money put in your bank
account and go buy your boat or you're
trying to actually do some good right if
you're watching this channel hopefully
you're in the second category you're
trying to serve you're trying to help
you're trying to create something of
value so if that is your intention then
trust your ideas stop holding yourself
back stop saying that you can't do it
stop finding all the reasons in your
head that you cannot take action because
your Heroes have done more with less
than what you already have right now
whoever your heroes are whoever you look
up to Jeff Bezos whoever Oprah Winfrey
whoever they started with less than what
you have right now they could do it you
can do it too you can
so if the idea is a good one it's it's
it's it feels right it's heart Centric
you want to serve you want to bring
value to people then trust that idea
trust it step number two immediate
action
immediate immediate immediate action the
problem is we get stuck in overthinking
over planning over preparing over
strategizing over asking other people
well what do you think I should do stop
that immediate action what's the first
thing that you can do
if you want to get an nfts go join
somebody's Discord go launch your own
single nft you're going to make tons of
mistakes perfect launch it you want to
launch a podcast great start your
podcast today you want to create a
YouTube channel awesome pull out your
phone record your video You're a
YouTuber now right you want to launch a
fashion business perfect create a logo
make a t-shirt like just start
it doesn't have to be anything great
just start the biggest thing for most
people that's missing is just momentum
it's all of these things stuck in your
head and not enough being created in the
world
and to get all this organized and
structured and actually making sense you
have to actually put something out
so trust your ideas that they're good
that they're of value that they're they
will serve and then set number two is do
something about it immediate in the
moment action let's go stop overthinking
it and today something has to happen and
then step number three is just expect to
suck expect to suck expect it not to
work out expect not to make money on
this expect no comments no replies no
feedback expect to to just fail expect
it to be a total failure if you expect
that going in then you're not
you're not surprised when it doesn't
work out and you're not taking it
personally that you tried this thing and
nobody cares about it right now
you're lowering the burden for what has
to happen for you to feel good about
yourself
if you only feel good when you win then
you will never try
if you will only take
a yes and enter that competition enter
that race or do that thing if you know
that you're gonna win you will never try
you you will stay stuck doing the easy
stuff for the rest of your life and
never accomplish what you're capable of
never hit anywhere close to your
potential
so you have to expect it just to suck
and again by it's sucking by getting a
sucky result
it actually means that you're amazing
doesn't mean that you suck as a human
you only suck as a human is if you don't
try
to reward yourself for trying
search reward yourself for the effort
so to reward yourself for doing the
things that are outside your comfort
zone that are scary for you scary
difficult hard right you think of that
you're doing it and then you reward
yourself saying man I did that I can't
believe I did that was crazy
even though I didn't work out because
you know that if you kept trying and
kept learning kept improving
that it of course is going to work out
you just have to show up with that level
of energy and enthusiasm and intent
every day
the difference between where you are
right now where you want to be is how
many experiments you're putting out
there
how many ideas that you've got that
you're trying
because you will not be rewarded for the
ideas that stay stuck in your head more
importantly you don't want to get to the
end of your life and look back and say I
had all these ideas but I was too afraid
of failing that I never tried any of
them
Wayne Dyer says don't let that song Die
within you
got to play the song while you're alive
you've got a great song in you
let's get it out to the world to get
great at anything you have to be
consistent right you know for anything
any any skill that you want to develop
you have to be consistent on at the
beginning of a journey it's okay to
experiment and taste and test and try
and do a bunch of things you know I made
my first video and I wasn't like the
next day making another video in the
next day making another video or it
wasn't consistent at the beginning and
my growth reflected it you know in year
one I post on my website where I'm at
with subscriber count year by year by
year and year one is like 25 subscribers
and by year five in my fifth year I'm
still at 700 something subscribers you
know it's not like I took off and was
blowing up right away a lot of it was me
sucking and not having the skill but a
lot of it was just lack of consistency
as well and that I wasn't doing it every
day and because I wasn't doing every day
I wasn't gaining the skill to actually
get better at the thing there's a reason
why from all the people I've studied the
number one rule for Success that they
have is you have to love what you do you
know love the process not just the end
result of the thing that you're doing
but you have to love the actual thing
that you're doing it just takes so much
effort and so much time to get world
class at the thing that if you don't
love it you're gonna quit you kind of
have to be crazy doing it because you
just love it so much for most people
with quit that's how you end up winning
and so finding the thing that you love
to do that you can stay consistent on so
that doesn't feel like work is the thing
that ends up
getting you through it like if you're
hosting a podcast show like this
and you don't like interviewing people
do something else right like there's no
point in doing this you have to actually
like doing interviews and talking to
people and pulling questions out of them
and getting insights and if you don't
cool don't do it because podcasting is a
hot Trend go do something else that you
really love to do we've made over 13 000
videos now in 13 years I made videos
through tragedy and Trauma and the
broken neck and divorce and all sorts of
like terrible things that have happened
and videos still went up why because I
love what I'm doing
and that's how I wasn't
burning out and if I stop liking making
videos then I'll move on to something
else so the consistency really matters
but it's a lot easier to stay consistent
on the thing that you actually love
doing I think everybody has the single
most important core value
and when you figure out what that is it
allows you to live a more intentional
life so like even if you had to pick
what's your most important core value oh
man Integrity it's a big one just being
a green period
I mean I mean that makes sense knowing
you and so now when you're looking at
you know who do I whether it's in a
relationship with somebody or you're
bringing on team if you're gonna if
you're gonna bring on a new video editor
for your team what most people do is
just think do they have the skills that
I need where for you that's not enough
they have to they have to be a person of
Integrity big time and when you're
around people of Integrity it just
allows everything to to flow more right
where you had the greatest video editor
of all time but they're they're cutting
Corners in line or whatever it's not
just about the results like how they get
it really matters to you and so it
changes the intentions which you show up
so if you're going to do a job posting
now for a video editor it's like you
post a video editor who believes in
integrity like and that's the title and
some people will see that and say that's
the stupidest thing of all time who is
this guy like cool like don't apply
right like
self-eliminate thank you and others
would be like yes finally somebody's
speaking my language and so I think
everybody has a single most important
core value
and it's the job of finding out what
that is for you and so for me it's
believe and that becomes the brand and
that like a brand is just an emotion so
I want people to leave everything that I
make with more belief I may not
accomplish it but it's the intention in
everything that I make and so if you
could gift Integrity To The World what a
great what a great gift to be able to
create I like it
um
let's go here YouTube is is an education
platform like I think a lot of people
think of it as as entertainment and fun
and movies and music cool but YouTube is
is the number one education platform so
you know people are trying to figure out
how to become a more influential leader
where are they going to go they're going
to go to the library yeah who are they
going to talk to they're going to talk
to their mom like what they're going to
go and search in your stuff will pop up
and not just your videos but against
other people's videos this content that
people are going there to learn and so
YouTube is different than every other
platform
where we want to be making long-form
content teaching people because ahead of
whatever we're trying to sell we want to
put information we want to put education
okay we're teaching people at scale to
then bring them into whatever the thing
is that we're selling coaching products
program Services books Etc and the
beauty of something like YouTube is one
you're you're contentless forever so the
videos you make now in a year and two
years and six years are still getting
your views subscribers attention leads
Etc where every other platform it goes
away right like Instagram nobody cares
what you posted a week ago it's instant
it's Instagram it's gone every other
platform's the same YouTube has the best
monetization so they'll pay you right
like you could be making seven figures
just from the ad revenue on your videos
as well as actually building your
business
um and the best part about YouTube is
you can take the content since it's long
form and splice it up to put in all the
other platforms so YouTube will tell you
the best moments in every video
according to what the audience cared
about those little highlight moments you
can then tweak and put them to Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook and all the
other platforms so all you really have
to do is have a Regular Show long form
on YouTube and now we're creating
content everywhere most of the people
listening watching your goal is not to
be a full-time just content creator you
got a business that you're trying to run
we're trying to build our membership
groups and our coaching services and be
a speaker and all of that stuff and so
you don't have time to all day every day
be on every single platform you don't
have to be long form from YouTube take
the data cut it up to be on every
platform so it kind of sits above all
the other social media platforms and
most importantly to help people's
message get out to change the world I
used to struggle a lot with manifesting
just the idea of it I would watch videos
on it and I didn't understand what they
were saying I didn't I just didn't
understand it uh what was manifesting a
lot of attractions like what are they
saying I don't understand the words that
are coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind it and watch again it's like I
don't get it I don't understand I don't
I don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
color of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything the potential to
the dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
we'll choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house now I'm
paying attention to the for sale sign
you ever notice when you buy a car you
start seeing that car everywhere right
or even thinking about buying a car
you're thinking about buying an X you
start seeing it on the street more often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth are
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as they came up with an idea
it's like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that you can
never plan all the way out there's no
way you know if you wait to have the
perfect plan by the time you start
actually executing the plan is is dead
it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you show cut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then
but when when you're positive and
optimistic and bold and courageous and
an idea comes to you trust that that's
the right idea for you just trust it
it's erratic and then go do something
about it where normally what we do is we
overthink and we over plan we over
prepare and then we lose the momentum
and then the next day and the next week
or the next month it's gone it's over
it's like oh I can't do that no that was
actually a great idea for you and it's
happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically but I just decide to listen to
it and do something on it and it leads
to something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car when you buy
your new car you see that car everywhere
and then number two is trust a good
ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
Attraction people talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
[Music]
I'm that big
but to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but but look I've got I've got a belly
or I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm
I am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too I
think the key to overcoming your fear is
the awareness of the fear I think most
people aren't even aware of their
biggest fears that are holding them back
on a daily basis in their business and
in their lives what often happens is
somebody gives you an opportunity right
come speak at this event or here's this
project and work with this person or go
on this date whatever it is you get an
opportunity and the real fear you have
is that you're not good enough that
you're gonna fail that you're not going
to give a good result that's really the
fear deep down inside but you come up
with I don't have the time to do it I
don't have the time to do it as the
biggest BS excuse of all time you may
not be making the priority to go out and
do it but we all have the same amount of
time you should never say I don't have
the time you can say I choose not to do
it I choose not to make the time but as
soon as you say I don't have the time
you abdicate responsibility you are in
control you get to pick what you do with
your 24 hours every day it's the one
thing that is equal across every human
being we all have 24 hours so we
disguise our real fear with some
practical reason right we say we don't
have the time we don't have the
resources blah blah blah whatever it is
but really it's some kind of fear and I
think I think that's the case for a lot
of people so many of our fears are so
subconscious and we're so we do it so
automatically every single day and we've
convinced ourselves that there's a
logical reason behind it so the first
step in my mind is the awareness of the
fear the awareness that it's not a lack
of resources the awareness has not a
lack of time
and it's really that I'm just afraid
that I'm gonna fail and I don't want to
do it anymore so awareness of the fear
is the first thing next thing is do you
have a why to get out of it is it
important to break that thing is it
important to crush through that fear do
you have a strong enough reason to make
a painful change and when you do the
third step is to start to catch it and
you often can't catch it in the moment
usually comes afterwards usually you're
meeting with somebody and you do the
same thing that you always do and you
don't catch it in the moment you catch
it the next day the guy I did it again I
did it I should have said that I should
have done that and I didn't I did it
again
succumb to my fear again and when you
have that awareness what you'll find is
the awareness starts getting closer and
closer and closer and closer to the
moment where it's actually happening
so you started off and it's like the
next day when you realize it and then
next time with maybe a couple hours
later next time is a couple minutes
later and then you get to that magical
moment that magical moment where you've
caught yourself just before you take the
action
you're meeting with somebody and they're
giving you a project and you're about to
back away the words are about to come
out of your mouth it's about to happen
again the same pattern that you've
always done forever and ever is about to
come out again and you have that magical
moment to catch yourself
and choose to be bold to overcome the
fear to push through it and take a
separate action instead of going the
same path you always go
swerve and go this way and when you do
that it gives you the muscle to do it
again and every time you get to that
point it's going to become easier and
easier and easier and easier and easier
so one for me is understand what your
real fear is I think we have the
awareness to have a strong enough why to
get out of it and then three get closer
and closer and closer to the moment
where it's happening and then choose to
be bold choose to be powerful and choose
to push through your fear you're not
changing because you're trying to do
everything yourself you're trying to do
it all alone you can have a moment of
inspiration moment of this is the day
I'm gonna change it all and then when
your environment and people around you
don't support you in doing it and you're
doing it all alone you lose momentum the
next day that momentum is gone and the
next day the momentum is is absolutely
zero have you ever you ever been there
until you get the people around you to
support you to create a circle where you
can feel like you do not have to do this
alone own
you won't change and you'll stay stuck
knowing that you're capable of more
and frustrated with yourself with the
lack of momentum I run this challenge
inside my movement makers program and
every month we have to talk about a
certain topic movement makers is For
Thought leaders it's people who are they
have a message they have a mission they
want to get out to the world your story
matters let's get it out there and go
come on
but it's really hard to share your story
and it's really hard to make videos and
it's really hard to put yourself out
there and you have these moments where
you want to do it and you feel on top of
the world like yes I'm ready and then
and then what then all the insecurities
and fears and doubts creep in and
as I was noticing people and Movie
Makers not making enough content I
decided to do a challenge and the
challenge is once a month we pick a
topic
and this month's topic is courage
and what you have to do is make a solo
video that's 10 minutes long you have to
make a lead magnet to help grow your
business and you have to do three
collaboration videos and most people do
Instagram lives they collaborate with
each other and all of a sudden
people who took up the challenge started
making content all of a sudden the
excuses went away the I don't know what
gear to buy I don't know what camera to
use I don't know what microphone I don't
know what to talk about my story is not
good enough I'll start next week I'll
start next year I'll start next month
I'll start at my birthday I'll start on
January 1st I'll start on Monday I'll
start I'll start next month right all of
the all of the excuses all of a sudden
went away
because you're not doing it alone
because all of those reasons that are
holding people back that are holding you
back you want to do something bigger
all of the reasons that are actually
holding you back are not The Logical
ones that are in your head
right the idea that you're not making
content because you don't know what
phone to use or what camera to use or
what I'm sit I'm making these videos for
my channel on my phone I'm I'm in my car
at my wife's acupuncturist she's getting
acupuncture done right now in the
building right next to me and so I'm
making content in my car you can too
right they're logical reasons why you
are not doing a thing that you want to
do right that you say is important to
you there's logical reasons that you are
buying
you you've you've you believe them they
are actual reasons but they're not good
enough reasons and underneath those
reasons why you're not doing the thing
that you need to do is just that you're
afraid
it's just fear
and suffering through fear alone
is really really hard it's not that it's
not possible it's not that you can't do
it it's just immensely difficult and
most people won't most people won't
follow through most people don't follow
through because they are alone
in this journey you might have people
around you you might you might have
great parents friends a spouse
but if you feel like you're walking the
journey all by yourself
it's just insanely difficult to actually
follow through and get the results that
you want
the good news is you can change it right
the good news is hey we don't have to
stay stuck the good news is you can
change your circle and I'm going to
share a couple ideas in this video of
how to do it so
number one
I like to collect good people
collect good people think about the
people around you in your life how many
of them make you feel happier more
energetic more positive and you may not
have many people you know there you may
not have someone like that
great
think about the people who you've ever
met
maybe it was at a conference maybe an
event maybe a lunch or dinner some kind
of party a friend of a friend
I
find ways to spend more time with good
people I remind myself that I like to
collect good people and as someone who's
shy and introverted
that's that's
not my default state
I don't think to call people I don't
think the message people I don't I don't
um default to being around people but
when there's somebody whose energy I
really love and I leave the conversation
feeling more uplifted than when I went
in
then I I try to find ways to spend more
time with that person and maybe it leads
to a business maybe it leads to some
kind of opportunity maybe just leads to
another conversation but think about the
people who you have met at some point in
your life maybe not the people around
you right now but an old high school
friend or again somebody at an event or
a club or some meeting that you met that
you really like their energy and their
Vibe I'll lean in on the awkward and say
hey do you want to go grab a coffee I'd
love to learn more about your story
or I really love your energy
do you want to go and get some lunch
together
it feels super awkward but chances are
they need somebody too
and if you be the first one to do the
Outreach and say hey I'd love to learn
more about you see the people who you
don't really know that well but you'd
like to
and you can even say that when you're
talking to them hey I don't really know
you that well but I'd like to
and lean in on the awkwardness be the
first one to go off and do it so so
think about the people in your network
people who you have met one-offs
meetings
who filled you with that positivity and
and fight for more time with them
because if you had four people
and you met everybody once a month
that's once a week now you're meeting
some amazing human
whether it's coffee whether it's lunch
whether it's a zoom call whether it's
actually performing some kind of
business together there are people who
you've come across who
are the support that you need and you
need to do the Outreach to say hey I'd
like to get to know you a little bit
better and spend a little more time with
you
leaning on the awkwardness collect good
people that's number one two is is
change your environment to be around the
people even if you can't meet them so
watching this video is a great example
watch this video did you wake up this
morning and you're like yeah my gosh so
amazing let's go crush the day
probably not right I didn't if you if if
you did then I am super jealous of you
if I woke up and you're tired and you're
looking at your phone and what's on my
calendar for today and immediately some
of the limiting beliefs and thoughts and
attitudes uh popped in your head and so
if you can't be around the people every
day you know collect good people if you
can't be around them every day then
you can be around them virtually
through videos through YouTube through
books through uh social media follow the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and make you want to go off and
Conquer your goals most of the time when
people are spending time on social media
YouTube Instagram Etc
how much of that time is spent actually
learning and being inspired versus
wasting time
how many times have you opened your
phone went to a social media app and all
of a sudden 40 minutes went by you
didn't even notice because you're just
scrolling scrolling scrolling scrolling
right has that happened
that's that's that's not what you want
to do
don't lean in on that right
audit right now audit who you are
subscribed to on YouTube and who you're
following on Instagram and ask yourself
do these people make me feel better
about myself or not
do I leave feeling more inspired than
when I came in and if no then unfollow
those people and good news is lots of
amazing people not just me there's tons
of amazing people who are making amazing
content
and whatever you want to learn whatever
you want to get more into
when you can surround yourself even in a
social media environment if you wanted
to work out more if you followed a whole
bunch of Fitness people people who are
working out constantly people who are
not you're making excuses for why they
can't get to the gym today if you
followed all those people it's now in
your environment you'll start to see it
more often it'll become it'll become
that daily reminder for you and you're
more likely to go to the gym and work
out so whatever you want to be whoever
you want to be whatever your goals are
choose to follow the people who are
achieving those goals who are living
that because it's not your identity yet
and for them it is and the more you're
around that they will suck you in to be
like them so choose very carefully what
you want to get sucked into right it can
also lead down a really negative dark
path right whoever is more confident in
their beliefs win so if you're around
people who are strongly believing in
something that is that is bad or evil or
you know against your core values you
know you could be sucked down a really
dark negative hole as well so Step One
is collect good people step two is to be
around them be around in social media
with intention the people who make you
feel better about yourself and and go
achieve your goals and the step three is
to join some kind of community join some
kind of group uh who are focused in on
on what you're trying to do so if you
want to
if you want to get into fitness then you
you can hire a coach to help your
fitness trainer or join a gym or join
some kind of collective where you feel
like you don't have to do this by
yourself why movement makers is so
special is because if you want to be a
thought leader where do you go where do
you go to hang out with other thought
leaders
right nowhere do you know anybody who's
a thought leader is trying to make great
content and share it and have a message
to give to the world you know who who
else that you know in your life talks
like that probably not right so being
around that and and whatever it is that
you want to learn you want to be better
at chess then join a chess club and hire
a chess coach be around the people
be around the people join some kind of
community so you don't have to do this
all alone one of the things that I
struggled the most with is feeling like
I have to come up with all the ideas
myself carrying everything on my back
and what I realized
varied later in my entrepreneurial
Journey right I mean I'm I'm
what I'm 40 how old am I now 40 I'm
almost 42 when I'm filming this video my
first Real Business and Entrepreneurship
when I was 19 so it's been a while you
know 20 plus years of being an
entrepreneur
uh not including like garage sales and
that kind of stuff and one of the
hardest things for me was just not
trying to have to do everything myself
not putting all the pressure on myself
to have to do everything everything
everything all by myself
I like the same movement makers that one
plus one equals four thousand you know
like you come in
and not just movement makers but any
anytime you do this any any club you
join or group you join especially if
you're a giver givers have a hard time
asking but when you're with other givers
they want to pour into you they want to
give to you they want to see you win as
well so you come in hoping to get
something and then when you get that
plus you can contribute to other people
and what they're doing and see that
you're showing up for them also allows
them to go off and accomplish their
goals
it's just such a great cycle
and it's such a weight lifted to know
that you don't have to do everything all
by yourself
so you could be willing to change you
could have these great Ambitions and
great ideas of who you could be and who
you want to be and the impact that you
want to have
but it's not going to happen until you
realize that you can't do this alone
stop trying to do this alone stop trying
to do everything yourself
you can change people will support you
but it's on you to collect good people
to audit who you follow on social media
and to join a group of people who are
like-minded
if you want to make one single change
this year
that will have a tremendous impact on
the growth of you actually accomplishing
your goals decide to not do this alone
anymore the difference between you
hating and loving your life is
perspective as Marcus Aurelia said the
impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
that negative situation that you're
facing right now will Define you either
you succumb to it and you hate your life
forever or you rise above it and it
becomes the greatest blessing of all
time the choice is yours and I'm going
to show you how to conquer it so you may
have noticed that I have this armband on
this really colorful armband what's the
story I have this on as a reminder to
stay in a beautiful state it's a
reminder to myself every day now
naturally I'm pretty optimistic and
happy and positive and I've trained and
worked on myself to be even more
optimistic and happy and positive and
consume things that make me even more
happy and optimistic and positive but
there's still some times that I feel
negative there's still some times that
I'm not proud of myself the classic
example for me is when I get interrupted
if I'm working on something and I'm in
the zone and I'm focused and I'm
building momentum and somebody
interrupts me I can be really short I
can be really rude I'm not going to say
anything offensive or
something that I would regret but I
could be I could be short and rude and I
want to I want to change that I don't
want anything to knock me out of my
beautiful state at least that's my
ambition that's my intention that's my
goal if I can get closer to it I'll be
pumped it's the perspective shift and so
part of my daily routine is I put this
on I don't I don't sleep with this on uh
at night I'll take it off and then part
of my morning routine is I'll put this
on and and it's a reminder as I put it
on that I want to see in a beautiful
state today that I might get interrupted
but I want to be proud of how I deal
with it
and then I look at it every day it's
hard not to right it's not just some
little tiny you know wristband it's some
it's it's Giant and it's colorful and it
stands out and it's a reminder every day
as I'm typing I see it they're like oh
yeah yeah beautiful say let's go and
also something that when I'm talking to
people they'll ask me about it because
it's a conversation piece why am I doing
it right people are curious they want to
know and so every time somebody asks me
about it it's a chance to tell the story
again and in telling that story even now
as I'm telling this story it reinforces
for me this is why I have it on this is
why I'm doing what I'm doing and so
having some kind of trigger that brings
that up it really works for me I think
it could work for you as well George
Bernard Shaw famously said the
reasonable man adapts himself to the
world the unreasonable one persists in
trying to adapt the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
Unreasonable Man the entrepreneurs who
win are the unreasonable women and men
who are trying to make it difference
you're different you don't fit in stop
trying to instead make the world adapt
to you I want to tell you a story about
guanyu and his guandau
let me get my prop so this is a heavy
collapse from this
we good can we see okay good this is
guanyu guanyu is a legendary uh Chinese
General god of war and he was a huge man
in Chinese history he was huge by by
stature giant he was bigger than
everybody else that he was fighting
against so when he was getting started
in fighting when people gave him a
regular sword or staff or spear it was
so light for him it was too easy for him
because he was such a giant Beast of a
man and so instead of just taking the
tools that everybody else was using he
made his own weapon called the Guan Dao
it's this it's this crazy thing right
here it's this crazy you know staff with
a giant blade on the end of it guandau
nobody else could lift this thing
because it was so heavy but he had it
crafted for him because he could lift it
and it made him even more powerful than
everybody else because he had this giant
weapon that he was using in all of his
fights that's what I think entrepreneurs
need to do that's what you need to do
you are a genius you are Michael Jordan
that's Hilton you are go on you at
something the greatest fighter in China
at the time right that's you at
something
and for you to win
you need to have your own guandal you
need to craft your weapon craft your
business craft your habits craft your
activities craft the people around you
so that you can leverage what you're
naturally great at I make videos right I
love having my own message I love DJing
content
it's what I love doing
I can make four videos a day across my
channels because I have a team of people
who help create all of this stuff if it
was just me doing everything I would not
be making the content that I am
I built the business around me what I'm
great at what I love doing what I want
to continue to Excel and improve at you
need to find the same thing for you you
are a guanyu you are a Michael Jordan
it's time to embrace that and then
create something that hasn't been
created before that's what entrepreneurs
are doing create your guandal to let you
do what you're so good at at an even
higher level if you are the most
ambitious person that you know you are
going to play small for life look around
at your friends your family the people
that you hang out with what do they want
out of life if you're the one always
pushing them and no one's pushing you
guess what happens you don't get the
push that you need and you stay in
mediocrity being the best in a group of
unambitious people so I just came back
from an event in Florida that I was
doing a keynote at and at the end I
challenged an entrepreneur who showed up
to make some changes on this YouTube
channel we met over dinner I helped him
with his YouTube channel it was him and
his business partner sitting there and I
said by tomorrow here's what I want you
to do I want you to go in and make sure
you have these things updated and he
said yes I'll do it I said it's
important to do it by tomorrow because
I'm still here I'm still here in the
morning if you need anything you can ask
me face to face while I'm still here
before I fly home to Toronto yes I'll do
it next morning comes around
we show up in a meeting I gotta meet up
happening we got I don't know 30 people
who showed up to to meet with me and I
see him out of the corner of my eye
sitting at the back of the room and I
say hey did you do the thing that I told
you to do
they said no I didn't do it
I said why what happened
I said well we we were doing lots of
other stuff it's been a full day you
know we had this entire day of of
speaking and meeting people and then so
much information went home we were doing
all this kind of work
okay great but what about the promise
that you made to me to do it and then
his business partner chimes in and said
you know it's actually my fault I told
him Evan's probably not gonna notice
he's not gonna remember don't worry
about it we'll take care of it when we
all fly back home
and so I told him
don't let your business partners low
standards prevent you from moving
forward on the things that you said you
were gonna do
staying committed to the thing that you
say you're gonna do your word to
yourself is the whole game forget about
what you just say to other people what
do you do for yourself because we're
often looking for no's we're often
looking for somebody else to give us a
break right he's been working hard and
and he is and I know him and I know his
business partner and these guys are not
Slackers they're not Slackers and and I
was poking a little bit at his business
partner saying his low expectations his
low standards but in this situation it
was true
like entrepreneur that I was speaking to
said he was gonna do this thing by
tomorrow morning before he came and went
to my event he would do it
and his business partner says he's not
going to remember don't worry we've
worked too hard already let it go we'll
do it when we get home and they would do
it when they got home I know they would
he's looking for the reason not to do it
when you say you want to hit the gym
when you say you want to hit these
business goals when you say you want to
have this outcome and be proud of the
effort that you put in every day when
you say that you're gonna do something
there will be moments where you want to
let yourself off the hook where you say
I work it works hard I'm so tired or I
deserve a break right this is the
language you use to yourself and so when
that happens you're looking for
affirmations from the people around you
and if you are the most ambitious person
in your friend group if you are the most
ambitious person what's gonna happen
they're gonna say you already work so
hard anyway what are you talking about
yes of course give yourself the break
and it's the exact answer that you're
looking for because you want to give
yourself a break now if you're proud of
your effort maybe you should take a
break but it's not because somebody with
lower standards gave you the pass it's
because you're proud of the effort that
you put in and so this is where it gets
really dangerous when you are the most
successful the most ambitious person
from the people around you
they're always going to give you a
reason to play smaller
you can't accept it you have to push
through you need to change your
environment standing up has changed my
life not just standing up for myself and
standing up for what I might believe in
and the the standing up what is it it's
not the metaphysical the the the
theoretical I don't know but but
actually standing up like the physical
standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
setting up was probably
wow I don't know maybe maybe 20 years
ago 15 years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline could be underneath it and I
get 20 to 40 000 jumps a day on my
trampoline and went through three
trampolines last year because they broke
because most are not designed to be
jumped on that often but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found that when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients
I would be better when I was walking
around I don't know if it's a nervous
energy or what but when I sat down it
was
less energetic less less like let's go
do this thing and when I when I stood up
it was just I had more energy
you test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
fidget with my ring so my ring whenever
I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking I like walking around just
having something go and it helps me
think and process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss
again way back in the day and the the
test was not a full-on stand-up desk
because those barely existed but I took
my bookcase
and then cleared off the book and all
the books in the bookcase and I found
the shelf that was the kind of the best
height to put my laptop on and I just
tried standing there and I think this is
a good life hack not just for standing
up or not but just in general if you
want to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand-up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for to be
delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
the best thing to do is just start find
a small way to just get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase and the first
day I didn't last very long 20 minutes
40 minutes I it didn't last very long
when you're not used to standing up it
it's really hard it's like oh where I
need to sit down and after that first 20
or 40 minutes I got tired and I had to
sit down because my body wasn't used to
it but while I was standing up like I
really like this this is cool I have
more energy in just answering emails and
whatever else I was doing at the time I
had more energy so I'm gonna try it
again and that 20 minutes became 30
minutes became 40 became two hours
became four hours became six hours so
the point was like I could just stand up
all day long it became weird when people
came over to my office because there
were no chairs to sit down at so when
we're doing a meeting I'm standing up
and so they were standing up because
there were no chairs and it felt awkward
to have one person standing one person
sitting and then they start getting
tired because after 20 minutes of
standing up we got tired so I had to I
had to bring chairs back to my office to
host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had foot issues I
had uh things that you put in your in
your shoes what they're called not
implants uh customized Souls whatever I
was going to a car like in my 20s I was
doing a chiropractor almost every week
because my back was was a mess my knees
were were achy and cracking every time I
was walking like my body seemed to be
falling apart in my 20s I'm now 42 in
May I'm 42 and my body is in better
condition than I was in my 20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier
the move to a trampoline came because I
was I was already standing up for
at least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh backstage he
would always jump before he goes on
stage Tony jumps a couple times on his
rebounder rebounder's just a mini
trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what'd you have in your
backyard a rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go and so that's pretty
cool I wonder what he's spraying in his
mouth uh and I like the whole trampoline
thing if I'm already standing up why not
get a trampoline and try and so again
what's what's the easiest way to go off
and do it well I I went to my local
Walmart and I bought a rebounder and
brought it home and
had to adjust the height of my desk and
had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right but
whatever it's fine Lessons Learned right
you figure it out you think do is this
worth doing or not take the idea that
you've got and try because again the
biggest thing that most people are
missing is just momentum you're just not
trying you have this you've got this
idea and we spend our best energy
planning it and ideating and researching
and what's the perfect trampoline and
what's the perfect stand-up desk and you
spend all that energy researching and
then tomorrow you wake up the next week
you come back or the next month or
whatever like nothing has happened on it
still
if you've all these great intentions but
there's not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them
and so go get the stand-up desk by
creating boxes in your office
you know go get the cheapest trampoline
at Walmart and just jump on it and see
how it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore uh
we actually moved we just sold our place
we bought a new place and I moved uh
into one of the rooms as a temporary
place where we were showing our place
because my office backdrop doesn't is
not very conducive to selling the house
most people are not used to a stand-up
desk a giant stand-up desk and
trampoline and all that and so I took my
office down because when you're selling
a home you wanted to appeal to everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say sitting is the new smoking right so
try standing up and just give it a shot
and don't stress out if you get tired
after 20 minutes like I did the first
time through it's okay but do you have
more energy while you're working
while you're standing up and if so then
just keep going and just start with the
bookshave for some bookshelves uh or
some boxes whatever just to get started
and the second lesson is is just do
something just momentum imperfect action
the ideas that you have in your head are
great they're genius you need to do
something you need to stop putting the
gas pedal on the energy that's flowing
through you like greatness is flowing
through you and you're actively saying
stop stop stop do something find the
smallest possible way today today like
right now the smallest possible way to
take that awesome idea in your head and
build some momentum towards it
because the only thing you're missing
towards your great life is the momentum
I think we play small by default I think
man we are capable of so many amazing
things and we're constantly living in
fear and excuses and reasons why we
can't do something and we we have it
trained in us from a young age our
parents our family our friends our
teachers think about who did you learn
about life from probably people who
didn't like their own life you know who
did you learn about careers from
probably people who did not have a great
career you know who barely are enjoying
what they're doing in their work and
they're living in scarcity mindset of
this is all I can do and that's what
we've learned from and you know guidance
counselors at school do they love what
they're doing I mean I think this is a
huge problem and we're stuck living
small and living scared and living as a
result way below our potential of what
we could do and who we could help
I think it's a big problem I think lack
of belief is the world's number one
problems when I wake up every day trying
to do trying to help trying to create
and so how do you how do you get out of
it well I think the starting point is
being around the people who are living
and doing the things that you want to do
I think the way to 10x your results is
not to 10x your effort
sometimes it is especially at the very
beginning sometimes the answers just do
more work but once you're at your Max
Capacity you you get to a point where
you can't actually 10x your work anymore
it's changing your mindset it's getting
new leverages busting through limiting
beliefs because
just working harder will not be the
answer anymore right is it working
harder working smarter well it's both
right you have to working hard is is
your entry to the game
nobody wins without working hard in
anything you have to work hard but
there's lots of people who work hard who
who never accomplish their goals who
don't end up succeeding or winning
because they're not working smart so
it's a it's always a mix of both
and so if you're not working hard then
you don't have a shot but assuming you
are working hard and you want a 10x
again then it's a shift in mindset and
the shift in living beliefs so how do
you identify the living beliefs how do
you figure out where it's holding your
back how do you break through the
Paradigm and hit a new level a lot of it
is environmental you know the the
current thinking that you have was
environmental it's your parents and your
family and your guidance counselor and
teachers and family Etc that's
environmental you've adopted their
beliefs and unfortunately a lot of them
are
negative limiting beliefs there's
probably some that a lot that are very
positive but a lot of them you've
adopted that that actually don't serve
you anymore for what you're capable of
and where you want to go especially
what's possible now in today's
environment so the shift is in a new
environment to start to surround
yourself with the people who are like
the people who you want to be
who believe the thing that you want to
believe and whoever is more confident
wins and so if you're around people who
are deeply confident that the thing that
they're after is possible or they've
already gone and accomplished it if they
deeply believe it and you just kind of
don't believe it they'll pull you into
the land of belief because they they are
more confident in their belief than you
are in the disbelief and so it's finding
the people who are living the life that
you want or at least aggressively
chasing it down they will motivate you
inspire you to want to go and live your
life as well so well how do we do that
right I mean it'd be great to be able to
hang out with Warren Buffett and Elon
Musk and all these people uh every day
but you know we can't so how do you do
it well
step one I think is just through content
it's why I make so many videos on all of
my channels is why I've stayed
consistent over a decade of making
content why because
I think when you are around the people
even just visually even just through a
computer screen or a cell phone it
starts to shift your beliefs and your
mindset and what you can do even for me
I make these videos for myself so that I
can be around John Ashraf and Warren
buff and Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey Etc
because they inspire me to want to be
bigger looking at Elon Musk is an
example the news of the day right now as
I'm recording this video is he's looking
at buying Twitter and when somebody
asked me yesterday on Instagram do I
think Elon Musk will buy Twitter
said no I don't think you'll buy Twitter
but it's probably not a good idea to
underestimate Elon Musk
just in general right
you know lots of people have
underestimated him and he's proven them
wrong many many times and I just like
the thinking
you know one of the things I love about
Elon Musk is
whenever I watch his stuff it challenges
me to think bigger
why would Elon Musk it logically if
you're thinking through it if you're if
you were running Tesla uh in SpaceX
would you have thought about buying
Twitter
would that enter the realm of
possibility you know like this is the
difference between
small thinking and expansive thinking
like in his world it makes sense
and he wants to have a backup plan for
the planet whenever I think I'm thinking
big
Elon Musk is trying to have a backup
plan for the entire planet I realize I'm
still thinking way too small and the
point of that is not
um to beat yourself down like oh I'm not
as big a thinker or as Elon Musk right A
lot of people say comparison is a thief
of joy and a lot of people will
get off of social media because they're
comparing themselves to others I think
comparison can be a fantastic tool I
think it can be amazing because when you
are
running with
people who only make you feel good about
yourself but based off of their smaller
accomplishments then you stay stuck and
you stay a big fish in a small pond I
think competition is amazing but using
it in a positive way as opposed to
looking at someone like Elon Musk and
saying oh he's so much smarter than me
he thinks I'm much bigger than me I suck
I'm never going to be able to do that
look at this hey this is what's possible
there's not that big a gap between you
and Elon Musk it shows that it's
possible that you could do it too if you
can do it then you can do it
you came from South Africa and
immigrated to Canada then immigrated to
the United States he had a father who he
calls a Monster who beat him he had his
friends bully him and push him
downstairs at school like he had
he had all sorts of pain and Trauma and
struggles in his early life and he if he
can overcome that to get to where he's
at I see it as so can you and I see the
comparison as a opportunity that when
you see somebody else do something it
makes you feel a lot more confident that
you can do it too and so just use it in
a positive way instead of a negative way
so whenever I see someone like Elon Musk
it's a challenge to myself and looking
at him trying to buy Twitter it's like
huh what should I be doing you know it's
easy to get stuck in the same in the
same Groove
but the groove can also be a rut in that
you're getting slow growth and improving
where it could be a lot more expensive
it could be having exponential growth if
you change your environment to be around
the people who have expansive thinking
right so step one is just through
content through through aspirational
mentors what I call them an Elon Musk a
John Assaraf a Oprah Winfrey people who
who you may never meet but you can still
learn a heck of a lot from
step two is to then try to go to some
events that change up your environment
right if we're a product of our
environment then if you're always stuck
in the same habit the same house the
same routine the same environment then
it's going to constrict the thinking
have you ever noticed when you go on
vacation you come up with some great
ideas why well you've changed your
environment you've been influenced by
new things and it leads to more
expensive thinking so doesn't mean you
have to go take a vacation to the beach
or something this week but but what are
some changes you can make to your
environment what are some conferences or
events you can go to to be around the
people who think the way that you want
to think to inject some newness some
creativity some ideas into you that will
have you come back a stronger Bolder
more courageous person because you've
broken some of the chains of the rut
that you were in that things that used
to make sense like yeah that that that
makes sense for me to keep doing all of
a sudden you go away to a vacation a
competent event you come back I wanna
you ever gone away and come back and
wanted to be
a different person wanted to be working
on new projects new goals come with new
ideas I get ideas all the time when I'm
traveling just think about if you're
just constantly stuck it doesn't mean
you have to go travel on vacation it may
mean you take up salsa dancing it may
mean you try a new hobby take that idea
that you've got and just go go to it
look at any events that are happening in
your city meetup groups conferences
clubs so you can join and be part of to
meet new people and take on a new
interest and I promise you they may not
all work out in terms of this is my next
career move but it leads somewhere it's
a part of who you are you take the
learnings and the lessons from that and
it'll make you a better person a better
entrepreneur and you'll find a creative
way to mix things together I think if
Steve Jobs who started Apple who dropped
out of University because he wasn't
enjoying the classes and he dropped in
on calligraphy classes drawing like text
and letters for fonts which made no
sense like why are you dropping out of
this really practical school and
material to then sit in on calligraphy
when are you ever going to use
calligraphy it made no sense but he was
interested in it and what ended up
happening was when he's when he started
the apple and he created the Macintosh
it had the most fonts it wasn't just
boring computer fonts there were a bunch
of different fonts that he could use
that people could then use in their word
processing Etc and it was the most
beautiful uh computer at the time with
with unique fonts why people because he
pulled from his experience in his
calligraphy classes and how he describes
it is you can't connect the dots looking
forward to only backwards he didn't know
going to the calligraphy class that you
know what in five years I'm going to
start a company and I'm going to have
beautiful fonts as a part of it he was
just interested in calligraphy so he he
went to the class not knowing how it
ever working out but trusting that the
dots would at some point align in the
future right so looking back it makes
sense oh this and this and this all the
line to get me to where I'm at but he
wouldn't have known that unless he
dropped out of school and dropped in on
the calligraphy class so it's changing
the environments being a part of new
things it's it's not just staying stuck
in the same habit the same routines and
and same thing you're doing constantly
and that will inject newness that will
then allow you to be more creative and
create amazing opportunities for your
next goals so step one is to be around
aspirational mentors to be around the
people like an Elon Musk Oprah Winfrey
Etc watching videos content interviews
podcasts books that make you feel better
stronger more courageous step two is to
get out of your comfort zone and go go
to things physical things travel more
take take on classes say yes go to
conferences and events just so that you
expose yourself to new ideas and
opportunities and come up with fresher
ideas of what you could do with your
life and step three is to to actually
have humans in your life who you're
around who make you want to push and do
more and be better and this mean I hey
if you're hanging out with Elon Musk
amazing that's awesome you're probably
not doing that but who can you hang out
with who are on the same similar path as
you and that's where I love groups like
mover makers that I created for Thought
leaders but you know some Movie Maker is
something else but being around other
people who are doing the thing who
believe in this in the same thing if
you're if you're trying to run more join
our running club you're trying to work
out more you're going to join a gym if
you want to be a thought leader join
mover makers if you're like join a club
or a group where you can feel like
you're not doing this alone where you
can talk to people about the journey
that you're going on will they'll
understand you and not look at look at
you like you're some kind of alien like
your family or friends might like what
are you talking about what are you
getting into right join relevant Discord
groups like be a part of a community
because it's probably the biggest
mistake I made early on in my life I was
doing everything all by myself I had I
had business partners I guess but I felt
isolated felt alone I didn't have
friends had nobody to talk to and
I really really really struggled so find
other people who are on this journey
that you can do it with because when you
feel like you're doing it with other
people and you're not alone you'll be a
lot more productive a lot more effective
and have a lot more fun as well the only
thing you're missing is momentum this is
one of the most frustrating things with
entrepreneurs because you've got the
heart you've got the soul you've got the
desire to serve you know you're capable
of more you see these people doing great
things you say why why can't that be me
I've got everything I've got all the
tools why am I not having more success
when I see all these other people
winning because you don't have momentum
knowing alone is not enough watching
this video is not enough researching
going to conferences events it's not
enough it gives us this temporary high
it's so fun to think about where we
could be and what we could do when
living in dream mode of the things that
we want to create how That's so exciting
right but until you start actually doing
something and so you start going through
that little fear Zone to start actually
creating nothing happens and this is one
of the great missions of my life is
trying to get heart-centered
entrepreneurs with a cause you want to
serve and just getting you out of the
Starting Gate and then just help when
you stay consistent on the thing those
two things from idea to just doing
something and then finding a way to stay
consistent if you did that if you did
that's all you're missing if you did
that your life will be dramatically
different the people you're going to
serve the the amount of income you're
gonna make the life you can provide for
yourself and your family the the mass
massive just flow of goodness you're
going to create for the world will be
totally different you will be a totally
different person one year from today if
you did those simple things the only
thing you're missing is momentum the
only thing you're missing is momentum I
promise you
I look at
my YouTube channel and everything that
we've done here and man it took me so
long to get going it took me so long to
get out of my head it took me so long to
get comfortable making videos no matter
how much people told me just press
record and just do it I still was still
that voice inside my head is like well
I'm so awkward in front of the camera
and I don't know what I'm gonna say and
again I'm trying to memorize my script
and what camera should I find and all of
the things that we tell ourselves are
important that aren't
you know if you look at my growth on
YouTube the first five years was so slow
the first five years was so incredibly
slow because I started and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and convinced myself of why I
couldn't do it and my whole intent with
this is to try to shake you to say don't
waste five years like I did because in
the second five years that's when my
channel started to really blow up and
grow and that's when I started to see
the impact and see the growth and see
the see the the money coming in all of
it it started to take off because I just
started creating a lot more momentum I
stopped watching my videos and reminding
myself of how much I sucked and just
kept going
so how do you do it how do you start
building momentum how do you start
taking the thing that you know is inside
you that you know you're capable of more
that you don't want to be stuck in the
same spot one year from today it's like
I need to finally make something happen
right is that you are you ready for that
how do we actually start getting the
momentum in our lives I'm going to give
you three strategies okay
number one
your morning routine has to be on point
as I said in the top of this video
successful people don't wake up and say
yes oh my gosh what a day I'm gonna take
over this is gonna be amazing I woke up
and I was tired I don't remember what
day it is and I got lines in my face and
I'm struggling out of bed right
everybody wakes up the same way
don't judge yourself and feel like you
suck because you woke up and you were
tired and didn't feel super motivated to
go off and crush your day right that's
everybody that's me that's Brandon
bershard That's Tony Robbins it's Oprah
Winfrey everybody the difference is the
routine to set you up for success and
chances are if you watch this video you
already have a morning routine right
you're an achiever you have a morning
routine so I want to take this to the
next level for people with a morning
routine because your morning routine is
probably not working for you most of the
world doesn't have a morning routine
most of the world wakes up like an
accident most of the world wakes up
falls into their phone and starts
responding to other people's emergencies
right that's probably not you at least
not every day you might be 50 50 but you
probably have a morning routine
what's the value of a morning routine
the value of our morning routine
is to get you the feeling of bold
confidence and courage
that's why you haven't worn machine it's
supposed to help you go and win the day
if you don't feel confident both in
Courage at the end of your morning
routine then you've done something wrong
either the morning routine itself is
broken and you need to add something in
or you just didn't do it with enough
intent
most Achievers here's what's happening I
want you to do a fair self-assessment
and audit of your morning routine most
Achievers what you're doing is you have
your list of things that you're supposed
to do in the morning and you probably
hit those maybe 70 to 80 of the time
but most of the time of those 70 80 you
just check in the box
you said you're gonna do this okay I'm
gonna work out I'm gonna watch this
video I'm gonna read this book and
listen to this podcast so I'm going to
whatever but you're not intentional with
it having this video on was I created
the espresso channel here to try to
support you to try to be there for your
morning routine to give you a shot of
espresso every day to start your day
let's go but if you're watching this
video while you're making your bed and
brushing your teeth and and looking over
your email and browsing through social
media guess what happens
you're not getting the feeling
you could check the box and say yep
watch the video but if you don't feel
courageous and bold
you didn't do it with enough intent you
didn't do it with enough Focus you were
distracted all the way through and so
this is what happens with Achievers in
the morning routine is you check the box
for all the things you said you were
going to do but you don't feel any
better than you did when you woke up
and if you don't feel any better than
you did when you woke up you're not
going to go off and win the day
so the most important part of a morning
routine whether it takes you five
minutes or three hours
is getting the feeling so do an honest
self-assessment
do you feel bold at the end of your
morning routine and if not what you need
to add in there so that you do
or do you need to go back and just do
your morning routine with actual
intention because if you'd started your
day with the thing that made you feel
bold powerful Unstoppable confident your
life will dramatically change when
you're from today I promise you so
number one is you have to fix your
morning routine
number two to get more momentums how do
we get more momentum in our lives number
two
is to go from idea to action
start to teach yourself that you come up
with great ideas normally what happens
when you get an idea what happens
normally when you get an idea
we get excited maybe you tell your
friends about it your family or you're
just researching and planning and
brainstorming you get excited about it
and then what happens is this little
voice inside your head tells you all the
reasons why you can't do it you can't do
it because of this because of that
because you don't have the connections
of the money the skills or the education
the family or whatever there's always
some reason and so the combat that you
try to do more research and more
planning and more more understanding to
try to have the perfect plan and this
was me guys I lost a 40 million deal
when I was in my 20s because I was
trying to be too perfect because I was
afraid and all I really need to do is
get more momentum so you have to teach
yourself to go from idea to action when
you get that idea
trust that the idea came to you for a
reason trusted the intention is good is
the intention good is the intention to
serve is the intention to help yes
perfect action something today has to
happen today use your best energy on
creating some kind of momentum in
Perfect action versus trying to have the
perfect plan
and then you wake up tomorrow and you've
already talked yourself down you can't
do it so number one is you have to fix
your morning routine number two is you
have to go from idea to action and then
number three is to change your
environment
the more that you are around the people
who are doing the thing that you want to
do the more that that starts to seep
into YouTube
it's why I have so many channels
because there's always content hopefully
out there for you you might say yeah but
I don't know anybody Evan who's
successful I I can't hang out with
Brandon Bouchard or Oprah or whoever I
don't know these people great
I know Brandon but I know I don't know
Oprah
and I didn't know Brendan when I first
got started
how did I learn from the videos about
having videos around me every day having
these people on the wall behind me even
wearing this hoodie when I feel like
Batman putting it on every morning makes
a big difference to start to change your
environment to be around the people who
are thinking the way that you want to
think the people around you right now
are influencing you to stay where you
are
might think about the people who you
hang out with now that old expression if
you are the average of the five closest
people to you yeah great so who are the
five closest people to you they are
influencing your thinking and they're
keeping you stuck where you are right
now and if you love where you are right
now great but if you know you want to do
more then you have to start to change
what starts to influence you
consistently not these one-off moments
of inspiration and boldness but
consistency that's the thing that's
missing you might have this one day
that's amazing oh my gosh I can do
anything and what happens you wake up
tomorrow and all that energy is gone
it's a start and stop and start and stop
and start and stop that is holding you
back
so be strategic with your environment to
think about how do I start to surround
myself with the people with the videos
with the books with the podcast with the
physical environment that make me feel
like I can do more that you can do more
fix those three things fix your morning
routine go for my day to action and fix
your environment do that because the
only thing you're missing is momentum
the only thing you have you have the
heart you have the care you have the
desire to serve you have great ideas
inside you
other people are winning with inferior
ideas with less of a desire to serve
than you do and they're winning and the
only difference is they got started and
they're going
the only thing you're missing is
momentum
I can't wait to see you actually start
to apply it to make massive change in
your life and your business people don't
show up for one of three reasons number
one is you're afraid you afraid of
rejection you're a failure you're afraid
of it not working out and so you just
don't show up number two is you're not
consistent you show up some days but you
don't show up other days because you
don't have the routines and habits in
place to make you show up consistently
every single day and number three is you
don't want to you don't want to show up
because you don't actually enjoy the
thing that you're about to do you would
rather procrastinate on it because you
don't love it and showing up is more
painful than just sitting around so my
goal today with this video is to help
you bust through these so that you can
show up for life and have the impact
that you want to have so I think the
fear of showing up is actually a good
thing it means that you are doing
something different something outside
your comfort zone something that is that
is not normal that is new and that's
good you want to be pushing the envelope
if there was nothing that you are afraid
to show up to today tomorrow next week
then you're not growing you're not
learning you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones and so even
today I had to show up but and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating in on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel more across pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed for the people with a new idea
that I had so when the idea was first
suggested to me about doing us and
reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay
it's going to require an ask I might get
rejected it may not work out and I had
it scheduled for today because today was
my YouTube day and so I look at the list
today I'm like ah maybe I should start
with one person or two people or just
pick the easy people and just the fact
that I felt that just the fact that that
was one of the reasons meant I had to go
and do five I had to do a bigger number
I had to go after the harder people I
had to do the people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
going to care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid so I'm
going to give you a three-step process
you can follow to help you conquer your
fears to help you show up consistently
every day let's do it number one is tell
yourself that you do scary things one of
the biggest reasons why people don't
Advance their ideas forward is because
it's scary it's scary you're afraid
amazing that is now no longer an
acceptable reason you do scary things
you love scary things you Embrace scary
things you want to do scary things
isn't just a mindset trick it's actually
true you want to do scary things you do
what's the opposite of scary things the
opposite of scare if you walk through
life and you're never scared of anything
it's not that you're super confident no
it means that you're living inside your
comfort zone it means you're only doing
things that have zero fear that you have
absolute certainty in because you've
done it before
you're bored you're living inside your
bubble and you need to break out because
that means you're photocopying your life
every single day if there's nothing in
your calendar that makes you scared you
hate your life and so pay attention to
the language pay attention to how you
talk to yourself pay attention to when
you feel afraid
and as long as it's not against your
code of ethics or doing something stupid
don't go jump out of an airplane without
a parachute because you're afraid
right most of the things you're afraid
of are not life-threatening
teach yourself that you do scary things
you love scary things and you're not
allowed to use as an excuse anymore for
not taking action number two is think
what makes you sore what is the thing
that gets you feeling bold alive
confident ready to take action wanting
to show up to life what is it I go
through five s's every morning as part
of my morning routine the versus sing
and then sun and then soar and then
sweat and then scare the most important
part is sore though it's a thing that I
do to make me come alive that makes me
want to soar and so for me what I do is
I think about an entrepreneur that I
helped yesterday and then I pull up my
phone and then I record a message and I
share that to my YouTube stories
Instagram stories Twitter LinkedIn I put
it everywhere
I need to feel like the work that I do
matters right now I'm just talking to a
camera I'm just talking into a camera
right now and and later it's gonna be
edited and it's gonna be thrown up on
YouTube and lots of people are going to
watch the video that's that's crazy it's
hard to imagine because I'm just sitting
here in my office talking into a camera
and so I need to remember that the work
I do has purpose that this matters to
some people right that people rely on my
videos every day as a part of their
routine
and that helps make me soar so I wake up
just like everybody else I'm tired I'm I
don't know what time it is sometimes
even this morning I woke up I didn't
even know what day it was is it the
weekend is it I had no idea right yeah
wake up I'm not coming out of the day
saying yeah oh my gosh let's go right
that's not how anybody wakes up nobody
that's not how Grant Cardone wakes up
Evan Carmichael Tony Robbins no but it's
not how we wake up the difference is the
habits that you set on a daily basis to
demand that success to demand that you
show up
and so what is the thing that helps make
you soar maybe it's remembering the
impact you want to have maybe it's
sharing a message to YouTube to
Instagram to LinkedIn maybe it's doing
an active service maybe it's meditation
maybe it's reading maybe it's watching
these videos what is it that makes you
feel like you want to soar and then
don't randomly hope that it happens the
man that is part of your morning routine
because if you woke up and did the thing
to make you sore to make you feel bold
confident Unstoppable and you did that
every day for the next year your life
will be dramatically different you will
not recognize the person who you used to
be
the challenge is you're not consistent
in soaring and so I need you to make
that part of your morning routine and
then number three is understand what is
your Michael Jordan Talent what could
you be the greatest in the world at you
could be the
the greatest of all time at something
you are but what is that thing most
people are living way below the
potential because they settled you
settled too early you settled because
you were pressured you settled because
you were afraid you settled because you
ran out of time or at least you felt you
did that's not an acceptable answer
anymore you could be the greatest in the
world at something and if you're
procrastinating on something it's either
because you're afraid of the thing in
which case you need to go and do it
because you do scary you do afraid right
back to tip number one or two you just
don't like it you procrastinate because
you don't like it and if you continue to
do work that you don't like you're never
going to be the best because you're
going up against people who love it who
love it
who love it right if you're going up to
play basketball against Michael Jordan
you better love the game as much as he
does or you're gonna lose if it's just a
strategy for you you're gonna lose and
so look at the thing that's in front of
you look at the thing that you are not
showing up for it's for one of those
three reasons either you're afraid to do
it and therefore you must do it or two
you don't have consistent habits in
which case you need to put the thing
that makes you soar into your morning
routine or three you just don't actually
want to do it and stop forcing yourself
to do it go off and find the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
most people don't get what they want
because you don't follow through enough
you just don't follow through it's based
out of insecurity you start and stop
start and stop you're afraid of hurting
people's feelings you're afraid of what
they're gonna say about you you're
afraid they're gonna judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume and so we we stop we
stop and try to do something else where
we're seeing more immediate results but
if it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stories with Brendan Bouchard
and I went to speak at his event in
Phoenix and I I knew of him but I didn't
know him at the time it was his business
partner that had me come out to his
event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help or you know what's
next for you and I said I won't work on
my book and he said I'd love to uh I'd
love to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone uh number and I said how about
email and he said oh I'm not really good
on email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and follow up
a couple weeks later and then he said oh
man thank you uh I'm super swapped right
now but uh let's see they're due
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oh I don't want to
bother him
um maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out uh maybe
I'm offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's he's just a busy guy he had a lot
of stuff going on he had a launch that
was happening that I wasn't even aware
of uh that he was planning behind the
scenes and so he is he was you know not
crazy stressed out but he just has a lot
on his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
uh just one more email that's it I'm
gonna send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or whatever
and he wrote back an email and like hey
sorry man again I'm not super great on
email just been swamped planning all
these things uh yeah come on out come
out to the event speak at the event too
and that was his big event that was you
know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind to
be a part of that then I spoke on stage
that then at the event after I spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis house and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses all of
that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up and I followed up
and I followed up when I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence and and I and the reasons
why you're not doing it are based in
reality right I mean I could be
overwhelming it's it's possible it's
possible that he thinks that I'm
overwhelming that I'm not given enough
value that I'm being too selfish that
I'm bothering him I mean it's possible
but we default to just assuming that
instead of actually finding out
and we miss out on a lot of upside and
so here's what I found that really helps
one
you schedule it in
you schedule it in every X number of
weeks right so every two weeks I would
send in another email every two weeks
every two weeks every two weeks every
two weeks every two weeks every two
weeks and I never felt like doing it
because every time I saw that in my task
list
I I didn't want to do it like ah you
know let's give it another let's give it
another few days let's give it another
week you know I never wanted to do it
but because it was in my calendar I did
it
you will never want to do it because
you're afraid right underneath it is
really just fear it's insecurity you'll
never want to do it so you schedule it
in every two weeks or every week or
every month or whatever the thing is
that makes sense for the timeline that
you're on
schedule it in so that you have to do it
so when it came up I knew I had even
though I didn't want to even though my
heart was beaten like
I still went off and I did it second
thing is
lead with the intention before you write
the email before you make the call
before you do the follow-up like what's
the intention is your intention to screw
this person over is your intention to
just suck up their time is your
intention to negotiate a bad deal for
them hopefully not
if you're if you're a subscriber of this
channel uh hopefully it's with its
positivity and hope and belief and and
mutual you know uh benefits and so if
you lead with that intention every time
it's really unlikely that they're going
to
come back in a really negative way
the truth of the matter is they're
probably just really busy
maybe they're doing something
insane in their life maybe they have a
health scare maybe they're in the
hospital maybe their mom's in the
hospital right like you never know
what's going on behind the scenes
and if you leave with intention as
opposed to a copy paste email or just
some kind of spam if you if you leave
with I love this person I want to do
something with them I want to help I I
want to I want to learn like if that's a
positive intention going in your your
call your email your follow-up will just
be a lot better it'll be a lot better
and people will feel it I forget who it
was I want to say it was
ah no I forget who it is I'm thinking
princess dive I don't think it was her I
wanna I don't forget who it was where
she would say before I send an email
I would always smile
I would think about the person
and I would smile before I I wrote an
email wrote a letter
and it would always change
the the vibe of the letter right like if
you're thinking love kindness smiling
before you make a video before you do a
DM before you do a uh an email right
like if you're thinking that
chances are you'll make them smile
you know like if you're smiling
before you do it you're probably gonna
make them smile
and so just taking that little pause to
reflect on what is my intention here
instead of defaulting to insecurity and
the stress on your side
default into let's lead with positivity
let's smile let's leave with love
you'd be amazed at how many great things
happen
so those two things
one you put in your calendar
until you get a response like if
somebody if somebody says no
okay
at least you got a response
but again it's likely going to be a
loving no because you followed up so
many times and you've always LED with a
positive intention and love and kindness
they might just say I'm just you know
what I can't do this right now or I'm
not interested or
or hey sorry I haven't gotten back to
you let's do this
right A lot of times it's just a timing
a lot of times your timing is way off
and it's not your timing it just doesn't
fit into their life or their world right
now but in two weeks it might or in two
months it might or in two years it might
and if you're following up every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks and you're leading with
love and kindness and with a positive
intent amazing things will happen
you have a great Mission inside you
you have a desire to serve and the help
and to create great things for the
people who you work with right like that
that is at the core of Who You Are
and that needs to be spread
and at the beginning when people don't
know who you are it's a little harder to
get attention to get on people's radar
but if you are consistently following
through consistently even in the face of
not getting any response you just
consistently because it's on your
calendar you're consistently following
through and you're leading with the
intention of Love kindness positivity
great things will happen
promise you great things will happen to
change your life you have to be willing
to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing to do
different things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing
self-doubt and fear and insecurity and
nobody's watching the stories and he's
not good enough and who am I to share a
message in in our IG live one of the
things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content and some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
to get in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day it's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it if it's just you but you don't want
to fail in front of other people and
that can no longer be a good enough
reason because if you only do think
about this if you only do what's
comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what do
what you've always done you're going to
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs as you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I had to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is a thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountables that you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
it's not against your value system right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I want to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary is a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when
um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 we had 23
cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour instead of
just doing a small tour of three cities
or something like 23 cities 90 days you
know a quarter of the year on the road
straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things the willingness to show up even
if you don't win
[Music]
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck
you're photocopying your life today look
the same as yesterday look the days the
day before same as the day before is why
most people do not like their life is
why most people drive to a job that they
hate
they're driving to a job they hate most
people wake up all you know look at all
these cars here most people here in this
parking lot they're picking up every day
and driving to a job that they hate they
do not like their life most of the
people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something what's the
goal of yours that you've been sitting
on and then what's the voice in your
head that that's giving you an
acceptable reason for you not to do the
thing now try to get to the reason
behind the reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I don't have the time I don't have
the camera I don't have the gear I don't
want the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we're afraid when people won't watch it
and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone bad camera bad
microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
failure if it's fear of not being good
enough if the fear of being in posture
if it's fear of being uncomfortable
whatever your actual fear is that's your
trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period you are the product
of the five people that you spend the
most time with you've heard that before
you know it's important and the reason
why it's so true is because of a concept
in Persuasion in that whoever is more
confident wins
whoever is more confident in their
opinion on something in their habits on
something is the one who wins and
persuades and influences other people to
join them even without having to say
anything just somebody being so
confident in their own negativity in
their own world and their own bad habits
without even telling you anything you
will naturally pick up on that thing and
dive down that same negative rabbit hole
with them and and that that's the fight
because if you are around people who are
negative who have the bad habits that
you don't want to have anymore it's not
that it's impossible but you're making
it a lot more challenged on yourself to
be able to pull yourself out of the hole
you are the result of the five people
that you spend the most time with so
let's say you want to work out you want
to work out you want to be healthy this
is the year you want to lose weight you
want to be in the best ship of your life
amazing right
but it's a new habit and this is the
problem at the very beginning of a new
habit if we go back to the concept of
persuasion
you don't have a lot of persuasion over
yourself yet you don't have a lot of
influence over yourself yet on this
habit because it's so new
so it's easy to get pulled in a million
different directions you're looking for
any possible reason why not to do it and
if you have a goal to go to the gym
every day or you have a goal to eat
healthy today
and then you see your friends around you
just diving in on Big Macs and lying on
the couch and complaining and being
negative
you can fight that
but at some point that fight starts to
wear down on you and your resolve isn't
strong enough yet because it's too new a
habit and so it's likely to happen is
you're gonna go join them because they
are more confident in their negative
approach than you are in the positive
approach they have such a history with
the bad habit
that didn't influence you to go back
down that negative path I remember
hanging out with a very popular YouTuber
and he was asking well how do I grow
even to the next step and I'm I love how
consistent you are he's talking about my
channel how consistent I was and when I
was
with him over dinner
one of the things that I struggled with
is when I travel I usually let my diet
go you know I'm traveling having fun I
don't have my usual routine and so not
that I would just smash Doritos down my
face but I would just eat whatever and
he was at a restaurant with me and he
was eating really clean he had a fish
and salad and no dressing and just
really really clean and was waking up
the next day he was gonna go for a run
some of those habits are what I do here
when I'm at home but I don't do it when
I travel and so here he was admiring how
consistent I was on making videos and
having however many thousands of videos
now on the channel and I was admiring
how consistent he was in his eating
healthy and his working out now what
would happen if we started to hang out
more
if we started to hang out more and we
look at those two things the consistency
on making videos and the staying healthy
on the consistency of making videos I am
so
it's just part of me now I'm so
confident in my making videos and that I
have to get it done that even if he was
lying on the couch all day not that he
would but even if he was he wouldn't
negatively influence me so I would suck
him to making more videos he would be
making more videos as a result of
hanging out with me it would just
naturally happen without me even saying
anything to him because here's what
would happen he might be on the couch he
might be getting distracted might be
doing something else I said okay man I
gotta go make videos and by me going off
and making videos it will motivate him
to go make more videos I don't have to
say anything your actions speak way
louder than your words don't tell
somebody to go do something you want to
influence and persuade them go do the
thing and they'll see you doing it now
it's in their environment and it's gonna
suck them in so if we hung up together
he would be more consistent on the
content
on the other hand if we hung out
together consistently
I would get healthier with my my travel
diet if I traveled every time with him
then we would likely eat at more healthy
restaurants he would likely be working
out every morning I would likely join
him on some of those he would just
pull me towards being a healthier
traveler compared to what I am now
because he is so confident in that habit
that he's trying to build and so where
we struggle as entrepreneurs is we're
trying to build these new habits we're
trying to pull ourselves up to a better
brighter future better place more proud
of ourselves but we're still stuck with
the people around us who are in a
negative environment who want to stay
stuck who just complain about where they
are instead of actually trying to build
something better for themselves so if
that remains your friend's Circle in the
next five years it's going to be really
really challenging for you to get to the
place where you want to be okay well
that's that's great Evan how do I change
it I mean I don't want to just leave my
friends I don't even know where to get
new friends how do I start this process
there are three big strategies I want to
give you that I think will really really
really help first off you don't have to
go off and tell all your friends hey you
guys suck I'm better than you I don't
want to hang out with you anymore
right so step one is just do an audit
just do an audit of your friends just do
an audit of the five people that you
spend the most time with just think
about it in the past two months who have
you spent the most time with and then
how many of them make you feel better
about yourself where you leave them
feeling more bold more confident more
excited for your life more ready to go
and take on the big challenges that are
ahead of you and hand me them make you
feel worse how many of them you have to
go home and have a nap or how many of
them you just feel drained as a result
of talking to them not that they're bad
people they're just in a lot of pain
right again I don't think like there are
toxic people I just think that they're
in a lot of pain and and hurt people
hurt people right so if you're not
strong enough yet to influence them
they're gonna suck you down so step one
is to do an audit of your friends step
two is to limit access to the people who
are making you feel worse about yourself
again it doesn't mean you have to go and
tell them that they suck just just stop
spending time together
as you spend less time together you find
that the relationship just kind of
Fizzles away you don't have to have some
big conversation just kind of access
spend less time go out once a month
instead of once a week call them less
frequently stop doing things together
you'll just notice that as you spend
less time together
you stop getting influenced so
negatively people are so afraid of
breaking off a friendship because you
think you have to have this really tough
conversation you don't you don't you
just have to spend less time with them
just look at your calendar see how often
you usually spend and your goal for next
month is to spend half the amount of
time or a quarter of the amount of time
that you spent with them as last month
that's it that's step two it doesn't
have to be some big break doesn't have
to be crazy scary it doesn't have to be
overwhelming and massively painful
is it going to be to fill the void so if
you stop spending time with people
two things happen one you get a this
void it's like well who do I spend time
with now I have this extra time in my
calendar I've got these blocks and the
other thing is you start to feel lonely
you know if you don't have that fun
circle around you anymore it's easy to
feel lonely which is maybe even worse
than spending time with them at least
you have some kind of connection we're
settling for just okay relationships
because we crave the connection because
you just want to have somebody around
you because it's better to be with that
person than it is to be alone
and that's the biggest fear is that
you're just gonna end up alone that
you'll never find anybody even in
romantic relationships but also in your
friendships because it can be harder as
you get older to join friend circles to
make new friends is why a lot of people
are still stuck with the same friends
they had in high school and University
because they never actually went to go
out and search for new friends because
it's so afraid that you're gonna be
stuck alone so in that vacuum in that
void in that hole in your calendar now
what are you gonna do well the goal is
to now meet new people and you don't
have to treat it like it's dating it's a
relationship you just go off to the
events and the and the people that you
feel like you might have a connection to
so I'm introverted I'm shy I am not a
people person I hate networking events I
hate small talk
and so how I would do it if you're
extroverted it's super easy just go and
go to the events and hang out and say hi
and say hi I'm Evan good to meet you I
would never I never go up to anybody and
say hi I'm Evan it's great to meet you
what do you do I just I never do that
um so the easy way to do it is think
about the clubs the activities and the
events that are really interesting for
you that it's a lot more natural for you
to have a conversation about so if there
was just a business networking meeting I
would hate that I hate that kind of
stuff where you have to explain what it
is that you do and they don't really
care or interested in but finding common
Hobbies
so for me
I'll pick entrepreneurship I would pick
League of Legends I would pick salsa
dancing and signing into Minecraft so
maybe maybe some Minecraft I would pick
something in those four areas where I
could easily connect with people that it
doesn't feel like a chore to talk about
because I love that topic as a quick
example
um I was on an airplane and I was flying
to Brighton burchard's event in Puerto
Rico and so I was I was one of two
external speakers coming in to speak at
the event and this is his high level
Mastermind these are people who are
paying 30 to 50 000 to be in that room
and I'm flying down there and I you know
I'm in business class there's only one
person next to me and he's trying to
strike up a conversation and I I just I
just don't like it it's like so where
are you going like well we're going to
Puerto Rico like where are you coming
from I'm from Toronto and he was coming
up from Vancouver and I just I hate the
small talk right I hate the small talk
and so I think he kind of noticed after
a couple tries that I wasn't really
interested in talking to him I didn't
mean to be rude I just it doesn't
fulfill me I'd rather just be by myself
and alone and focus on what I need to
talk about and so we're flying down
there
and I don't really know why he's going
or what you know what he's going for
what his business is in Puerto Rico if
he's speaking if he's got an event what
so we don't really talk for the rest of
the way not anything rude just we're in
our own world
I get there and get in my uh my taxi or
Uber whatever and drive to the hotel
where we're staying
and as I'm checking in guess who shows
up right behind me
right next to me on the counter the same
guy that I spent all this time now just
sitting next to not talking to on the
airplane
and he said hey you're here too it's
like and as soon as I knew that he was
here for Brendan burchard's event it's
like yeah man are you here too oh my God
what's your business
as soon as I found out that he was an
entrepreneur it's it's way easier to
have a connection and so we spent a
little more time there chatting it's
been a couple a couple of moments over
the over the course of the conference as
well but it's so much easier to make
connections when you have a joint
interest right if I know you're an
entrepreneur or I know you care about
League of Legends or Minecraft or salsa
dancing if I know any of those things we
are instantly going to be friends and
have something to talk about
but if you're just a normal human who
maybe I don't know anything about then
it's a lot more difficult so
because you have this vacuum and you
don't know who to connect with and you
want to feel that connection and
belonging with the group
don't let that hole and that pain drag
you back to the circle that you know
doesn't ultimately support you and look
for the events that are exciting for you
to go to for the clubs for the
activities that you are generally like
oh that'd be so cool to be able to go
there and you'll end up meeting
like-minded people and that becomes your
new friend Circle and when that happens
when you hold on to good people like
that you actually stop even caring that
some of the people
you know I've kind of drifted or you've
let go of at some point instead of
spending once a month with them now
maybe it's once a year just catching up
or maybe you don't talk again not again
because you've had some conversation and
they hate you you just Grown Apart
and the last time you spend with
somebody the more you're gonna grow
apart you are the product of the five
people that you hang out with the most
you've heard it before you'll hear it
again when is the time to actually take
the action do the audit of your friend's
Circle do they make you feel better
about yourself or Worse about yourself
stop spend as much time with the people
that make you feel worse about yourself
and then feel the void fill the vacuum
with people who lift you up by going to
events and clubs and activities that you
genuinely care about it's not just a
strategy to make connections but you
love being there you will meet some
amazing like-minded people practice
ultimate 50
Freedom more you practice the better you
get at something the more skilled you
are at it the more information you have
the more it actually allows you to play
more have more fun be more flexible and
have ultimately more freedom this is
something I struggled with a lot in the
early days of my speaking career I was
asked to speak at a bunch of events and
this is what 20 years ago I guess I've
I've had as a speaking career now and I
used to be so worried about
disappointing people that I would
memorize my entire speech I would
practice and practice and practice and
practice and practice and just memorize
my speech at the point where
word for word it would be the exact same
thing every time and I thought that was
good I thought that's what you're
supposed to do obviously yes practice
makes perfect keep going keep practicing
keep doing it and what ended up
happening was yes I delivered the same
speech each time but I think the worst
thing you can do as a speaker is just
give the exact same speech every time
we did a session of Movie Makers around
the signature talk it was one of the
most voted topics was how do I give my
signature talk and I think having one
signature talk is actually not great I
think you should be able to
be able to speak to the audience every
time your job if you're a speaker is to
give your audience a fantastic
experience and so it's knowing who's in
the audience don't assume it's the same
people every single time
right so you have to be able to know so
much about your subject that then you
can have your framework that you operate
in but then give a lot more value to
People by making a custom to them
so now whenever I'm doing a speaking gig
I'm always asking okay tell me about the
audience tell me who's here tell me why
people are setting it up what are people
here for both in terms of the
information they're hoping to get as
well as their background and their
interests and their concerns and what
they struggle with and of course there's
genuine human struggles that everybody
goes through but why are people here at
this conference and so here's my process
right now when I'm doing a a speech or
talk
they're going to have me coming they're
going to talk about believer
entrepreneurship or YouTube there's
gonna be some set themes you're not
having me come to talk about my apple
strudel recipe
because I don't have one right I'm
coming to talk about things that are
inside my domain perfect
and I could easily just get up on stage
and talk
but I want to know who's in the audience
so before going I'll ask them tell me
about the people who are going to be
here and then I'll frame my speech
around a couple of key ideas that I
think would be valuable to that audience
still sitting within kind of the my
usual domain perfect
I'll practice it I'll practice giving a
speech I'll practice the points at home
I'll practice I'll practice talking to
my dog I'll practice on the airplane on
the way over I'll practice to kind of
get a sense of the stories that I want
to tell that I think will be the right
fit
but then the day before and the day of I
like to be there a little early to to
talk to people to
one makes me feel a little more
comfortable
um being able to connect to people in
the audience so it's not just
people I don't know but I've had a few
conversations with people but two
in feeling the vibe out of the event
I'll often end up switching up part of
my talk again to make it as customizable
as possible to the people I'm talking to
and this isn't just a speaking thing
guys this is any interaction you're
doing you're trying to sell your product
trying to sell your service you're on a
call with somebody who could use your
product or service hire you as a coach
Etc you have to customize your pitch
customize your talk for them not just
give the same thing every single time
you're talking to somebody you have to
know what makes them tick know why
they're talking to you what their their
deep desires and fears are and address
those things so that you can close the
sale right it's the same thing I'm just
giving an example through speaking
has been willing to deviate
from your talk
to actually give more value
and I think again the worst thing you
can do is the speakers just give get on
sale you can give the same talk every
single time
that's what I used to think was the way
to go but this is actually a lot more
valuable
because you can inspire people but when
it becomes boring for you to get up and
just do the same thing over and over and
over again and two if you can customize
it to actually address the thing that
they're specifically concerned about
you're gonna have a bigger impact why
are you there you're there to touch
people you're there to move people to a
positive direction right
again whether you're whether you're
speaking or you're just talking to
somebody on the phone a potential client
why are you working with them yes
they're going to pay you but why you
want them to get a result you want them
to move you want them to make a change
you want to solve a problem for them and
so the more you can actually connect to
what they're struggling with the easier
it is for you to
to close the sale and have the impact
that you're trying to have so it's a lot
more fun it's a lot more impactful a lot
more meaningful and so that's my usual
process now why are people here
I'll prepare a version of my speech to
address those people and then it always
changes up the day of because I met
somebody in the lobby who inspired me or
I met somebody on the airplane the day
before who shifted my thinking a little
bit and gives me an extra story to tell
and when you're so prepared and you know
your stuff so much it's easy to add
those things in
when you don't really know
you're kind of all over the place
so it's being overly prepared and then
the day of being willing to be flexible
it's that like rigidity of practice and
practice and practice and knowing what
you're doing so much that allows you to
play when you show up it's the you know
going to sports you practice your free
throws so much your practice your
penalty shot so much you practice you
practice so much that allows you to be a
lot more flexible than play when it
comes to game time let me share another
quick example from the opposite side
where I was interviewing somebody so
instead of being the person on stage
speaking I'm interviewing somebody and I
recently had Tony Robbins on the channel
and it's the third time it came on the
channel the first two interviews we did
had three million views on them combined
which is amazing and he's coming back
for the third time talk about his new
book and I'm always nervous before a big
interview
and this is probably the least nervous
I've been because it's the third time on
but I was still nervous going in and so
I'm preparing preparing and preparing
and preparing I'm trying to find a
thread that I care about I don't want to
just ask the same questions everybody
else has asked I don't want to just use
the questions that his PR agency sent
over because he's going to answer those
questions on every other show I want it
to be different and unique and fun and
special and so I prepared I know I've
got
uh half an hour with him uh I know he
likes to go long in his stories you
don't get that many questions in so I
need to I need to really be careful of
what I'm gonna say and make this time
count
it'd be easy just to show up and ask
okay why did you write this book what
does it mean to you what do you hope
people get from it what was your
favorite part about it and then then
half an hour is done and you haven't
really asked anything super meaningful
so I'm preparing
and I wrote down on a notepad file that
I had opened when I was talking to him
you know four questions five questions
that I wanted to ask and I practiced how
I would ask them I practice you know
what what I was going to say
and then I practiced it so much that
come game time come show time here we go
Tony's coming on let's let's do our
one-on-one
I was able to actually be present and
listen to what I was saying and and play
ball with him right to to throw and
catch with him instead of just going to
the questions when you haven't prepared
and you're really insecure you just go
to the questions you just go okay here's
what I said okay here and just ask the
question we're the best interviews are
when you can throw and catch right where
they say something and you take that a
little bit deeper as opposed to just
moving on to the next question because
I've watched a lot of interviews and in
the work that I do and one of the things
that I find most frustrating is the
person says something amazing and you
want them to it's like okay ask a
follow-up question and instead of asking
a follow-up question then just go to the
next question
because the interviewer it was never
even listening to what the interviewee
was saying they're just so worried about
getting the next question in that that's
that's all they're thinking about it's
like okay great and then tell me about
this next question without going deeper
into the conversation so I didn't want
to be that kind of interviewer even I
get it because you're nervous
you're not fully prepared you're worried
about the questions
so one example with Tony he was talking
about a recent Health scare that he had
and that his career would be over
the doctor said your career is over
and in my head I was thinking about some
of the other stuff I knew about Tony
Robbins and so I asked him how many
times have you been told that your
career is over
it was off script right it wasn't
something his team prepared it wasn't
something Tony's maybe been asked I
asked him how many times have you been
told that your career has been over
because I remember uh you know he had
this
um tumor that made him grow crazy
quickly and and people said his life
would be over I remember he burned out
his voice box and his doctors told him
he'd never speak on stage again and now
this injury that happened to him he
wasn't gonna be able to go into his
event so he's been told consistently
that his career would be over
and yet he still gets up and he finds a
way and he does it right one of the
things that we love about his ability to
follow through and stay consistent and
so in the over preparation and knowing
his story and also knowing that I had
questions to fall back on in case
there was a lull on the conversation it
allows the play it allows the freedom it
allows you to adjust the situation which
then creates a much better experience so
whether you're speaking whether you're
interviewing whether you're coaching
whether you're mentoring whether you're
on a sales call
you need to know your script you need to
know what you're going to say you need
to understand your customer and who
you're talking to you need to know all
that and over prepare
but then understand that the greatest
asset that you have is not in rehearsing
again the script is that you have the
ability to be free now
that you can play because you've done
all the drills and now you need to have
the back and forth it's it's throwing
and catching I'm gonna throw the ball to
you you're gonna catch it you're gonna
throw the ball back to me it's not just
throwing where a lot of times the
biggest mistake is that you're just
throwing you're just throwing another
one and another one and here's my other
line here's my next question here's my
next pitch throw throw throw throw
and the person I'd be saying but there's
no receiving and them throwing the ball
back to you that's the best part in any
interaction if you have a goal to get
them to move forward to make a change in
their life just to sign you up to hire
you to work with you so you can make
that impact that you're trying to make
there has to be that back and forth and
the more prepared you are the easier it
is to then have the freedom to play what
you believe about yourself is the only
thing that matters at the end of the day
no matter how much outside affirmations
you get or other people telling you that
you're amazing if you don't believe in
your heart that you are amazing it won't
none of that will last like you've ever
gone to an event or you ever made a
video or created something or you're
hanging out with a friend and they tell
you how amazing you are and that feels
good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades but that stuff doesn't
last you don't have somebody being a
cheerleader for you every day showing up
in your bedroom saying hooray go do this
you're amazing right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never gonna love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
well okay so that's that's a lot of
words how do you actually go off and do
it
I think for me this is why I believe
that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people we're not hard
enough on ourselves let me let me stick
with me for a minute we're not hard
enough on ourselves because in order to
get to where you want to go you actually
need to push yourself more the problem
is why we can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
we're barely hanging on to what we're
doing we we can post all these great
things on Instagram or wherever and make
it look like we're enjoying our life but
most people are barely hanging on the
people who are judging you for your life
and telling you that you suck hate their
own lives they are barely hanging on so
how do we get through it well yes we can
be harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
um I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masking
and insecurity right it's like those
people who uh
have you ever seen those memes where
yeah
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything now he's like doesn't care
you know just walking on a T-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masking and
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
came on you would have to you would have
to move right it doesn't mean that
you're up and like dancing through the
whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today yes
but I demand excellence and that that
starts with music because I don't have I
don't want to spend a lot of time trying
to get into the right state of mind I
can command it whenever I want just by
putting on the right song so be in
tension with your music and the lyrics
being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and this is probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rocking a walk
to Tim Hortons usually get a coffee
you know this costs two bucks two
something so I only had now what's the
what's the best money I spend every year
well it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
a coffee every morning and I'm thinking
about what's my intention for the day
and I'm thinking about what I want to
accomplish today and the lives that I
want to serve and the people I want to
help and and what I'm about to do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be
11. first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brand lytics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate I mean
it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe locks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation in somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things the biggest
fear we have isn't failure you're not
afraid of failing the biggest fear we
have is of failing in front of other
people you're afraid of people's
judgments the reason why we stay stuck
the reason why you still are where you
are is because you're afraid of other
people's opinions you have
great ideas inside you you have great
ideas if you're watching this video
You're subscribed to this channel you
have great ideas you know you're capable
of more you know you want to serve you
know you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
shut them off because we find a logical
reason why we can't do it right the
logic reasons in our head are well the
timing's not right or I don't have the
gear right on the connections or uh you
know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based on some kind of fact
but they're still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underlying that is not the fear of it
not working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
fail
we're so tied up into what other people
think about us that we'd rather play
small for life than actually go off and
accomplish and risk failing in front of
other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off in
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that's still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that that
people will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
a crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
at printer burchard's event and uh it
was in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here you know it was
a 30 to 50 000 Mastermind and
everybody's got giant businesses right
these are multi-million dollar
businesses owners who are in the house
and it was a multiple Day event I think
it was a three-day event and I'm I'm
speaking for one of them not even the
whole day I'm speaking I have one I've
got an hour something of time right at
that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of event
we're really I'm a really tiny nothing
part of this event right I mean people
are there to see Brendan burchard the
scene Dean graziosi to see the other
speakers there if any one speaker sucks
I mean if Brendan sucks that's a big
deal because he's speaking for 80 of the
time if I suck for one hour nobody's
really gonna care nobody's really gonna
be asking for a refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews would cancel on me the
meetings would cancel on me
um I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this if this makes sense or if it's
happening to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance for two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'd happy to do that and then
on the day of I look at my calendar and
say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email I
remember I'd be checking my email hoping
that that person would cancel on me to
say oh I'm busy or I got sick or it's
not going to work out anymore and let's
reschedule and I remember I check in the
morning and I check two hours of four
and check an hour before and check half
an hour before and check 10 minutes
before and like if there was no email
then then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it
it almost always worked out like I never
had an interview or a meeting or
something where I just massively
underperformed and actually sucked right
that that never really happened but I
was always afraid of it happening
and so I had to teach myself
this is
what you want to do like the only thing
worse than me not doing this
is is me doing this and canceling right
or them me never doing an interview and
me never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and feeling in
front of somebody else
I'm sitting here filming in in the car
Nina just came back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm filming here you know in the car
we got the dogs here in the back seat
timo's chilling and this used to make me
afraid you know that look there's a guy
who just pulled up next to me
he's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you have to be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know I used to be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy
right
why am I afraid of him
laughs
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh if somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leaving with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be a
giant failure and everybody's gonna
laugh for me to kill us right like
that's the thought that's that's in our
head where the reality is most people
don't care
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they're in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you plain small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you could write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st so I start this next
month or next week or Monday or on my
birthday or some artificial day you come
up with some reason of when you should
be starting this thing right but if you
actually examined it if you actually
took a little step back and looked at
your goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
and look at them
and look at your list of reasons why you
haven't started really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are
not chasing down the things that you
want to do because you're afraid of
somebody else's Judgment of you as long
as that is a thing that rules you you
will never win you will never accomplish
anything great and you'll you'll live
life with regret so even now my my
biggest fear is still disappointing
people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
some of the courage to go do the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head-on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck
and every time you catch the fear and
you do it because of not just feel the
fear and do it anyway Feel the fear and
do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being honestly I think we're all
thinking small
you're thinking small I'm thinking small
we're all thinking small compared to
what what we're capable of and I think
we've been conditioned to think small
we've been conditioned by our upbringing
our family our our parents our guidance
counselors our teachers our
we've just been conditioned to think
small because we're learning about life
from people who
also never thought big and so
because we are products of our
environment we have conditioned
ourselves to think the same way is it
that people in our environment and if
you're not happy with your environment
and your environment is not around
around big people who've done amazing
things or thinking big then you will
stay stock thinking small as well what I
love about Naveen Jane is that he thinks
big you know the first time I found this
content there were three people who
I get recommended all the time you
should do a top 10 on this person you
should do an Express on this person you
should profile this person and there
were three people who for the first time
upon first consumption of their content
really blew me away one was Denzel
Washington
uh if you have not seen Denzel
Washington you should go watch his top
ten he his backup plan for his life was
being a minister uh and he is a fire
presenter I just kind of a lot of times
we do actors it's really hard to get
anything good out of the interviews that
they're doing uh but Denzel Washington
is a whole other animal so he really
blew me away the second was Priyanka
Chopra uh who had just amazing set of
interviews and super intelligent bright
woman and the third was Naveen Jane
where I'd like no idea who this person
is you should do Naveen Jane great go
look him I was like oh my gosh this
guy's amazing I want more Naveen Jane in
my life I think that's a great sign you
know like when you find people like that
even if you've never met them and up
until this year I had never met Naveen
Jane The Good Fortune had just recently
have him on on my channel to do an
interview in a collaboration but up
until that point I'd never met him
before and
when you find the people who make you
think bigger who make you feel more
confident to make you feel more bold
you around them more
this is my solution right I am trying to
hang out even if it's just virtually
with the people who inspire me to want
to play a bigger game you know either
those three people I haven't met Denzel
Washington
yet I haven't met Priyanka Chopra yet uh
and up until you know this year I hadn't
met Naveen Jane yet but I can still be
inspired by them I can still learn from
them I can still look at their content
and it can still push me to become
better
and I think a lot of us stay stuck and
stay small because it's so
good to feel important
and we end up being the big fish in a
small pond if you're watching this video
you are probably the one that's pouring
into
everybody else you're probably the most
optimistic person in your circle you're
probably the one who cares the most
about the people around you you're
probably doing the most for the people
in your circle and you're the one people
come to and say Hey how do I X you know
how do I grow how do I get better how do
I you're the one that's advising and
helping and pushing other people maybe
pushing them too much that makes sense
maybe you're maybe you're pushing some
people too much but you're the most
optimistic most ambitious person in your
circle probably that's great in a sense
and that you can pour and give back and
help others along the way but who's
pushing you
you know if you don't have somebody
pushing you to be better to be stronger
to be greater to be more ambitious to
think bigger than you probably won't
like if you it's really uncomfortable to
think bigger
and if you don't have somebody inspiring
you pushing you helping you then you
probably stay stuck
and that's what we need to change and so
it's a message for you but it's a
message for me equally so and so step
one in doing that I think is just
changing the environment to be around
the people who do inspire you and
chances are most of the people who do
inspire you are not not people who have
you have direct access to and not people
who are taking on an intern you know
Warren Buffett's not taking on an intern
to go live with him for a year as far as
I know
so how do you do it well the easy way is
through content
I've learned so much you've been
inspired so much by just amazing people
through the content on my own channel
like I make these videos for me because
I need them because I need to believe
more in myself and then I share that
with you and thankfully enough of you
like it that I can make it a business
and hire a team and continue to make
even more content because if it was just
me then it'd be a lot fewer videos
coming up and a lot less profiles and a
lot less content
so being around the people and when you
find people who really speak to you who
really get you going who like yes this
is exactly what I need then
be around them more subscribe to their
channels buy their books listen to their
podcasts be around them more if they're
speaking an event go to the event
because it'll push you to reach another
level and this is why it's so great to
have so many people now I'm I'm
passionate about helping bring
new people onto the to platforms like
YouTube and getting their message out
there because some people
[Music]
will push you through things some people
will hug you through things everybody
has their own lens and you'll connect
with people in a different way so you
look at uh Eric Thomas so you look at a
Jocko willink or you look at uh Andy
frisella
who are going to be very in your face
cut right to the truth no BS no excuses
no wiggle room like get up and go chase
down your life now it's a hard push they
may be yelling at you they're very
intense it's a hard push forward and
then there'll be other people like Oprah
like
um brene Brown like Dave Meltzer who
have a different approach it's a much
softer approach they'll hug you through
it you know some people will push you
and yell at you to get through it and
some people will hug you through it a
lot of times the message is exactly the
same you know Oprah's message is very
similar to Eric Thomas's message the
difference is the delivery
Oprah will hug you through it and Eric
will push you through it and it really
just depends on what you need there's no
right or wrong it's just what do you
need and when you find the people who
give you what you need just be around
that more be around that more because no
matter how much you watch one video
the impact will wear off right like
you're waking up tomorrow the same
person you were almost yesterday maybe a
half a percent better
but you could be you could watch this
video get all inspired be like yes all
right I'm gonna chase things down
amazing let's go and you have energy for
a few hours for the day but then you
wake up tomorrow and and that energy is
gone right has that happened to you that
energy suddenly is not there anymore you
don't feel as bold as courageous or
ambitious as you were yesterday why what
happened
it's not that there's nothing wrong with
you that's just normal
because you got an injection into your
environment that took you to another
level and then it it fell off
because there was no consistency in the
environment so you are what you
consistently do so whatever you want to
accomplish whoever you want to be to
consistently surround yourself with
people like that
because you're not getting enough in
your home environment your home your
environment now your life has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are it's allowed you to get to where you
are right now amazing and if that's
where all you want to be awesome
congratulations you've done it you've
you've hit the jackpot but if you want
more
then your current environment is not
designed to help you go and get more and
again I'm talking to myself just as much
as I'm talking to you like saying these
words out loud it's like what changes do
I need to make to my environment who do
I need to be hanging out with more
either in person or just through the
video content to make me want to
push more be more courageous save save
Bolder things and have bigger
aspirations and goals and dreams and and
take Boulder action towards
accomplishing them
okay makes a big big big difference and
so
if you want to accomplish something if
it's business success or mindset success
then it was just thinking bigger then if
you love Naveen Jane be around Naveen
Jane more
watch all those interviews and and
listen to any podcasts that he does and
I did one on my main Channel we'll link
that up at the end of this video you can
go watch if you want if you want to
improve your health and fitness and
you're tired of you know being on an
Oreo diet okay
you can make a choice and a decision
that I'm gonna I want to be this person
I want to be the person who works out I
want to be the person who takes care of
my body takes care of my health and
energy and
that's awesome as a decision but you
need the environment to support you and
so now if you're subscribing to health
channels if you're following people on
Instagram who are working out and take
care of their bodies it will make you
want to live a healthier life one of the
ones that I love watching is Tom bilyu
and his health Theory show where he's
interviewing experts around health and
every time I listen I was listening to
one this morning every time I listen
watch it makes me want to be a little
bit healthier
you know the more that you're around
that kind of stuff the more you will
take on the mindset similarly if you're
injecting poison like if you're around
negative people or you're consuming
negative content and that's most of the
news and most of media to be honest is
mostly negative if you're surrounded by
negativity constantly and you're you're
watching negative videos and reading
negative news constantly you will be a
lot more negative you'll be a lot more
scared you'll be a lot more scarcity
mindset you'll be a lot more afraid
you'll be a lot less positive and
ambitious because that's what you're
feeding into your mind so be very
careful about now designing and
Engineering your environment your
environment has happened to you
you know you've had some control over it
but it's it's mostly happened to you
and now you can with intent change it
to be more positive if you had to ask
yourself if I wanted to surround myself
with the most positive encouraging
inspiring
people who will make me more courageous
bold and ambitious
who would those people be what would
that environment look like
and then make a choice
change it change who you subscribe to
change what you're listening and
watching unsubscribe from all the
channels that make you feel worse about
yourself change your physical
environment what what clothes are you
wearing what do you put on the wall
around you what's your background on
your cell phone and on your computer you
start to change it and when you change
your environment it'll Force the change
in your habits in your mindset and in
your thinking you're not afraid of
failing you're afraid of failing in
front of other people you will sing in
the shower but you won't sing on the
street corner why because of other
people because they may see you because
they may laugh at you because they may
say look at that person they're so dumb
right you're not afraid of failing not
not just by yourself you're afraid of
failing and who is going to watch and so
that becomes really important because it
now means you're living your life based
off of other people's expectations and
judgments and maybe that's
people in your own family maybe that's
people you know maybe that's your mom or
maybe that's random people you're afraid
of the Judgment of unknown YouTube
commenters and leaving some kind of
feedback on your video telling you how
much you suck right we're afraid of the
people that we care deeply about in
their perspective and opinions on us and
we're also afraid of the the people who
we don't know yet who are just out there
in the world on the internet who might
come and leave negativity on whatever
you're going to be creating so you're
not actually afraid of failing you'll do
it all the time but it's failing and who
is going to see us fail and so
there's a lot to unpack inside of that
let's start with
what is your big goal what do you want
to accomplish what mission are you on
who are you trying to serve who are you
trying to help and in order for you to
go off and accomplish those things and
serve to your highest capability you're
going to have to do things that will be
scary where you're going to risk failure
right if you are never risking any kind
of failure then you're living your life
so small and so safe that you don't like
your life
if there's nothing in your calendar in
the next month that you are excited by
the that your heart's getting you're
you're scared really you're nervous
right you're like oh my gosh that
thing's happening if there's nothing in
your calendar that's like that you don't
like your life that that's honestly most
people
you're just photocopying your same life
over and over and over and over and over
again that's what most people wake up
and do I'm sitting here in the Costco
parking lot right like most most people
you just wake up and you're photocopying
the same day you had yesterday and last
week and last year that's not a life
so you have to be willing to risk some
kind of failure which would potentially
risk other how other people see you and
judge you I used to not be able to
record videos like this I mean the first
video I ever recorded in public
was I was walking down the street at my
old house and I was challenged by my
agent he said you have to record videos
in public like Steve big fetus in public
are you crazy I can barely make videos
at home I'm going to now make them in
public like you have to do it like okay
great so I'm walking down the street
carrying my big video camera at the time
and
I made sure I picked a really quiet
section of the street where nobody was
usually outside because it made me feel
like I was recording the video and doing
the task but there was nobody around so
I wasn't really doing the task and I
remember there was a male male uh male
woman who was dropping off mail and as
soon as I saw her and I felt like I was
in auditory range of her then I pulled
the camera down
and then as I passed her I started
filming again
it's like I did the assignment Steve
look I filmed outside I didn't really do
the assignment why because I'm afraid of
of a male woman's opinion of me like she
doesn't even care about me she's she's
living her life doing her thing
and so something like this now I'm
sitting here in a parking lot filming
and people are walking by and some
people are watching like what's this guy
doing
you just keep going you just keep making
because fear of other people's judgments
cannot be a good enough reason for you
to play small not anymore and if you
want to do great things most of the
people judging you don't like their own
lives and any judgment they have of you
is just a reflection of self
so there's a couple of hacks that I've
used to be able to get through it that
might serve you
number one is studying successful people
and anytime you study successful people
you find out that they failed along the
way to their success
a lot of times you may just see on the
surface just their accomplishments and
list of what they've done and all that
and it could feel
um imposing you know how are they so
perfect and I suck and I have all these
fears and insecurities but if you look
deeper into their story and maybe watch
some of their interviews or videos
you'll see that they struggled a lot and
they had multiple failures on their path
to success and I used to before my
channel came out I used to read
stories of different famous
entrepreneurs and how they got started
and you know the kind of zero to one
story because it made me feel like
it was possible
that looking at Warren Buffett now is
crazy you know it's like he's done so
much you can't relate but how do you go
from zero to one and what did he
struggle with and where did he fail that
was inspiring to say hey okay if he
could get through that
now me decades later with a lot more
opportunity in technology and resources
and I could do that
you know I could do something similar so
that inspired me to to get out of my
cocoon and to be around people who are
doing amazing things inspired me to want
to go off and do more it's also why I
make videos like this so that you can
learn from Warren Buffett and all the
people that we profile and because I
think the more that you're around that
the more you'll win I don't know Warren
Buffett personally you probably don't
maybe you do maybe you can text him and
ask for advice I can't not yet but I can
watch his videos and I can learn from
him and I can get better and I can
improve Myself by being around him and
the more that I watch his videos the
more I can think like him just a little
bit and and that's important because
that shifts you forward so being around
more successful people will will shift
you towards success even if they are
virtual through through a computer
screen through videos podcasts books Etc
the second thing is
teaching myself that I do difficult
things
and I think that's really important
because we've accepted fear as a good
enough reason for you not to do the
thing you've accepted other people's
opinions as a good enough reason for you
not to do the thing my trigger words I
call them play bigger triggers you come
up with the triggers that will allow you
to play bigger so if I say scary
difficult or hard then I go off and do
it because I want to be the person who
does the things that are scary difficult
or hard to myself and that's why I still
make videos that's why I write books and
speak on stage and find all of those
things incredibly scary difficult and
hard
so what is it for you and when you can
stop accepting scary difficult or hard
as a good enough reason like I want to
do it but I'm scared okay well that's
not a good enough reason you've already
set you've pre-decided that that's not a
good enough reason so you have to go up
and do the thing it's a scary difficult
heart you say it you write it you think
it you tell somebody else it as long as
that is the reason for you to put the
brakes on your life it's not a good
enough reason anymore it has to be
something stronger than scary difficult
or hard otherwise you have to go and
take action and you start to teach
yourself that you are the kind of person
who takes on things that are scary
typical of the heart so number one was
being around successful people
study them and learn from them and get
mentorship from them even if it's just
through a video number two is that you
do difficult things and then number
three is
focus on service
and
if you understand that the thing that
you're afraid to do is not just for you
it's for other people right if you're an
entrepreneur you're trying to create a
business it's not just for you this sure
there's selfish goals of I want to I
want to make money and provide for my
family and live a great life Etc but
above that needs to be service and
helping others that you're creating
something that's going to bring value to
other people that it's not just about
you making money but you're providing a
real service something really valuable
to other people that's going to make
their life better if I'm making videos
it's not just about me and numbers on
the channel it's about it's about you
and hopefully for for one of you
watching this video it has a big impact
today when I speak on Sage or write the
Books it's not about me it's about who I
can help serve and whenever you can
deeply connect to who you can help serve
at least for me it gives me the courage
to go off and do the thing if I'm
terrified to speak on stage
I'll often look behind the curtain at
the audience and I'll try to find a
couple people's like I'm doing it for
that person I'm doing it for him I'm
doing for her I've got a message that I
can share that can help them
and that gives me the confidence and the
courage to go do the thing because we'll
show up for other people more than we'll
show up for ourselves and so when you
can tie what you're doing to other
people to Value to service to helping
them it'll give you more confidence and
courage to go off and do the thing that
you need to do and so I call that the
the push and the hug so
the I do difficult things I do scary
things is the push like get out get out
there and do this Carmichael let's go
and the service is the hug like hey I'm
not I'm not doing this just for me I'm
doing it for for all the people out
there as well and some days you need
more of the hug some days you need more
of the push
and you just lean in on what you feel
you need most you know there's some days
when pushing yourself harder is not the
answer you need a hug and there are some
days where hugging yourself more is not
the answer you need to push
and so having a self-awareness and now
okay I need the push right now or I need
the hug right now and then going off and
doing that will give you the momentum
that you need
failure
failure is gonna happen
and the biggest failure again is that
the fear of other people seeing you fail
and as long as you live your life by the
expectations of other people you will
live small forever and if you can flip
it to say I'm doing this to help others
I'm doing this because
I want to live a great life and I'm
doing this because I do difficult things
when you can make that shift happen you
start to accomplish your goals so as an
introvert Making Connections always
seemed incredibly scary to me I hate
going to networking events I'm not life
of a party I don't know uh how to
approach people and ask them questions
and it always just felt I think at the
end of the day very fake and inauthentic
and just not me you know I don't know
how to introduce myself and I don't know
I don't know what to talk about I want
to sit here and talk I'm here in Arizona
and it's beautiful and it's sunny and
it's amazing but I don't I don't I don't
want to just talk about the weather you
know I don't want to talk about
boring
superficial stuff and
it took me a long time to get
comfortable coming to events and I'm
this is actually a great moment because
I'm here at genius Network it's a I just
came out of a two-day event where people
are paying 25 000 to be a part of and
the next two days uh it's another event
where they're paying a hundred thousand
dollars to be part of and I'm a guest
here speaking at um at both events and I
would have I would have never like
younger Evan would have never come to
something like this because
not that it's not valuable just I would
have been too afraid to to network and
to uh to ask for help and to introduce
myself and all of those things what I've
discovered if you're an introvert
what I've discovered is that introverts
are great listeners
and we care
and you can be a fantastic networker if
you're an introvert but your goal is not
to know the entire room and the goal is
not to run into the the the event and
say look at me here's what I do and
where the shiniest suit and be the
loudmouth if that's you awesome roll
with it but if it's not your goal is to
just connect with a few people on a
really meaningful level
I've connected over the past couple days
with some amazing people who've given me
some amazing advice and connections and
experiences and
just amazing people but it hasn't been I
don't there's lots of people who I
haven't connected with
you know there were maybe
50 people here over the past two days
and in the bigger the more expensive
group I think there's 30 people or 20
people coming and I probably won't get
to talk to everybody
um probably not I mean maybe
but I'm not I'm not I I'm not judging
myself for not knowing everybody I'm not
judging myself for
how many business cards I leave with
though I don't do people you still use
business cards I don't have any business
cards I'm not judging myself by if I
connected with them or not it's more I'd
rather spend
time with a few people
who I can connect with on some kind of
level and
that ends up leaving to so much better
things Joe polich is the guy who runs
this so this is his office and he's the
one put puts his events together and
he's he's known as the most connected
man in the world right some of his bios
and websites will say people talk about
him he's the most connected man in the
world in hanging around him for the past
few days I can understand why so if
we're going to reverse engineer
Joe polishes success and he'll he'll say
that he's you know on the introverted
side
um
he's invited me to his home
he's I came in a couple days early and
helped him with his team and His Channel
and he invited me to stay at his home
today's our day off in between the two
events and he's invited me to go work
out with him and go do some IVs with
vitamins in it and go sit in a hot sauna
then jump in a nice cold bath and ask me
how I'm doing and what I'm up to and if
I need if I need anything or if I want
to use his office I mean I'm using I'm
using his office I guess the outside the
film today it's too beautiful today not
to film outside but but whatever I need
he doesn't just do that for anybody you
know he's not just going to open up his
home for anybody
and he's really trying to spend time
think about me if I would do that and I
think man probably not and so that's
that's maybe a learning for me because
I've run events I've hosted my own
events and they usually just knock me
out when I when I've hosted my thought
Leadership Academy in Toronto it would
knock me out I mean the last day of one
of the um
the last day of my event I remember I I
passed out like I had a break of 15
minutes and I I passed out and fell
asleep on a floor like on my dance floor
because I was giving so much and then my
my body gave out on me
and so I couldn't imagine then also like
Joe's got such a crazy week think about
how much people are paying him right
they pay him twenty five thousand
dollars for
the event that just finished and then a
hundred thousand dollars for the event
that's coming up
you gotta deliver some value right if
people are coming and they're paying a
hundred thousand dollars to be here that
that's
got to be at least for me incredibly
stressful to do that and while he's in
the middle of all of that he's worried
about me and how I'm doing and if I want
to stay with him and if I need to if I
want to go do some vitamin IVs and if
I'm being looked after if I need an
internet connection or a place to work
and the amount of text that he sent
while he's
in the sauna or working out or
doing his meetings
I was like how are you still thinking
about me you've got you've got so much
going on I don't I mean it's something
that that I'm honestly inspired by and I
find aspirational
but he does it so well
and it's like he can't do that for
everybody and so uh you know I'm
grateful I guess that he saw something
in me that he'd want to spend that kind
of time with
but he's very selective over who he
brings in and then once you're in he's
he's
gonna be the greatest resource of all
time and I think that's how you win
ultimately at least for me I think it's
a fantastic model for me to learn from
and keep trying to do better at and that
how can you win as an introvert when you
are networking
and trying to help people
introverts are great listeners
introverts care we want to help we want
to serve and we can't do it for
everybody because we let too many people
in we then we have no energy for
ourselves
and recognize that that's how you you
that's your secret superpower
let's do superpower
use superpower my superpower is to find
just a few people
at every place you go to your goal is
not to meet the whole event it's made a
few people
and figure out how you can help them and
genuinely help them like generally serve
them not not just if I help them do this
and they're gonna help me do that right
we're not don't don't approach it as a
transaction I think introverts are great
at this right it's not on transaction
you we value relationships
but are too afraid to go up and say hi
to people and don't like the The Fluffy
talk
so just make it a goal to find a few
people
and be of service and great things
happen
one of the things I've taken away and
just reinforced from the past couple
days is great things happen to me
and I'm I'm actually becoming less of a
gold person like where do you want to be
next year I have no idea because great
things happen to me
because if you keep pouring into other
people and keep bringing value and keep
helping
great things will happen to you that you
you never thought of
you know that you never thought would
exist and yet here they are now showing
up in your life
and so a challenge for you would be to
think about
whether it's the next event you're going
to or even just some people in your
network
like who do you already know
who are good people
be in the business of collecting good
people like who do you already know
who's a good person who who you
you want to serve and help on a deeper
level
and just find a way to reach out and
help them
be of service I make a list of of the
top kind of 100 people that I want to
stay in touch with because I'll forget
I'll forget to stay in touch and two
present-minded Focus but if I haven't
stayed in touch with them in the past 90
days I'll find some some way to help
whether it's sharing something on social
whether it's making a video giving them
some YouTube advice to just connecting
asking how it can be a resource
I schedule in the ongoing connection
because
these people have helped me a lot and I
want to continue to help them and if
you're just going strategy you know
continue to help successful people will
lead to you having more success because
it will they will find ways to come back
and help you you're almost guilting them
to do it even better is to not even be
as strategic about it
just by putting out good energy just by
serving others just by using that good
karma it comes
and in the process of giving if you can
remind yourself that great things happen
to you
that if I just keep showing up and
serving and helping and doing my very
best every day
great things will happen to me great
things will happen to you great things
will happen to you you just have to keep
going the biggest hack to stop caring
about other people's opinions to stop
living other people's version of your
life and to start actually feeling happy
and proud of yourself the biggest hack
to doing that is to figure out what you
stand for to figure out your single most
important core value I believe that
everybody has a single most important
core value and when you figure that out
it gives you a lot more clarity a lot
more Direction a lot more confidence and
allows you to start to to do things that
you never thought were possible all of a
sudden that idea that you've gotta oh my
gosh I could do this thing but then
never take an action on it things start
to happen for you because you have that
Clarity of value so I wrote two books on
this your one word and built to serve
and we go through the process of
figuring out your one word or your who
who are you what do you stand for what
is that single most important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out do I
just pick one at random do I just you
read a book like how do I actually
figure out what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math
is because they made you feel different
as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
Farr but I'm far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely use French
and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of of uh
High School
and she would meet with me every week
Force before school started once a week
we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk about
life we talk about school we talk about
where I was at we talked about what was
on my mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more that I
that her belief in me created more
belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask another one you can
look at is what was your favorite movie
growing up and why
what's your favorite movie of all time
why there's so many movies that you've
watched most of them you don't remember
but there's one that that sticks out
that really stands out for you in some
in some way for some reason my favorite
movie is Seabiscuit it's about this
horse that is way too small it's about
this jockey that's way too big it's
about this owner that's bankrupt and
somehow they all find each other and
start winning a whole bunch of races
when when they they shouldn't be you
know and it's based off of a true story
and it ended up lifting a nation that
people love this Underdog Story and it's
a story of belief same thing
it's a story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner and helping
not just each other believe in
themselves but also the nation
for the audience for the fans helping
them believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best version of
you
at my core I'm I'm the best when I
believe in myself and my biggest problem
is still I need to believe in myself
more to get to the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value your who your one word
what you need
my biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who was just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her
we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like
we're having an impact on people whether
the closest people to us or to the world
but we're stuck and we're lost and we
need guidance and if you feel like you
have all these ideas but you don't know
how they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example if I'm struggling to
do something I'm struggling to get on
stage to speak I'm struggling to turn on
the camera to make a video for you I'm
struggling to launch my next project you
know I get an idea and then I say oh man
I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what I really need
like what's the thing that's going to
turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
report the video to get on stage she
launch that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance also his who
was belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not hitting his goals and doing the
work it's because he doesn't feel like
he belongs doesn't feel like he belongs
to himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
stuck
if you are going too slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
and say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually feel that
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
the chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who
watch your life change this is where my
perfectionist nature you know used to
take over and slow me down so I could
get an idea and you get these ideas and
then your brain takes over and you start
researching like I gotta I gotta make
the perfect Plan before I start don't
make any mistakes so I'm just going to
start what I've trained myself to do
is two things
one
I tell myself that great ideas flow
through me
that great ideas will flow through me
because it came through me then it's a
great idea and what that does is kind of
shortcut the brain from over analyzing
over preparing and overthinking that as
long as you're in a good emotional state
right like you're like if you're
frustrated or pissed off or upset or
jealous maybe don't trust the ideas that
come to you you know like if somebody
cuts you off in line or in traffic and
you want to go chasing like maybe think
on that one but but if you're in a and
if you're in a positive place if you're
watching this episode and you're feeling
inspired or hopeful or or you want to do
more you're grateful trust the ideas
that come to you because those ideas
often don't make sense like your next
great idea doesn't make sense
because your brain tries to make sense
of it but it doesn't make sense but your
heart wants to do it so it's it's
listening to your heart and just
trusting that great ideas flow through
you from there to get over the
perfectionism uh I would I came up with
what I call the two percent difference
so what most people do is focus on how
do I plan to 100 I'm going to start a
podcast so I need to have look at Alan's
setup he's got the TVs and he's got the
microphone and he's got the right and
people would look at that I need all
that before I start the two percent
difference is if you trust a great ideas
flow through you then what's the first
two percent
what's the first two percent that you
can do right now just to get started and
don't expect it to be perfect expect it
to suck but momentum for most people is
the only thing that's missing
we often use our best energy on planning
and so you come up with an idea and then
you're planning you planning you plan
and plan your strategies and then a week
goes by and then you realize you don't
have the same courage and boldness that
you had a week ago and you spend all of
that great energy on planning instead of
doing where the first step should be to
do something
and then you start working on the plan
so if you want to work out you got to
get healthy you're cool what's the
perfect workout plan well did you do hit
do you do cardio do you hire trainer you
you go to the gym and lift weights like
what are you gonna do there's so many
options the best thing to do is just do
as many push-ups as you can right now
right you get on the floor and you do
five push-ups 20 push-ups like however
many you can do is that going to help
you long term get your result no it's
just one day of doing a thing but the it
solves the most important problem which
is momentum because if you do 10
push-ups today then you can do 12
tomorrow you can do 14 the next day you
could do 20 the next day and then as you
start applying maybe you realize hey
push-ups aren't the thing maybe you
should be doing pull-ups maybe you
should be doing yoga maybe right like
the plan always changes just like we
talked about the Allen from five years
ago could not plan to where the Allen is
right now the plan will always change
but the biggest thing is missing for
most people is just momentum so trust
that great ideas flow through you and
then apply the two percent difference to
just get started whatever you think the
problem is with cancer or or whatever
like well I think you know I think the
woman who solves cancer would have
solved it by now but she's a she's a
manager at an accounting firm hating her
life because she never either didn't
didn't go to medical school or never
even thought about it or uh just never
chase it down like I think everybody has
what I call Michael Jordan level genius
at something you're the greatest in the
world at something and we either don't
believe in that or we don't chase it
down and we end up living a life that is
less than what it could be and so even
me I mean my biggest problem is a lack
of belief to get to the next step and so
that's what I wake up every day trying
to solve um you know never gonna do it
and I wake up every day trying to do it
who's watching a YouTube video for three
hours the the entire world right like
think about if you're gonna teach if
you're gonna make a video talking about
how do you become an influential leader
where am I going to learn that from
nobody and the people who are sharing it
like go to YouTube and search people are
talking about it are they as good as
Rory Vaden on that topic no it's like
someone who came from Instagram and you
know they're 25 years old and still
trying to figure it out but they're
gaining a lot of traction and attention
because people like you who actually
know what they're talking about aren't
on the platform so there's giant demand
and consumption and very little very
little Supply period and and almost no
quality Supply so like am I too early am
I too late on YouTube we're just getting
started inside of Education uh so if I
wanted to learn how to become that
influential leader
if you did a four minute video how much
you're gonna teach me in four minutes
not a lot but if you talk for an hour or
you did a coaching session with somebody
or you had a guest coming on sharing
something people would watch that
because it's the best thing there
available and then when you've got your
next launch your book your course your
program your private membership like I
love this Rory guy nobody's talking like
him how do I get more of him and they
want to pay for the access to get into
everything that you're offering and so
you don't worry about giving away too
too much there I mean like uh I mean how
many of those videos is it is it kind of
more like have one really killer two
hour video
or are you trying to like crank because
to do that every week would be pretty
tough not to mention you know if you did
an hour-long video every week that'd be
that'd be a lot of content
um like what would you be charging for
if you were giving away that much so is
it kind of like have a couple key key
trainings out there and do it that way
or
it depends what game you're playing uh
often the best thing to sell is access
so the best thing to sell is access to a
community uh so if you're trying to sell
your your program your community which
is awesome I was able to you know I had
the honor to speak in front of if you
had a lot of long-form content that was
getting millions of views you're going
to convert a lot of those people to want
to spend more time with you because they
love how you think like you're you're a
weird duck you think differently than
other people like I want to think the
way Rory thinks and I want to be around
him more often so I want to join his
community
um it's less about the actual ideas a
lot a lot of people have paid programs a
lot of the same content is in the
YouTube video as in the paid program
it's just packaged all together so it's
easy to find it's sequential there's
Community there's access and so that's
really what we're selling not just the
information I'm I put out I'm giving you
everything I got nothing to sell here
I'm giving you the best like you're
asking me questions this is what I do is
what I teach people will still some of
the names that you mentioned want me
need to help them with their Channel I'm
telling them the same thing that I'm
telling you guys right now here on Rory
vaden's show right so that I think
builds credibility builds trust and it
makes people want to have a deeper
relationship with you and buy all your
stuff I think ultimately we're all built
to serve Eric right like we all want to
serve we all want to wake up and feel
like we're going to do something today
that matters and some days we feel like
we're going to change the world like if
you're listening to Eric's show you want
to have a big impact you want to change
the world you want to you want to have
big ripples across the planet right I
mean that's that's why you're here but
some days that feels too big and some
days
like I'm never going to change I can't
do that it's too big a mission cool but
you can help one person
yeah or what about like yourself
yeah definitely like whatever you need
whatever you want to give to the world
you still need yourself I think though
at the end of the day you want you want
to feel like what you're doing is
helping somebody else like if you're
only chasing down selfish Pursuits you
won't end up being happy like the
happiness will come from serving others
in some capacity either on some Grand
scale or or even just knowing that you
made an impact on one person today
somehow I I don't think it's possible to
feel down and negative and low and have
a terrible self-esteem if you are
actually helping something like when
somebody says thank you so much you
really helped me even if it's that
little moment the 10 seconds of like the
brightness and enjoying your life
because you did something that helped
somebody else out and so that's always a
path like we want to feel like what we
do matters is important to somebody else
um and that's what if you can connect to
that it's hard right you might have the
greatest day of all time today is great
I'm talking Eric it's amazing here we go
we're changing the world but let's do it
let's go Eric let's go pick up tomorrow
and it's like it's you're back to school
one you know it's like it's a it's a
it's like brushing your teeth you have
to do it every day you have to find a
way to connect to the mission that
you're on the connect the serving people
every single day otherwise it's an easy
slippery slope down to
uh you know apathy and uh if you keep
going down stress and anxiety and
depression and suicide because you feel
alone and you feel like you don't matter
and you feel like the work you do
doesn't matter you know like when you
feel like what you do doesn't matter the
next step becomes I don't matter and
when you're in I don't matter that's a
really dangerous Zone to be in and so
the path out is service helping every
day the editing Almost Doesn't Matter
like why are people listening to you
because like if we think about quality
content it people default the production
quality like oh what microphone using
their Rory and what's your headset and
like what's the lighting but nobody's
watching your stuff for your microphone
so the quality isn't production quality
it's quality of thought
can you teach me to think like you think
and so the mistake a lot of people make
is they if they're doing it themselves
at the beginning a lot of people do this
you spend 20 minutes uh making a video
and then five hours editing it
you're training the wrong skill
you're training yourself to learn
editing software as opposed to training
yourself to be a better speaker where
your ultimate goal should be to be a
better speaker train spend five hours
making a video and 20 minutes editing it
or zero time editing it because the
ability to communicate your message in
front of a camera will be a skill set
you use for the rest of your life
whether YouTube exists or not when we're
beaming into your your living room in VR
and eight Holograms and all that you're
still just talking to a camera
and so that ability to get your message
out there is the thing to train and
practice so I wouldn't worry about
editing being the most important thing
train yourself to be a great speaker
train yourself to press record deliver a
fire message and then release that as a
video because when you when I go live on
a podcast like this when I get up on
stage when I'm doing interviews there's
no edits I mean maybe if I really mess
up Rory will do me a solid and like cut
out that piece but we get on stage
doesn't know what it's like you can't
train yourself as if you're a speaker
you can't train yourself to only
communicate when you're perfectly edited
yeah so we have to train ourselves to be
great it doesn't mean that you
completely disrespect the editing but my
goal would be to hey let's get your
business up to the point where the
content is helping you generate enough
money whether it's through your coaching
or your books or your programs so that
then you can afford to hiring Editor to
take it to the next level but the
editing will not save you it's quality
of thought more than production quality
this is like the only thing I had going
for me you know like I wasn't I wasn't
super smart I wasn't charismatic I was
not getting any you know real success
like 2 000 subscribers five years in
um the only thing I had going for me is
I always focused on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't yeah
so for me it's like if I had 50 people
watch the videos like 50 people watching
a video I think it's pretty cool right
like those are 50 real people who saw
that like if you were gonna go give a a
speech at a library or something and 50
people showed up at least for me at the
beginning I'd be super nervous and
excited to go off and do that but when
it's online we feel like we're some kind
of failure and I'm ambitious and I want
to grow and I want to have a huge impact
and and it's great to chase numbers
um but I just always focus on who I was
actually helping I think that leads to a
lot more satisfaction doesn't lead to
doesn't mean you stay complacent and and
only like gratitude doesn't mean that
you have to stay stuck
but it it makes you feel more connected
to impact you know I think we all want
to wake up and feel like today is going
to matter that we're going to do
something today maybe we're going to
make something that hits a million
people or maybe we do something that
just touches one person's life but we
want to feel like today is going to
matter in some way and that's what I
always just if I saw 50 views on the
videos like this is weird to do that you
don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that I want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing
stuck keeps you small keeps you
frustrated keeps you knowing that you're
capable of more and being too afraid to
go take the action and until you can
break that pattern of negative self-talk
nothing will happen
so we're gonna fix that in this video I
think as soon as we come up with ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not capable that it's not
gonna happen
we'd land into
procrastination mode and you can call
yourself a perfectionist it has to be
perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out of
fear of being seen fear of not being
seen and it keeps you stuck
when I procrastinate on things even like
making videos
yeah I've made I don't know how many
twelve thousand thirteen thousand
fourteen thousand videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before I sit down to make the videos I
procrastinate a little bit
in today's filming session I'm here at
my wife's Acupuncture Clinic she's
inside getting her acupuncture done I
joined her sitting in the car and it
probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
The Zone I know I'm gonna make the
videos I've developed the identity that
I'm gonna get get it done but I'm I'm
worried I want I want the videos to be
good I wanted I don't want to embarrass
myself don't want to let myself down
don't want to let you down if you're
disappointing people is my my biggest
fear I don't want you to feel like this
is wasting your time ever had these
thoughts you know like you want to do
something and then you want it to be
good and you don't want to disappoint
people and so you him and you ha and you
procrastinate and then and then all of a
sudden the day is gone you haven't done
anything you know has that happened so I
try to keep it to 10 minutes 15 minutes
it is a little longer I'd usually be
like five ten minutes it took a little
bit longer 15 minutes today to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
what if I just check uh check and see
how my team is doing and and
because I want to feel valuable and
because I want to feel like I'm doing
something productive I want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no no
sit with it
we gotta we gotta change it we gotta go
we gotta make some content you're gonna
do this and make that first video so
even for me even for someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time I sit in front of the camera
to make a video the first one I
procrastinate I sit on it because I'm
afraid
and I don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal so if you feel like
whatever the thing is that you want to
do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal you're not there's nothing
wrong with you it's not abnormal it's
100 everybody goes through it
the difference is how quickly can you
shift how can you get unstuck because
most people just stay stuck they stay
constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just not just not coming
out
you're constipated
so how do you do it how do you shift it
here are a couple things that help me
that I hope can help you
number one is is floss the first tooth
take immediate momentum you think about
flossing
people don't want to floss I mean my
floss I've built the habit of flossing
twice a day most people don't floss and
the concept is just floss one tooth and
once you've floss one tooth you'll floss
the rats probably right just get your
running shoes on and go for a walk and
once you're walking you'll probably do
more than you know the two minutes that
you set yourself into mind like just do
two minutes so for me is just make the
first video
come on Evan just record the first video
so I recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and I'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this is amazing
come on
just get going just just go it's so much
easier to keep the momentum going once
you've built some momentum the hardest
step is the first step the hardest step
is just building that initial momentum
at the beginning once you get going it's
a lot easier to keep going so just start
don't don't make it some big thing don't
make it some giant Endeavor that you
have to go off and Chase it's nice to
have big goals and big Ambitions and Big
Dreams but sometimes they're too big and
then you feel like you can't do it and
you need venture capital and you need a
team and you need all sorts of things
before you can do anything on it it's
great to have that big goal and what are
you gonna do today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building up momentum
it's just so much so much so much so
much easier so the challenge for today
is just just find one small simple easy
way to get started that it doesn't have
to be amazing it doesn't have to be
great it's just the first step
once you get your first step it's so
much easier to take the second so that's
one just start building some immediate
momentum number two is change your state
one of the reasons why I like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car I like I like being
out I like I like being out of the place
out of my home I like I like energy I
like nature I like being able to see
trees and and sunshine and have people
around you know I like I like that it
changes my state it's it makes it a lot
easier for me to go off and film when
I'm by myself so it's not just
um me talking to the camera if this
feels more conversational I don't know
game
but it feels more I feel like I'm
talking to a friend hello how you doing
I'm Evan it feels it feels more
conversational and natural for me I like
having the sun on my face you know it
just feels better and so changing your
state can be a good way if you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space that
you're thinking negatively in really
helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
really helps I promise you have you ever
had a uh you're thinking really
negatively
you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room where you go to a different part of
the house or you go for a drive and then
you feel better like changing the
physical environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus to
that is music music I should have done
that today music is
the fastest way to change your state so
while I was sitting here in the car for
15 minutes procrastinating and making
these videos instead of thinking hey I
should go and check in on my team and
see how they're doing underneath like
logically that makes sense like how's my
team doing I'm being a good boss you
know good manager a good friend I should
check in on them see how they're doing
it's going to move my goals forward of
course because if they're waiting on me
for something right logically all that
makes sense underneath it is just again
the fear that my videos won't be good
enough so I need to feel productive I
need to feel value valuable to myself I
need to feel worthy so I'm going to
spend my time there instead of making
videos right I should have put on music
when that was happening
instead of going to check out my team
which I didn't do but wanted to uh I
should have put on some music
put on some music that makes you move
and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head bobbin
or your foot tapping or your knee
bouncing just songs that make you come
alive and there's no one Perfect song
but whatever song gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get unstuck and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is a fast way to change
your state and then number three is I
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall the things that you could
put in your life to remind you of who
you want to be so I'll share a couple of
them from my example in my office I have
five pictures on the wall and they all
tell a different story remind me of who
I want to be I've got Steve Jobs on the
wall who reminds me to be a Visionary
I've got epginini on the wall who's my
favorite entrepreneur of all time and he
reminds me to to believe in
um in the little guy and what I'm trying
to do I've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself I've
got Howard Schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important they've got Kanye on the wall
to remind me that the time is now that I
have to go do something now to be the
greatest me and
those pictures I picked with intention
and when I walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and I don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be I walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself the clothes that you wear right I
wear I wear this is my believe hoodie I
feel like I'm Batman I tell myself when
I put this on I'm Batman I'm a superhero
going to work fighting
the crime of lack of belief
right and and so somebody commented on
my hoodie yesterday's like you're always
wearing you're always on brand you're
always wearing your hoodie it's like
it's not just it's not just when I show
up to make videos this is this is this
is what I wear because I'm a I'm a
superhero going to work and when I put
this on in the morning it's like I'm I'm
Batman going to work or uh uh you know
police officer going to work it's like
this is this is what I do and
I'm a lot more for me
productive and ambitious and bold when
I'm wearing this compared to when I'm in
my pajamas
Intel is a conscious choice to say okay
what do I want to wear and so the
artwork on my wall the background on my
cell phone the computer screen
background the the things that I wear
right play bigger triggers
that you ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is that this is who I want to
be this is who I want to be this is who
I want to be I'm around the things that
make me remember what I'm trying to do
because your brain will trick you to
stay small your brain will trick you to
stay stuck your brain will trick you to
say yeah you you can't do that and
here's all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons you are really
you're just afraid I'm just afraid I'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid they're going to be judged we're
afraid of disappointing people we're
afraid of not being loved we're afraid
that
we're going to be seen and gonna be made
fun of you know we're just afraid at the
end of the day you me everybody we're
just we're just afraid that the reason
why you're stuck is you're afraid and so
when you can learn to catch those
feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them say you know
what
I'm going to change my environment I'm
going to change my state I'm going to
change what I'm listening to I'm going
to change what I'm wearing I'm going to
change my mind and I'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great Soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in 6 months and 12 months you can
it's possible you can your mission is
worthy and Noble and should happen and
you're the one to do it you you're the
one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum you're just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step my key to being productive is
doing different things on different days
different activities different energy
states on different days if you feel
like you're getting to the end of the
day you're getting to the end of the
week and you're working like crazy like
you're working you you were not sucking
off you're working like crazy and yet
nothing seemed to happen have you gotten
there it's like I did so much work this
week and yet I've moved very little
towards actually accomplishing my goals
if that's you
the way to change it is to realize that
you're flipping between energy states
too much and you're not you're not
tapping into your true productivity so
let me share with you what I do and
hopefully that gives you some value to
planning your schedule in your life as
well
different tasks on different days I'll
break down for you what I do every day
of the week
Monday is my mentoring day Mondays are
the days where I spend mentoring my team
and you've got 37 people on my team
there's a bunch of people I've invested
into as well in their companies and
Monday I just spend the whole day
talking to them all I have to worry
about is mentoring the people on my team
Tuesday is YouTube day so today I'm
filming on a Tuesday I don't know what
day this video is being released but
it's a Tuesday for me filming all I have
to worry about on a Tuesday is making
YouTube content and why it's so
productive these days is because it
takes a while to make the first video it
takes a while to do the first call takes
a while to get momentum going but once
you get the momentum going
it's easier to stay in the momentum than
if you switch to something else it takes
a lot longer to get into that momentum
so quick example it's YouTube day for me
it took me 15 minutes to get ready for
the first video and not get ready like I
have to do my hair
get ready just emotionally get ready
mentally get get ready not procrastinate
get ready to bring the energy and have
the right Vibe and feel good enough and
and all of the stuff it takes took me 15
minutes to get ready and then the first
video
it takes it takes a while to get the
Mojo going and then after the first
video the second one is better and the
third one is better this is my fourth
one recording is better and now it's
easier to go right and so in the time it
takes me to make one video the first
video I could then in that same amount
of time go make three or four videos
intermediate intermediate I want to say
sequential that's not a word succession
succession intermediate succession
whatever
after I can make three or four more
videos right after while I'm in that
same Vibe so same thing for you whatever
Vibe you're feeling if you can stay in
that energy Zone instead of switching if
I did YouTube video then write in a book
then doing a phone call that meant for
my team then you're just bouncing around
too much in this high high high energy
switching costs that then keep you
unproductive then this is I mean a huge
unlock because when you can figure out
how to chunk your time like this brain
fog goes away productivity dramatically
increases you suddenly have a lot more
free time as well to do whatever you
want to do Nina is back she's in the
house
we are at Nina's acupuncture let me put
my seatbelt on as we well as we get
ready to go
so Tuesday's YouTube day and I spend the
whole day making videos Wednesday is
Project day and on Project day I focus
on whatever projects I want to work on
and it's
I wake up in the morning I look at what
do I want to work on today and it's a
it's a lot more of a creative day
Tuesdays and Thursdays are very intense
productive days Wednesday is a
free-flowing day which is not very
productive but very creative what I had
to understand is creativity is messy and
creativity is not productive so I would
judge myself harshly when I was working
on a new project and it would take me a
long time and I felt like I got nothing
done that's okay like creativity is not
meant to be efficient
so you won't be efficient on your
creative days or in your creative tasks
it won't be efficient for you but that's
okay and I think you need to have
creative time built into your calendar
because if you're only doing things that
are productive you're going to burn out
you're going to hit your life and you're
gonna feel limited you ever get bored of
your own business you get bored of the
things you're doing well there's not
enough creative time planned into your
week when do you get time to work on new
fun things that maybe pay off maybe
don't pay off when you have time to work
on that well you don't okay so that's
when people have midlife crisis or
burnout or want to throw it all away or
quit or stop doing this thing and so I
think you have to have some highly
productive days where you're really
working on achieving the goals that you
know I have to get these things done and
then you have to have some creative days
where you get to focus on whatever
projects you want that you're not
judging yourself harshly for being you
know not very efficient creativity is
messy it's designed to be that way and
you need to have some creative days in
your calendar or you will get tired of
your business
so that's Wednesday Wednesday's creative
Day project day Thursday is public
facing day and Thursdays
I'm usually starting the day with either
movement makers or brand lytics and I'm
I'm introverted and shy and that doesn't
come across in these videos but I am and
it takes me a while to to get into the
zone of being around other people
[Laughter]
on Thursdays I start with my family and
movement makers are my community of
thought leaders are trying to build
their business and get their message to
the world and Brent Linux is my
community of people on YouTube who want
to build their YouTube channel up
specifically and want the advice to to
grow and create and so I start my
Thursdays with them because it's it's
family it's safe it's friendly it's warm
and it makes me feel like what I do
matters and is important and then the
rest of Thursday is interviews and
podcasts and in Zoom calls and just all
day spreading the message
spreading the message you know we got we
got believed to put out there and it's
easy to go off and do those things now
because I just came from movement makers
or brandytics so I'm already in the in
the zone of sharing and creating and
impacting and seeing smiles and so I
carry that energy into my next interview
on my next podcast and the next thing
that I'm doing so if I'm booking to be
on other people's shows even if I'm
booking for my own show Thursdays it's
always on a Thursday it's always on a
Thursday it's always on a Thursday and I
have five minute breaks in between so
it's usually 25 minutes or 55 minutes
and then five minute break and then on
to the next one on to the next one and
so it's really easy and all of a sudden
it's seven o'clock and
what happened to today I don't know but
amazing things happened because you're
all in that energy and you know do tons
of different shows and episodes and it's
again so much easier to be in that in
that one zone than to then go make a
YouTube video or then go and wrap my
book or then you know book writing was a
creative project so it's on a Wednesday
it took me an hour just to get into
remembering what I did yesterday or last
week on my book right so if you only
give yourself an hour to write the book
that would be absolute waste of time
because it took me an hour to remember
where I left off last time
uh since there's a public-facing day
Friday is CEO day so that's what do we
need to do to grow my business you know
what what are the big projects instead
of working in my business work on the
business so Wednesday's work in the
business on Creative projects Friday is
if I'm going to be the CEO of my
business what does that look like what
do I need to be doing because if you're
an entrepreneur you're you're the CEO
you're probably the janitor as well if
you're a one-person show and we have to
do a lot of things to drive the business
forward we have to be in our business we
don't have a giant team yet even at 37
people I do a lot of work in the
business as opposed to only just being
the CEO and just managing and
truthfully I like being in the business
I like like making videos like this is
not CEO time this is me being in the
business but I like it you know I think
I think people who often just be the CEO
if you're entrepreneurial and there's no
projects you're working on uh you you
grow distant from the business you don't
enjoy it so we all need time in our
calendar every week to focus on being
the CEO and now I spend all my Fridays
doing it at the beginning I just started
with two hours so two hours in my
calendar okay this is my CEO time and I
blocked it off and it made it important
and when I started doing that I started
seeing more results in my company
Saturday we applied to the weekends too
Saturday is fun day so Saturday spending
time with Nia doing whatever you know
going and starting to get warm here in
Canada you can you can see you know the
grass finally green so if we're going
for a hike or trying out a restaurant or
going to uh street festival or just
something fun Sunday is family at midday
so all of the stuff that we have to do
to manage the family you know go grocery
shopping fold laundry clean up the house
family admin kind of stuff that's on a
Sunday and then repeat the next day so
again quick summary Monday is mentoring
day Tuesday is YouTube day Wednesday's
project day Thursday is public facing
day Friday CEO day Saturday fun day and
Sunday is family admin day and that fits
my life
you know that's a calendar for my life
it won't photocopy perfectly over to
yours but the key is to chunk your time
and think about what is a balanced life
look like for me so that I'm happy I'm
creative I'm productive I'm moving
closer to becoming the person that I
want to be and if you can't control
your calendar fully maybe you have a job
maybe you have other responsibilities
maybe you're still stuck doing some
things you don't want to do that's cool
don't don't stress out and worry about
oh I can't I can't completely control my
day I can't have a YouTube day okay
don't worry about it you have some
controllable time focus on the control
of the time you have and just be more
intentional with it
so that you're not wasting time
scrolling through Instagram posts or
YouTube videos mindlessly that that
you're you're there with intention and
you're gonna you have so many you have a
certain amount of controllable hours I
think part of the advantage of being an
entrepreneur is we have a lot more
controllable hours right if you're a
full-time entrepreneur you get the
control sure we have to you know
be uh
be responsive to our customers but we
don't have a boss
and we get to choose when we show up and
we get to choose what our calendar looks
like and that's part of the Allure being
an entrepreneur is that freedom but if
you're not completely there yet you
still have controllable hours when you
get home from work to the time you go to
bed when you wake up to the time you go
to work and then on weekends you have
controllable hours
be more intentional with them
and decide what is the life that you
want to live that'll come down to then
the habits that you're executing on
daily which comes down to your calendar
and when you can chunk similar tasks
together
when you can stay in the same energy
Zone instead of switching between a
million different tasks every day it
allows you to be more productive it
allows you to be more effective it
allows you to be happier and allows you
to get a lot closer to your goals the
fastest way to shift your mindset in a
positive direction is to choose to show
up with love if you're stressed out if
you're fearful if you've got anxiety if
you're low on energy just shift just
tell yourself I'm gonna show up with
love and see how that moves you forward
in a positive direction otherwise you
get stuck you stay stuck because you
listen to the voices in your hand as to
you're not good enough why you can't do
it and everybody's doing better than you
and and so on where when you can choose
a show with love it just negates all of
that so let me share a couple examples
that I've used it in my life and
hopefully it applies to your life as
well to help you get the momentum that
you need so scenario number one is when
you're stressed out when you are
overwhelmed when you're doing something
scary or you're in doubt and you come up
with all these reasons why you can't do
something so for me it's staying on
stage you know going on stage doing a
big presentation even making these
videos every time before doing something
that I want to be good that I'm worried
about that I might disappoint somebody
the procrastination sets in the fearful
thoughts set in because I want to be the
best that I've ever done
my biggest fear is still disappointing
people and instead of listening to those
thoughts and how it may show up is oh
um my message isn't good enough oh I
don't know what gear to use maybe not in
my case for that one but what prevents
you from doing it this logical reasons
but really just fear talking where if
you can
decide you know if I'm making this video
is it my best video of all time maybe I
want it to be is it likely not but I'm
trying
and the way through that I just show up
with love like I love you I love you
thank you for being here thank you for
investing in yourself thank you for
putting putting goodness out into the
world you know I make these videos
because you can reach people that I
can't your business your heart your soul
your your beliefs what you've been
through your story can touch people and
change the world in the way that I can't
and so if I can be a little bit of a
push motivation whatever to help you
start doing something that makes me
happy it fills me up knowing that that
what I'm doing matters is unimportant
right so show up with love that's all I
have to do don't worry about it being
the best video of all time just show up
with love don't worry about it being the
best speech of all time just show up
with love remember why you're doing it
it's another version of it right like
why are you doing this thing but not
from an extra pressure you know if you
if you feel over pressured to be great
then that can be debilitating to the
point where you freeze a lot of
procrastinations you're just afraid to
do the thing and so choose to show up
with love I love this person I love who
I'm trying to help even if you don't
know them right some of you are watching
this video I've never met you before
thank you for being here
even if you say I love you even mentally
I love this person I love I love my eyes
I love my customers even if you haven't
met them yet it rewires you it just
makes it so much easier try it like
whether you procrastinating on that you
want to get done that you know you want
to get done not that that you don't want
to do but you want to do it's part of
your goals it's your Ambitions that you
hope one day you could be that person
right what are you procrastinate on and
just flip it from having to be perfect
to saying I love these people I'm gonna
show up with love and watch it just
shift you so you can actually start
taking some momentum it's a huge huge
huge huge huge thing for anything that
you're procrastinating on that you're
afraid of so scenario number one
uh the things that you're afraid of
scenario two is is people and
specifically the people who are who are
negative the haters that we might call
it I don't actually like the term haters
I don't I don't think there are haters I
think there's just people who are in a
lot of pain you know I think if somebody
is
highlight of their days to show up and
leave something negative on your website
on your YouTube video on your social
media accounts whatever they're in a lot
of pain you know I think people are
built to serve we are good we want to
help we want to we want to contribute
and so somebody that's everybody like
everybody wants to serve so if somebody
is showing up with negativity in their
heart thrown at you when they've never
even met you before
uh why would they do that well they're
in a lot of pain
hurt people hurt people
and so
a lot of times we get emotional you know
we don't like seeing those negative
comments I don't like seeing negative
comments even on a channel like mine
where it's only positivity I'm not
making bash videos on people
if somebody's gonna show up to a Channel
about positivity and leave negative
comments how how much in pain do they
need to be in to do that and even just
seeing it like that already starts to
shift it but what if you were to say I
love this person like how would you show
up if you love that if you loved your
hater
not because it fuels you to go prove
them wrong and be better but
feel bad for them not sorry for them but
just have empathy for them and say you
love them like if you love this person
how would you show up differently
instead of allowing that comment that
they left on your video to ruin your day
to me to maybe make you never post again
to get into a fight or debate or respond
uh to them you know and try to win win
the battle instead of that if you
actually said hey I love this person
even if you don't like you don't know
them you might think well that's
ridiculous I don't know this person I
get I know I understand this is not your
mom coming on your YouTube channel and
saying that you suck it's some random
stranger you've never met and maybe you
don't even know who they are and you
can't see their name and their profile
picture is a cartoon right or soccer
player uh so that's fine but even if you
just say I love this person how would it
change if you love this person and watch
it shift you watch the chemicals and you
start to shift towards you now being
more proud of yourself if you show up
with love it allows you to have the
courage to be the person who you want to
be who you're proud of like when you get
some negative comment and then you
respond in a really snarky way or you
show up somebody slights you some way
somebody cuts you off in traffic I'm in
my car right now somebody cuts you off
in traffic and you have to you have to
catch up to them and give them the look
or cut them off or Blast Your Horn you
know if you actually thought about that
are you ever proud of yourself
are you proud of yourself in those
moments like if you reflect back and say
see what you did in reaction are you
proud of how you showed up probably not
right probably not at least I'm not when
that happens and so the way through it
is is to show up with love like even
just tell yourself I love this person
I'll practice it with random people on
the streets you know like I'm walking
down the street and somebody comes by
and like I love this person just as a
mental exercise of practice how do you
show up instead of just being head down
ignoring them you know looking at your
phone maybe give them a smile it feels
really weird especially as an introvert
shy person
um I don't go up and say hi to people
but it's a good practice to get into but
especially for the haters like number
one and two one is again you're afraid
you're stuck you're overthinking
stressed out and number two is you're
you're also afraid but of people's
opinions and specifically the negativity
that's out there what they do is they
prevent you from taking action it keeps
you out of momentum
you're just stuck in fear Zone instead
of creation Zone and so
the opposite of fear is love
it's not hate like the opposite of Love
isn't hate the opposite of Love is fear
and so it allows you to get out of the
fearful mindset and into a loving
mindset which is not just Fufu Fufu what
I don't know fluffy it's not it's not
you know what I'm saying it gives you
into momentum mode moving from Fear To
Love allows you to take action and
that's what makes it super practical
so
have love even in your own mind for who
you're trying to serve and what you're
trying to create have love for any
negativity any people who are who are
criticizing you they're not haters
they're just people in a lot of pain and
show them love
and watch how it shifts you into
momentum and in the third scenario is
loving for yourself
a lot of times you seem to love
ourselves more so the first two are
loved that are outwardly pointed right
out toward our customers or the audience
towards people who are disagreeing with
us or disrespecting us or hating hating
on us but the third one is just
self-love more self-compassion self-love
love love that you showed up today love
that you decided to watch this video
today love that you're you're fighting
to chase down your goals and your dreams
even in the face of not getting a lot of
results or not being where you want to
be you know you're you're probably not
where you want to be right now and maybe
you're not proud of the week that you've
had or the day that you've had or the
month that you had or the year that
you've had that you could have done
better you should be you should be
further ahead right has you ever thought
has that ever popped into your mind
so self-love again allows you to get
into momentum so what can you be proud
of yourself for so love that you showed
up love that you're trying today love
that you're watching this video right
now love that you're making another
attempt even if you fail that a million
other times you're trying again like
love that love that you're starting love
that you're learning love that you're
adapting love that love that you're
gonna put your fourth your best shot
this time and maybe this is the one that
actually sticks like love that about
yourself as opposed to just beating
yourself up and say oh well here I am
again you know another thing that's not
gonna work because again that keeps you
stuck
all of this does two things
it allows you to actually build the
thing that you want to build
right it allows you to be proud of
yourself it allows you to start getting
more results start getting closer to
your dreams because you're showing up
with love instead of fear right love is
the opposite of fear and two it allows
you to have more fun along the way
so that you're not just constantly
stressed out of jumping from one problem
to another problem to another problem to
another problem because entrepreneurship
is a lot of problems right you have a
lot of problems running your business a
lot and and we're professional
firefighters just constantly putting up
fires so if you can do that would love
it's a lot more fun
this is a lot more fun
so it allows you to be more productive
and effective and it's a lot more fun
and so I think love is a strategy love
is a secret ingredient and it's
something that I need to I'm not perfect
at it I need to constantly remind myself
of it this video is a great refresher
for myself as well and the more that you
can have that as a reminder in your
daily environment as a as a mantra as
something that you live your life by to
choose to show up with love for your
customers for your haters and for
yourself
you can start to embody that even five
percent of the time the entire life
changes appreciation does not equal
complacency one of the biggest things
that I think we struggle as
entrepreneurs or as ambitious people is
you feel like if you start being really
appreciative of what you have then you
won't want to go off and do more and
that by being grateful or being
appreciative of what you've got it's
somehow squashes your ambition to go and
create more has you ever thought about
that I have
and what I've realized over the years is
that it's the exact opposite at least
for me that the more I can lean in on
appreciation the more I can lean in on
what I do have it actually gives me
the motivation to want to go off and do
more
hey if
but for example whenever
I look at my main Channel we've got
three million subscribers Plus on the
main Channel when I can connect to I'm
so appreciative of having three million
subscribers on my main Channel it gives
me when I can feel it when I when it's
actually in my heart it's like why I
can't believe that we have three million
subscribers that we've got 500 million
views that
that more than a population of the
United States in terms of the views on
the channel it sounds crazy
whenever I can actually connect to that
in my heart not just that oh that's
really good like a logical brain thing
but in my heart
it makes me want to do more it makes me
want to serve more makes me want to help
more makes me want to do more videos and
make me feel like what I do matters and
is important and I honestly think that
this is one of the biggest reasons why
I kept going
if you look at my channel the main one
we started in 2009 so many many years
ago and I've posted my progress of how
well the Channel's done over the years
in five years in I had seven thousand
subscribers something like that can you
imagine five years of making videos and
you're still at seven thousand
subscribers uh and you know year one was
under 100 subscribers and anyway you
could see the growth on the website what
kept me going
I was shy I was introverted I was scared
to make videos what kept me going what
kept me going what kept me going people
ask me all this how did you not burn out
what kept you going when you weren't
seeing a lot of results
what kept me going was I always focused
on who I was serving instead of who I
wasn't
I did a live stream last night on my uh
much newer gaming channel and we had I
don't know seven people who were
consistent in the chat
why why show up why do it why how is
that not a waste of time you know like
why should I not be doing something else
because I focused on the seven people
who were there
and I ended up making
a great connection for two of the people
there's a guy named Michael who has a
channel focused on helping people
understand people with disabilities and
he he brings on able-bodied people to
ask questions that might be
uncomfortable questions about what it's
like living with a disability
and while he was on the live stream last
night I thought of another friend of
mine Nick Tabor and I thought that the
two of them would get along really well
and I ended up making a quick
introduction for the two of them and now
they're connected gonna make some
content and and who knows maybe maybe
that leads to Noah nowhere or maybe they
become best friends and launch a billion
dollar business together I don't know
but it feels like it matters
it feels like yesterday mattered that
that stream yesterday mattered that even
though there are only only seven people
on the stream it felt like it matters it
felt like what I do matters to somebody
and at the end of the day that's what we
all want
you want to feel like you're going to
wake up today and do something that's
going to matter to somebody in a
meaningful Deep Way
and so you can be grateful for that you
can appreciate that and in knowing that
it inspires me to want to go off and do
more it's not the opposite it's not that
oh I'm so grateful and appreciated that
we had this great session last night and
so now I'm not gonna make any more
content
and gratitude for what you have actually
lets you go off and create more
it puts you in a much better much more
positive much more service mindset
to want to go off and create even bigger
scale things
so in my first videos when I was
struggling and didn't believe in myself
and had no confidence and
this is the only thing I had going for
me was I kept going and why did I keep
going is because I just always for
whatever reason there was no strategy
behind it there was no coach guiding me
I I maybe got lucky or maybe it was just
um great parenting
but I had the mindset of the time that
hey
40 people saw this video
that's really cool
I'm helping somebody
and that's what kept me going
it took me 350 videos before I wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself and 700
videos until I inspired myself with one
of my own videos where I watched it back
and I could finally start feeling proud
700 videos before I finally started
feeling proud of what I was making that
I could watch my own videos back and not
cringe so if that's you if you're
starting and you watch your own videos
back and you think that you suck well
hey that was me too
and it took 700 public videos before I
didn't think that I completely sucked
but I kept going because I felt like it
mattered because at least for one person
maybe you maybe you watching this video
it's still what I use today maybe maybe
this is the video that
encourages you to keep going that
encourages you to be a little more
appreciative that encourages you to
share a little bit more to say yes a
little bit more to take that idea that
you've got in your brain and actually go
and do something on like maybe this is
the video that pushes you just a little
bit forward to go off and do it use it
as permission to say hey I've got great
ideas
and I want to serve and it's finally
time for me to step up
you know it's finally time whether it
works or not I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
a little bit more today because it might
help one person and if this is the video
that gives you the permission to go and
Chase down that idea that's it that's
why I do what I do
and as much as I love the numbers and
it's great you know yes I want to hit 5
million subscribers and 10 million
subscribers and whatever I want to solve
the world's biggest problem right
people don't believe in themselves
enough that's the biggest problem in the
world I'm never gonna do it and I wake
up every day trying to do it but the
thing that keeps me going
is the appreciation and gratitude for
what I have done and what I have in my
life
you could stretch that to gratitude for
your health I actually just came back
from the doctor's office
um
I'm getting
immunotherapy done where I I used to
have really bad allergies to trees like
there trees and grass would cause crazy
allergies and I discovered immunotherapy
where they basically put a little bit of
tree and grass under your skin once a
month and slowly your body gets used to
it so now I can walk out without having
allergies I used to be taking two
allergy pills a day from early spring to
late fall almost the entire year just
winter off because I struggled so much
with my allergies and now I don't
and in being grateful and appreciative
of my health even as I'm saying these
words out loud where my brain goes next
is I want to have more health
so it's the opposite right we think that
if you're grateful and appreciative for
what you have you won't be ambitious and
want more but it's the opposite as I
think about my health and how grateful I
am to not have allergies right now to
not be struggling right now to not be on
multiple allergy pills right now
now I wanna now I want to be healthier
now now I want to go for a run now I
want to make a extra salad like I want
to invest more in my health because
there's momentum behind it
and so wherever you apply appreciation
and gratitude you'll see that area of
your life start to multiply
so if you're grateful for the
relationships in your life you'll see
those relationships get better if you're
appreciative for what you've done in
your business so far even though it's
not where you want to be listen you're
never going to be where you want to be
but if you're grateful and appreciative
for what you have done already in your
business it'll give you momentum to go
and create more
so wherever you apply gratitude and
appreciation that area of your life will
multiply will get better we'll continue
to improve
I want you to think about the opposite
you know again we we think that
gratitude and appreciation leads to
complacency
it doesn't
[Music]
we think that being appreciative for
what we have makes us less of an
ambitious person it doesn't it's the
opposite lean in on gratitude and
appreciation and watch your entire life
change the key to getting the life that
you want is figuring out what you're
going to say no to you can get anything
that you want you just can't get
everything that you want all at once and
if you're feeling like you're behind
you're unhappy you're not getting
anywhere close to your goals you're not
getting any kind of momentum towards
achieving anything then you have to
start really examining what are you
going to say no to where do we need to
raise the bar raise our standards and
stop saying yes to people to ideas that
don't ultimately serve where you want to
go so my son just finished having a
month off of school and so I had him for
a whole month no school and I decided
for that month that I would
spend a lot of time with him that
instead of him just being over me
working and spending evenings together
that I would I would spend most of the
time with him so I was I went from
working one of our normal work hours are
down to 10 percent 10 of the work hours
are canceled almost all of my meetings I
canceled almost all of my calls I didn't
do any Instagram lives the only ongoing
one that I kept was my movement makers
and branalytics program that I that I
train on Thursdays and that was almost
it I still stayed on top of email but I
wasn't doing most of the things that I
was normally doing I said no to most
things I said no to media opportunities
I said no to speaking opportunities I
said no to new ideas for this YouTube
channel and my other YouTube channels I
said no to almost everything I put up a
boundary for the month because I wanted
to be able to spend the time with my son
and we had an amazing time and it was
awesome and I took him to La he wanted
to be an actor so he took him to LA and
we went on some of the studio tours in
the tahalud Walk of Fame and all of that
fun stuff it was his first time there
and it was amazing I don't regret any of
it and also when I came back there was a
mountain of work that that I had to do
there's a mountain of emails to get back
to there's a mountain of uh people that
I needed to connect with and so it's
just making a decision as to what do I
want in my life especially right now and
are the things that I'm doing leading me
towards it or not and if there's people
that are not just getting in your way
but people who are bringing you down
people who are pulling you off in a
different direction everybody has an
agenda for your life right everybody has
ideas for what you should be doing with
your life
and we're constantly being pulled in a
million different directions so how do
you know which is the right one to do
well the process that I go through is I
start by one figuring out what is what
is my most important core value so mine
is belief right what is your most
important core value if you're being
pulled in many different directions by
all sorts of people who have plans for
what you should do with your life
until you understand what you stand for
as a human you're going to constantly
being be pulled in all those Milling
directions and never feel like you have
any safe spot to stand on you're going
to feel like you're in quicksand all the
time so what is your single most
important core value maybe one already
comes to mind maybe you've already done
this exercise you already know it but
that's a constant reminder and if you
don't know what your most important core
value is I go through it in year one
word and build the serve but basically
think about all the things that have
made you come alive the people that
you've loved the movies you loved
watching your favorite teacher of all
time what's the common thread between
all of them it's a feeling it's an
emotion your favorite teacher
growing up wasn't because they taught
you mine was mad I'm far it wasn't
because she taught me French it's
because she made me believe in myself
more right so all those great things
that made you come alive what's the
consistent thread between those things
and that's what you need more of right
now and it's what you need more of in
the future going into your life so the
projects that don't feel right the
people who are pushing you in the wrong
direction it could be from a really
loving place but if it doesn't match up
with your most important core Value Plus
the goals that you're trying to
accomplish then then it's not a fit and
I don't I don't think you have to have
necessarily tough conversations with
toxic people just stop spending time
with them
you know just stop spending as much time
with them if there's people who are
constantly negative around you just stop
spending time with them raise the bar
for what you accept into your life
you know and so the willingness to say
no to understand that you can't have
everything but you can have anything and
being super clear on what that anything
is and by going after that anything
like going after your big goals it
requires you to say no to other things
and this isn't just a business thing
this is for any goal that you've got if
you've got a health goal right if you've
got a health goal
while you you can have anything you want
you can go have pizza and donuts and
beer and whatever you can go eat that
you'll feel great in the moment but you
can't have you can't have everything
because you'll end up being overweight
and unhealthy and and not probably not
happy with your life if you are happy
great keep going off and doing it but
you know this morning I've got my my
coffee I go on I believe walk every
morning I spend time thinking about what
I want today to look like I'm making
YouTube videos with my intention I'm
going to want to put out there to the
world go get a coffee for myself and
Nina and it's and it's just a coffee
it's not what I love to go to Tim
Hortons and Canadian brand if you don't
know Tim Hortons and get a farmer's wrap
with bacon and sausage and egg and hash
brown in a Boston cream donut of course
my mouth is water as I'm saying all that
stuff but I'm not doing it because I've
got a health goal and so I can have
anything but I can't have everything and
so it's the willingness to say no to
those other things that may even bring
you some kind of short-term benefit but
are in alignment with who you want to be
so it's getting really clear on on who
you are what's your most important core
value and then what are the goals that
you want for yourself and then the
things that do that no longer kind of
match up the activities if you want to
hit your goals it's the activities and
the habits that you're doing on a daily
basis right eating eating a donut every
now and then it's not something in the
world eating the donut every day you're
gonna not hit your health goals so it's
more about what are you doing
consistently every day if you're around
negative people constantly
every day you're going to be a lot more
negative if you're on them every now and
then it's not going to make that big of
an impact so you are where you
consistently do and so it's choosing to
show up in a certain way to say no and
sending boundaries and raising the
standard for what you consistently
accept into your life and it's a choice
it's a decision and you don't have to
make some giant decision like I'm only
going to hang around millionaires now I
mean you could if you want but a lot of
these decisions are made in increments
that it's much more important what are
you doing today and then tomorrow and
then the next day in these micro
improvements that you're going to make
where you're
constantly and never endingly is that a
word neverendingly never endingly raised
in the bar for what you accept into your
life and one of my favorite ways to do
it is content is videos
feel like you're kind of stuck and you
haven't grown in a while and the friends
around you are just thinking small and
they're they're not inspiring you and
you feel stuck if you look back on the
past year of your life have you grown
are you further ahead do you know more
are you more confident have you
accomplished more are you moving closely
towards your goals are you proud of the
person that you have become right in the
past year and if no then it's changing
the environment to be around the people
who are like who you want to be and I
find content is the best way to do it
it's why I make these videos it's why I
do my main channel it's why I do so much
content that whether you're learning
from me or Bill Gates or Oprah Winfrey
or Tony Robbins or Lisa Nichols or
whoever that there's always something
every day to be there for you
um I believe walks in the morning I
always listen to one of my videos so on
my walk on the walk to get the coffee
I'm usually doing videos myself
responded to people on Instagram and DMS
and just sending out love and feeling
like I'm part of the community and the
work I do matters and then on the way
back because I have two cups of coffee
in my hand I can't record videos so I'm
listening and watching uh one of the
videos from my channel and I love
starting my day with a Warren Buffett or
an Elon Musk or whoever in my ears
because it pushes me forward no matter
how big I'm thinking how great I am the
work that I'm doing I love being around
people who are doing more and it pushes
me forward and no matter how great a day
I had yesterday
today feels like a new day
you have the greatest day of all time
yesterday but that that buzz that high
Fades the feeling like your Unstoppable
Fades and so it's having that as a
consistent again you are what you
consistently do having that is a
consistent part of your routine is being
surrounded by the people even if you
don't have them as friends but videos
podcasts books of the people who are
thinking living acting like the way you
want to and the more that you're around
them the more they will pull you forward
to accomplishing the things you want to
accomplish and you becoming the person
you want to be so you can have anything
you want you can have anything you want
you just can't have everything
and the difference between where you are
now and where you want to be is what and
who you are now going to start saying no
to because you've raised your standards
your vision comes from your purpose and
your purpose comes from your pain when
people ask me all the time how do I find
my purpose how do I find my one of the
number one questions people have well
it's actually pretty easy to find your
purpose you just have to understand that
it comes from your pain whatever you
struggled with the most as a human being
in your life is the thing that you want
to help other people through
and that may be something on a big scale
where you want to change the world and
make sure that it never happens to
anybody else ever again and ease the
suffering for others along the journey
if you're watching this video you're on
this channel it's probably more the way
that you lean but it could also just be
the people closest to you
the closest members in your family that
your closest friends the the team that
you're on your co-workers those are the
people who you want to help the most you
don't have to go off and change the
world but you do have to feel like what
you do matters at the end of the day all
of us want to make sure that we wake up
and we feel like today is going to
matter
when you feel like today matters to
somebody that you're going to be doing
work that is unservice to other people
that you will matter to them that what
you create today will matter to them
it's going to make you feel better it's
going to make you feel alive it's going
to make you feel worthy it's going to
make you feel proud of yourself however
when you wake up and you feel like today
doesn't matter like nobody cares if you
show up that your work will be
meaningless you're just going to toil
away and do useless things we probably
all had jobs like that right if you had
a job like that you woke up you went to
your work felt like you're just gonna
plug away even if you were working hard
but it just didn't matter there's no
appreciation the work either did matter
it didn't matter if you showed up or not
but that's I think most people we've at
least had a job like that at some point
in our past and that's the path down to
feeling worthless and depression anxiety
and suicide a lot of the problems that
we're facing a lot of for for a lot of
people the biggest problem is just you
don't feel like the work you're doing is
meaning anything to anybody and and
therefore you feel like you don't matter
because because the work you're doing is
not meaning anything to other people
therefore you don't matter because deep
down we all want to serve you were built
to serve we all want to feel like what
we do matters so you don't have to
necessarily have a big vision for the
world but you do have to figure out your
purpose
and your purpose comes from your pain so
for me I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
as a 19 year old getting his first
business off the ground and turning down
the big jobs and failing and sucking and
making no money and just pouring
everything I had into this company and
being absolutely broke
financially and and emotionally you know
the initial high of I'm going to start a
business I'm going to be an entrepreneur
we're going to do this we're going to
change the world yeah uh what's great
and then it wears off when you realize
nothing is happening we're barely
getting any customers we're barely
making any money the the the the high of
the launch Fades pretty quickly and then
you're in the muck of actually just
trying to create things and I really
struggled and those were the worst days
of my life
um it led to some of the best days uh
but just the worst days emotionally
feeling like I was worthless
and so that's why I do what I do
because I want to help all the 19 year
old Evans out there not struggle as much
as I struggled not be as embarrassed to
ask for help not to be I was ashamed to
feel like a total failure not to feel
like I'm going through this alone not to
have zero mentors and building this up
not to pretend like everything is great
when it's not
and it's not only talking to 19 year
olds around the world you know it could
be you it could be a 52 year old woman
you know who's going through the same
thing it's that emotion and so I love
helping I love helping I've helped a lot
of big people with their channels and
their businesses but uh my heart is
really in the startup because that's
where I really struggled the most myself
and so that's what I'm trying to create
an everyday wake up and and try to do
something else whether it's a YouTube
video or a tick tock or an Instagram or
write the book or speaking engagement
and whatever the next thing is VR Evan
and hologram Evan and 3D Evan and
whatever beaming into your living room
this is something forever when people
ask me how do you how have you not burnt
out how have you how do you keep going
so many years later thousands of videos
later
well I I feel like I'm living my purpose
it's another I record videos on Tuesday
it's another Tuesday sitting here in the
car and my wife is at her acupuncture
appointment and I'm I joined her and I'm
I've got my coffee and I'm sitting in
the car making videos and this is video
number I don't know how many thousand
and why I keep going well because I feel
like this video will mean something to
at least one person
maybe it hits a million people maybe it
hits one person but it's going to be
valuable to at least one person and when
you can feel that when you can genuinely
feel that that you're making something
that's gonna actually touch at least one
human being
that's a good that's a good addiction to
get you know to feel like we matter so
think back to what was the most painful
moment of your life
you want to find your vision you want to
find your purpose what's the most
painful moment of your life when did you
struggle the most as a human when did
you feel the most worthless useless it
doesn't mean that you were suicidal
though maybe you were but it also
doesn't mean that you're in depression
you know maybe you were but when did you
just feel the lowest I never had any
Suicidal Thoughts I don't think I was
depressed either but I felt really low
when was that moment for you what were
the worst days of your life and your
purpose is then to help other people who
are struggling with that very same thing
because you've made it through
and it it doesn't mean that you're done
growing and learning I'm I'm still
learning I'm still growing that's why I
still watch videos and make videos
because I'm I'm still learning and
that's great you want to climb you climb
forever you never want to stop
progressing and stop climbing that's the
whole idea you know beyond the mountain
there's more Mountains you wanna you
wanna climb forever swim forever play
the game forever there is no Finish Line
that's the best part of it and every
time you take another step you reach
back and you help somebody get to where
you're at
and so you've learned a lot of lessons
if you think about who you used to be go
back to that moment where you were
struggling the most and that person you
know for me is probably sitting at my
business partner's dining room table
uh just frustrated
lost
tried everything nothing's working how
am I here why did I say no to that job
why did I say yes to this what did I
just throw away everything my whole life
you know it would be overly dramatic but
that's what was going through my mind
this is what I was actually thinking so
I had it had you know what could I what
would I go back and tell that Evan so
for you what was the most painful moment
in your life imagine a picture it see
yourself there who are you with where
are you you know what's the setting
around you and imagine you can go back
and talk to that person younger you you
had 15 minutes with that person what
would you say
you could help that person
you don't have to
have to Simon sinek or Tony Robbins or
Oprah Winfrey whoever you can go back
and help younger you
can give them some advice and in fact
younger you would probably listen to you
a lot more than they would listen to me
or Simon sinek or Tony Robbins Oprah
Winfrey or whoever because you've gone
through it they know who you are they
know that you understand them
and so they need your help
and that's that's what you create
whether it's making YouTube videos
whether it's some product or service
that you end up selling whether it's
joining some other organization who has
a similar Vision that you're gonna tie
yourself to
but that's what you want to do that will
make your life meaningful that will make
you feel valuable that'll make you feel
connected to the thing that you're
waking up every day doing I think
ultimately that's what makes people
happy
and so your vision comes from your
purpose your purpose comes from your
pain
and if you felt like you're reaching
back and touching younger you and
helping make sure that other people
don't have to struggle and suffer as
much as you did
Secret
that's the answer
the fulfillness happiness money and most
importantly
feeling like you are proud of yourself
and that you matter you are staying
small because you're afraid you're
afraid of the worst case scenario coming
true losing having no money and being
embarrassed but you know you're capable
of more you know the way that you're
going about doing things right now is
nothing compared to what you're capable
of unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always going to stay small
knowing that you are capable of more
today I'm going to show you how so one
of the easiest ways to get out of your
scarcity mindset is to go from idea to
action as soon as you get an idea you do
something about it and sometimes that
idea often that idea is going to be too
big too scary too crazy you can't do it
who are you to do this you don't have
the money resources time connections
energy right all of that all of the
excuses that come into your head I like
to teach myself that as soon as I get an
idea I go do something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something so this
is great this is a grant video because
when I did my tour in 2019 that's
January to April we hit 23 different
cities over 90 days and at the beginning
I was trying to find different sponsors
that would help out with travel
accommodations because it was me Nina my
film guy Danny and and all of our gear
was mostly Danny's gear
lighting and we had speakers and camera
gear and all of this stuff and we ended
up renting a suburban and driving across
America but before doing that I emailed
Grant and I said hey Grant
uh
can I use your plane for 90 days
for my tour
and to his credit
the email that he wrote back was what's
the upside
not no not forget about it not do you
know how much it cost and just jet fuel
and and you know my pilot and that I
can't use my plane for three months he
said what's the upside I said well
listen I'm gonna let everybody in my
audience know about you and let's we
didn't get a deal we didn't make it
happen but it's that it's that idea of
going for my deed action
right and I still do a lot with Grant
right making this video helping promote
all the stuff that he's up to we're
looking at doing something together when
I go to Miami next
and so that one exchange didn't ruin the
relationship and I'm happy to share it
publicly
maybe that's embarrassing for some
people right but the idea of trusting
your ideas you get an idea you go do
something it may be too big and maybe it
may be scary you might have people say
no even if the most likely answer is no
right the most likely answer might be no
the most likely answer to me asking
grant that question is no right it's a
no but if I don't ask it's a no 100
don't take the no away from somebody
else
it might be 99.999 now but there's still
a little chance maybe there's a Yes
somewhere in there trust your ideas do
something I did and so continue to do
and that's how you escape scarcity
mindset that's how you escape playing
small and actually go down and Chase the
life that you want to live so let's get
more specific I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is idea to action
so as soon as you get that idea you
don't judge it you don't think about it
you don't say why me you just go and you
do something find the smallest possible
way to just get started right so you
just trust that the idea came to you I
believe that ideas flow through you you
got that idea for a reason why are you
thinking about it don't worry about why
you're thinking about it just go do
something about it find the smallest
possible way to just go do something
about it you are a genius therefore you
come up with genius ideas not all of
them work out maybe the timing was wrong
maybe the execution was wrong but it's
still a great idea because you came up
with it therefore it is a great idea and
you have to go do something about it so
trust your ideas and go from idea action
tip number two is what I call the two
percent difference here's what happens
most of the time when people come up
with an idea you default into planning
mode planning strategy thinking
researching and then you wake up the
next day and you're back to square one
you're back to normal like the energy
that you got the boldness the courage
that you had is gone because you woke up
the next day
so you've wasted your best time your
best momentum that Peak in energy on
planning where what I want you to do is
use that for Action so the two percent
difference is instead of planning to get
to 100 which is what most of us will do
you come up with an idea and then plan
how it's going to happen 100 to finish
line so you know what the finish line is
going to be stop thinking you even know
where it's going to be instead of
worrying about 100 focus on the first
two percent
the first two percent I have this idea
what can I do right now right now that
will get me two percent of the way right
you wanna you wanna make a YouTube video
great pull out your phone start
recording that's two percent you want to
remind yourself to breathe this is one
thing we have on our on our door every
time I leave the door every time I leave
my condo there's a sign that says
breathe right because I want to remind
myself to breathe take take practice my
Wim Hof take 30 breaths in in and out as
I walk outside my condo every time
I put that there was a as a play bigger
trigger for myself but it's easy to
think well if I'm gonna put a sign on my
door then I need it to be a certain size
and I need to be at the perfect picture
and I need it to be framed and you make
it bigger and then you don't do anything
that's the biggest problem you just
don't have momentum you're not doing
enough
and so step number one the two percent
difference is
I took out a sticky note and I just
wrote breathe and I stuck it on my door
and it's a reminder every day to breathe
that doesn't mean that you can't go back
and plan it doesn't mean that you can't
replace it with something nicer bigger
better yes of course planning has its
role but not as a first step your first
step is action if your first step is
planning you're losing
if your first step is planning that's
why you're a perfectionist that's why
you don't have momentum happening
against your ideas your first step
idea into the first two percent and in
Step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result this is
where again so many entrepreneurs will
fail because you tied your self-worth to
the outcome of you accomplishing that
thing if you woke up and you only did
things that you knew you were going to
win at You're Gonna Play small for life
you're only doing things inside your
comfort zone because you know you're
gonna win at them right or a very high
degree chance you're gonna win if that's
all you ever take on you play small for
life
but if you're going outside your comfort
zone taking on new projects growing as a
human learning getting better checking
on new challenges that are bigger and
Beyond you most days you're actually
going to wake up and fail because you're
doing something new
but if you woke up every day and were
proud of the effort you were putting in
you're proud of yourself for the effort
you put in your max effort you're trying
to make the best video you can you're
trying to make the best product or
service you can you're proud of yourself
for the effort every single day
you're going to create amazing things
Way Beyond what you thought you're
capable of and way more than the person
who just sits inside their bubble doing
things that they know they're going to
win it
tie yourself forth to the effort not the
results you have to decide whether you
are going to live an intentional or
accidental life do you want to live an
intentional or accidental life most of
the world lives in accidental life most
of the world they wake up what do you do
when you first wake up check your phone
right you set some alarm because you
have to drive to some job that you hate
you check your phone and immediately
there's all the crisis out there all the
expectations on you all of the fears and
judgments all of the tasks that other
people have set for you you wake up like
an accident and start living according
to other people's demands for your time
you've already lost complete control of
your day
what if though you swapped it and said I
want to live a more intentional life
what does it even look like was an
intentional life look like well I think
it starts with a value
if you were to think about what is your
most important core value would you come
up with right I've written two books on
it your one word built to serve back
there you can figure it out mine is
believe I want to spread more belief in
the world
what is your most important core value
that you want to organize your day
around
instead of responding to other people's
emergencies and losing complete control
of your day how about we organize with
intention for how we want to show up
today okay well that sounds great so how
do you do it well I'm going to give you
a couple tips that I use in my life that
I think can be valuable for you
number one your morning routine is so
critical you've heard it over and over
and over and over again from multiple
people Morning Routine Morning Routine
Morning Routine what's the difference
between a incredibly powerful morning
routine that allows you to be
Supernatural and do the things that are
beyond your comfort zone and and are not
by default in you yet
versus just a regular morning routine
the difference is the feeling this is
what most Achievers Miss okay most of
the world doesn't have a morning routine
with intent most of the world wakes up
falls into their day responds to the
people's emergencies hate their life
hate their day look back on the week
that just happened if you ever felt like
you've put so much work into this week
right you look at the end of the week I
worked so hard this week but I got
nothing done
you ever feel that way why because you
responding to other people's emergencies
instead of actually doing the thing with
intention that you should be doing
okay so the purpose
for Achievers I have a morning routine
is to get the feeling the goal is not
just to wake up and do your workout or
do your meditation or do your prayer or
or whatever the thing is that's on your
list right we're great as Achievers at
checking off the boxes right check check
check check I did it awesome pat
yourself on the back you feel good for
checking out the box but if you do not
feel
old powerful confident courageous belief
in yourself to start your day and have a
great day then your morning routine is
not working for you more important than
the task you get done is how you feel
about yourself and ready to start the
day
some people what they need to do is
actually tweak them on a routine and
some people what they need to do is this
is more likely the case you actually
have a good morning routine you're just
not doing it with the right focus and
intention because you say that you're
going to watch a video to get inspired
great perfect boy you're watching a
video You're brushing your teeth and
you're making your lunch and you're
preparing your coffee and you're doing a
million other things so you can check
the box to say yep watch the video but
you didn't get the feeling
and so it doesn't count
you need to feel old courageous powerful
belief in South ready to start the day
and have an amazing one or you have to
go back and fix your own routine or do
it again
starting your day to have intention to
do crazy new amazing big things
it begins with a powerful morning
routine okay
number two
look at your calendar
and think about how do you want to show
up today the most important part of my
morning routine I'll wake up I put on
some music usually the first thing I
play in the morning is Oldies play some
really I don't know the oldies just get
me going in the morning any song that
kind of gets you moving gets you flowing
gets you out of your state because we
all wake up kind of tired lines on your
face Etc right but then what song can
you put on because the fastest way to
change your state
and then I look at my calendar
I look at my calendar and ask myself how
do I want to show up for today
instead of having a a bucket list I
think your bucket list is your excuse
list things that one day you're gonna
get done forget that I'm getting stuff
done today you're getting stuff done
today your bucket list should be in your
calendar you're working towards actually
achieving things and so look at your
calendar for today look at your calendar
for the next week how do you want to
show up
so this morning I wake up I put on my
oldies and I'm looking at my calendar
and this is a Tuesday for today and I'm
filming YouTube videos on Tuesday
Tuesday is a day that I film my content
so how do I want to show up I want to
show up
present I want to show up and make some
of the best videos I've ever made I may
not achieve that objective but it's my
it's my goal it's my intention to show
up it's less important like did you get
the result today and more like are you
proud of the effort that you showed up
today I don't want to focus on team I
don't want to focus on emergencies in my
email I don't want to focus on social
media I don't want to delay and
procrastinate I want to get content out
for you guys believe Nation let's go I
want to show up even though I'm just
standing on my trampoline alone by
myself in my office I want this message
to reach millions of people
that's that's the intention that's when
I wake up I got my oldies playing and
then I'm looking at my calendar and say
this is how I want to show up most days
I don't remember what day it is when I
wake up I I had no idea that today was a
Tuesday when I woke up
I put on my oldies I look at the
intention
ready to go that does not have to take a
long time this doesn't have to be a two
hour morning routine
you're you could be great at it
you're just not going through the actual
exercise to ask yourself how do I want
to show up today
so look at your calendars it's a good
exercise think of what's coming up in
your calendar today what's coming up for
the rest of the day before you go to
sleep how do you want to show up
how do you want to show up in your
business or at your work how do you want
to show up for the people that you work
with how do you want to show up for your
family how do you want to show up
because when you set that morning
routine right step one create a powerful
morning routine that makes you feel bold
confident powerful a live belief in self
and two as a part of that having the
intention for how you want to show up
imagine if every day for the next year
you did just those two things
powerful morning routine that makes you
feel bold powerful courageous right and
two you send an intention every morning
of how you want to live today
whether you achieve it perfectly or not
but you did that every morning imagine
how much different your life is one year
from today
just by doing those two things
it's transformative
and then step number three is
in between
the activities during the day
remember your intention I have a
background on my cell phone it says
remember your intention so anytime I
look at my cell phone it's remember my
intention remember your intention
remember your intent what was my
intention this morning belief I got it I
want to spend more but I want to make
amazing YouTube content amazing videos
for you guys believe Nation remember the
intention because no matter what
happened in the morning you might forget
it come noon come two o'clock come four
o'clock come six o'clock
give me the reminder
of your intention so have it on my cell
phone background the other thing that I
do is I will book things in 25 or 55
minute increments
so if I'm filming blocks of content if
I'm doing meetings with people if I'm
doing training events or seminars
there's always a five minute break
from when I stop one activity to when I
start the next activity
and one reason for that is just to to
make sure that there's any technical
issues or one thing runs late or Etc I
have a little bit of a buffer but the
more important issue is that it allows
me that little window to reset the
intention for the next thing
so especially if you're switching tasks
you're coming home from work and you're
going you're going home and you're gonna
you're gonna see your spouse you're
gonna see your kids or you're switching
from one meeting to a next you're
switching from a meeting to making a
video or switching from video to write
your book you're switching between tasks
give yourself a little five minute
window to just remember the intention
again
it totally changes how you show up as a
human
if you are going from work to home even
if that's I'm I'm I my studio here is in
my home right even if I'm going from
here to outside the door
if I get myself a five minute break
in between activities from stopping
filming to then going to hanging out
with my wife
and I ask myself remember your intention
what was your intention for today
okay belief how do I bring that to Nina
how do I bring that to my relationship
even though I've just made all these
videos and my head's going a mile a
minute and I'm so excited for all the
content that we're producing and making
and launching amazing
how do I now show up for my relationship
just that five minutes it doesn't even
have to take five minutes but just
asking the question
resets the priorities
takes you off of living on autopilot and
living in intention
it changes how I show up to when I'm
gonna go out and hang out with Nina
so do those things your life will
dramatically change powerful morning
routine
set your intention every morning
and then have little breaks to remind
yourself of what that intention was
throughout the day
whether it's your cell phone background
whether it's five minute breaks in
between switching tasks
if you can decide
that you want to stop living in
accidental life
stop living a reactionary life based off
of other people's priorities for your
time controlling your agenda
put up a little bit of defenses and
walls to say no this is my time this is
my life
I'm gonna start living it with intention
you do that
Everything Changes I promise you
everything in your life changes when you
learn to tie your self-worth to your
effort instead of the results most
people tie their self-worth to the
results to winning you only feel good
about yourself when you win if that's
how you think then you're screwed
because that person only takes on
projects that you know you have a pretty
high chance of winning at and therefore
you play small for Life the key is to
tie yourself Worth to the effort to
trying and if you do that well you'll
win Beyond Your Wildest imaginations so
let's use me as an example look at this
video right here this video
two minutes before getting on to making
this video
I'm nervous
I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why I've done 6 000 of these videos
do I not love it anymore nope that's not
it I love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through
put this pressure on myself to say this
video right now has to be the best video
that I've ever made that's my intention
going in to every time I'm filming most
days I don't accomplish it when you're
trying something new and scary and
bigger and Bolder most of the time you
won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie myself worth my respect to the
effort I'm trying and every now and then
you'll make a bit of a breakthrough you
get a bit of a win
and then those accumulate and then you
get another one and another win and
another win and so the answer isn't have
a big goal and then find a reason why
you can't do it the answer isn't dream
big and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
abilities to get up and try again and
try again and try again and pat yourself
on the back for the effort you're
putting in not just when you're winning
so how do you do it I'm going to give
you a three-step process that I think
will help step number one is what I call
the pillow test this is my actual pillow
that when I'm in Toronto I sleep on
every single night and the pillow test
is make yourself proud before you hit
your head on the pillow right before you
go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not did I get the results I
was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in
that's the test that's the test for
tonight that's your test for tomorrow
night and the night after that and the
night after that and the night after
that and the more that you get a yes to
say yeah heck yeah
heck yeah I'm proud of my effort you do
that you watch your business explode
step number two is expect to suck at the
start anytime you're trying something
new expect to suck don't expect to just
try something new and it's amazing this
is where a lot of people fall down
you've had some success you're at a
certain level you're going to try
something new before you go up you're
probably gonna go down
that's part of the experientation
process it doesn't mean you suck as a
human it just means that you don't have
the skill sets the talents yet you're
trying something new
I haven't brought props in on my videos
before that was a new test I expect it
to suck maybe on an off chance that
works amazing I learned from it but when
you're trying something it's brand new
you don't have the confidence in it yet
you're still figuring out the path
expect to suck when you put so much of
your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make your video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it it
would eventually be awesome you'd
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos come back go back to my
main Channel go back to the beginning
see where I started I've kept them all
up so you can see the journey the
progress of how much I sucked at the
very beginning it took me 350 videos
until I wasn't embarrassed by my content
I was I was so embarrassed I couldn't
watch it back 350 videos but I kept
going
the problem is people are quitting on
things too soon you quit on something
too soon because you're not getting
immediate results expect to suck it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human it
just means you don't have the skills yet
I had to get the skills by practicing
and number three is ask yourself what
would the most bold version of you do I
got this question was talking to my
video guy Danny who came to me with a
really important personal problem in his
life at the time and I said what would
the most bold version of you do it just
came out man I love that
and anytime he doesn't know what to do
he asks himself that question what would
the most bold version of me do it's a
great question because it allows you to
push through a lot of your fears a lot
of your insecurities to force yourself
to be bold and you want to be bold
you're meant to be bold
you're meant to create amazing wonderful
things you want that big vision of yours
to come true you are bold you are
courageous
but we don't live in that land very
often and so if you ask that question
what would the most bold version of you
do today
what it does is wash away a lot of those
fears and insecurities and gives you the
answer that you're actually looking for
the free leads you to the paid if you
have no momentum no traction no clients
then start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can't wait to have again and pay for
this time the goal isn't to do free
forever but the free gives you the thing
that you're missing the most which is
momentum in your business so I'm
pre-launching my book right now built to
serve and people who buy the book and
pre-order also get access to my private
Facebook group where I help people
one-on-one every week and so the guy
that I had on last week is a coach he's
a health coach he wants to help people
make transformations to their health
because he made a radical shift in his
health as well and I said great well how
are you doing right now well I have a
couple clients but I'm still working at
a restaurant I want to be able to leave
that so I can focus on this full-time
awesome if you're a coach what I need to
see you is coaching I need to see you
coaching people what I'd love to see now
is an Instagram live regular show and
what do you do on your Instagram live
you bring on people who need help being
coached through a health transformation
because it's one thing to say I'm a
coach and I help people get these
results it's another though to actually
see people change to have you go live
with them one-on-one and help them bust
through their limiting beliefs and their
mindset and the issues that they're
dealing with and then they come out on
the other side by the end of the call
feeling hope feeling invigorated feeling
inspired because people will watch that
and say man
I want a result like that they see
themselves in the client that you're
helping and they then want it for
themselves now you get two versions one
will be free people
one would be like can you do me I'll
take it for free
which is great don't say no don't get
discouraged don't get upset you want the
free because the free gives you the
content and so if they're willing to
come on and do live on Instagram with
you for free then you do it
and there'll be other people who say hey
I love what you're doing I need a
radical transformation in my health as
well but I don't want to be on Instagram
I don't want to make it public can I can
I hire you privately
Bingo right that's what we're looking
for that's when you start getting paid
the free leech to the paid one of my
favorite quotes of all time is whether
you think you can or you think you can't
you're right it's usually attributed to
Henry Ford from all the videos that I've
made all of the successful people that I
profiled from industry Titans to monks
one of the things that they all have in
common is the ability to focus on the
things that they can do to improve their
situation there are a million reasons
why your idea will not work out and eat
while it will successful people focus on
the eight reasons why it will succeed
and unsuccessful people focus on that
million reasons why it won't so it's
time to decide which one are you the
secret to getting everything that you
want out of life is to think big and act
small think big have a huge Dream create
a vision for yourself that excites you
that you want to make happen and then
act small don't let the big dream be so
big that it becomes so scary and you
never start find the smallest possible
way to just get started think big act
small otherwise your dreams will stay
exactly that I think entrepreneur is
going to solve every problem I think
whatever problem there is in the world
entrepreneurs are going to be the ones
to solve it and there's definitely a
place for government and everything else
but I just default to thinking it's us
it's entrepreneurs we're going to do it
we see a problem we want to fix it be
the change you want to see in the world
and and that's really at the Crux of a
successful business when people ask me
how do you make money as an entrepreneur
well you solve a problem with something
that you love doing if you are solving
somebody else's problem that they're
struggling with you can get paid to do
it and if you love doing that thing then
that's how you start having a business
right that can have success long term
sustainable if you solve a problem but
you don't love doing it you're gonna end
up burning out phasing out people will
be better than you at it it won't be
sustainable because you don't love the
thing and if you just love the thing but
you're not solving a problem then you've
got a hobby right if you love doing
something but it doesn't sell of
anybody's problem you've got a hobby and
it could be fulfilling and enriching for
the soul but that's not a business it's
in that combination of what solves a
real problem that you enjoy doing that's
how you start to make money I think one
of the biggest problems though for
entrepreneurs is we don't know what the
problem is we think we know what the
problem is but we don't know what the
problem is especially when it's for
ourselves we think that we know what our
problems are but we don't actually know
our problems because we're too in the
thing you ever notice how it's easier to
point out somebody else's problems like
you should be doing this you know the
problem with this business they should
be doing that but it's harder to look at
ourselves and say Here's the biggest
problem that I'm facing right now at
least I find this as a challenge I'm
sitting here at genius Network this is a
it's a what it's a mastermind it's a
success Circle
um of people who are
having seven eight nine figure
businesses and they meet once a month to
help each other out and one of my
favorite exercises is when you
basically go down and it's called hot
seat and you think about what your
biggest problem is and they put you in
groups and then you're explaining your
problem to the other people in your
group and you get suggestions you get
feedback and these are all you know
peers people who've done equally or
maybe even more things than you have and
it's great to get at least I think a
fresh perspective and so
yesterday one of the members that I was
in that group with
he came up and he said I my biggest
problem is I need to have more structure
in my life I need to be more intentional
with my time I'm too all over the place
I'm I'm too you know creative and and
and I you know it's got me this far but
it's not going to be the thing that gets
me to the next step I need to have more
discipline and schedule
and the first uh person started giving
him some advice and and she was telling
him how she sets her schedule and give
some feedback and
the thing that just kept throwing
flowing through my mind and when it came
to me to give advice I just asked the
question do you even want this
you know like do you even want this
and
he's like
it feels it sounds like prison
as a guy that you've been in prison
before so he knows what that feels like
he's like when I when I think about it
when I talk about it feels like I'm in
prison and that is
a classic case for a lot of
entrepreneurs who want freedom who are
creative who want to be out
like creativity is messy
creativity is messy and so you can't be
productive and you can't be efficient if
you're being creative and knowing a
little bit about him said dude that
that's not your problem see this is
where we got cut up in our own in our
own traps and our own thinking because
we can't self-diagnose very well we
often need people to help us so when he
says
my problem is I'm not being intentional
enough with my time and I'm wasting a
lot of time I need to be more structured
that's not his problem
in fact what he needs to do is the exact
opposite he needs to be spending more
time in his own of Genius he needs to be
spending more time being creative he
needs to have the freedom to spend three
days swimming with alpacas if that's the
thing that is in his mind because it's
going to lead to some awesome new
creation that if you take a creative
genius like he is and you force him into
a structure and a schedule then he's
going to end up
in a prison like you said and and just
imagine you know if he lives a week like
that versus a month like that versus six
months like that versus a year like that
the more he's trapped in that prison the
less effective he's actually going to be
he might be really efficient and
productive
for a short amount of time but he's
gonna end up hating his life and he's
not going to birth any new creative
things into the world and he's out of
his own of Genius
and so his real problem is he doesn't
have the person on his team to be that
number two to take things over
and he hasn't assigned that person the
responsibilities or given them
permission to be able to to run with
those things he's already built the
seven figure business so it's not like
I'm I'm talking to somebody who's brand
new startup doesn't know what he's doing
right this is a already successful
entrepreneur but again it's easy to spot
the problems in other people's
businesses and other people's lives and
sometimes in our own and so the problem
was different than the problem that he
thought he had
and solving the right Problem by getting
some perspective
will change his life just as I was
talking and expressing
what I thought about him you could see
these shirts that come alive and at the
end he's like I feel that this is the
guy who's really in tune with with body
and energy and is like I feel that he's
like touching his heart you know as he's
doing it and like thank you and what a
gift and so
we solved the right problem
and so
if you are struggling right now
I think one of the best things you can
do is is one model success so go find
the people who've done what you're
trying to do and see what resonates you
know Bill Gates saved my business even
though I've never met him because I had
a software company and I looked at Bill
Gates who started a software company and
that's what I modeled and it started to
work
but I think even more importantly
if you're really struggling right now is
to be around other people who might be
able to help
because you're around some people even
if you're a shy and introverted like me
you sell people some people around you
the problem is they can't tell you what
the problem is you know their their
version of the problem is something you
don't want to hear I don't believe in
negative or toxic people I don't think
that's what's going on but they're
you know hurt people hurt people so they
could be in a lot of pain they could be
hurt they have a different perspective
one that you you don't want their life
you don't respect their opinion on the
thing that you're asking about and so
you just probably around the wrong
people
and to be able to change that to shift
that to you might be able to I mean this
group here one group was 25 000 a year
being the other is a hundred thousand
dollars to be in so
um you may not be able to afford to to
go to a group like that but you don't
need it because the most you don't need
it yet you know the most important thing
is momentum to start building to start
being around more positive optimistic
happy people who you do respect you can
do something with I made a group called
movement makers and every two weeks we
meet and these are people who want to be
thought leaders who want to share want
to help have a message on their heart
and need to get out to the world and
it's great to be around me and I teach
and I share and I give my perspective
but the biggest learning I think
honestly is by them being connected to
each other by them doing challenges and
projects together by them interviewing
each other on their channels so that
they're not alone and they have people
to talk to and connect with and feel
like
like this matters and there's some
momentum because whatever you want to do
the people around you don't understand
it right if you're an entrepreneur
you're a little bit crazy it's awesome
like high five I love you celebrate but
you're a little bit crazy and different
and the people around you don't
understand you and some people might
just be supportive just not know what to
tell you and other people might be
straight out negative and say stop doing
that be practical be realistic go get a
job go to school go X go live a safe
life and you don't want that life
and so you need to start being around
the people collect good people who
support you who cheer you on who believe
in you who say that you can do things
who still push you but in a positive
left and Way Forward as opposed to a
negative way down that makes you feel
like things are possible and so how do
you find those people well
you could join a group right I mean
genius Network might be a fit for you if
you've got a big budget movement makers
might be a fit for you if you're trying
to be a thought leader but but actively
look for people actively look for events
and conferences and groups even if it's
a free meetup group at the beginning
like actively look to be around
people who are close to you or online
groups that you can join but that are
around the same interests of you because
when you're around the people who are
trying to do the same thing that you're
trying to do even if they haven't quite
done it yet it's not only mentoring
where they've done it and they're
showing you the ropes even if it's
they're trying to do it and you're
trying to do it to be around people who
are ambitious who want to chase down
their dream and goals and Achieve
something right and make something of
their lives if you're around those
people it will just fill you with more
energy
it will fill you with more energy and
make you feel like hope is possible
that'd be my immediate action item to
yes have the environment pay attention
to who you subscribe to on YouTube and
who you follow on Instagram and the
books that you're reading and the
content you're consuming does it lift
you up does it make you feel better and
belief and give you hope and strategies
and tactics on what to actually do and
look at your circle
and are you with the right people
and if not then just don't don't don't
make it some big thing that you have to
go join this giant group that's super
expensive
just start with
who can I who can I talk to right now
you know who's trying to do this thing
with me too
who's even at my level
that I can build and grow and learn with
and if you just switch your mindset to
start to look to start the search to go
to Google and type in your city and look
for groups or to think about the
industry you want to be in like how to
be a thought leader or how to be a XYZ
whatever it is that you are in whatever
your business is and Define groups of
people who are doing it you know you
want to be a Toastmasters for speakers
or whatever it is there's a group
to just join and try it because man when
you're around people who are doing
things
it just breathes so much more Life
Energy and momentum into your mission
smart people come up with really smart
reasons why you can't do something and
it's true there are a million reasons
why you will not win a million reasons
but there are eight reasons why you will
and you have a choice this is an
important choice you have to decide are
you going to focus on the million
reasons why you are not going to win or
on the eight why you will so let's talk
about being an introvert I'm an
introvert I still am an introvert I own
my introvertedness that often doesn't
come across you may not believe me you
might see these videos and think Evan is
so extroverted type A personality I'm
not
I I get nervous in big rooms I don't
like hanging out with strangers I never
talk to the people next to me on flights
or the train or anything I don't go up
and say hi and introduce myself I hate
all that stuff I hate small talks I I
have zero need to be around people if
it's just me and my wife I'm happy I
have zero need for contact to fill my my
social
equation whatever you want to call it
I'm introvert I still am but I I use it
as a positive where it used to be a
really strong negative I used to get
into a fight all the time with my agent
and he said the problem with you Evan is
you don't want to be famous it's like
you're right I don't I don't need to be
famous I don't need the spotlight I
don't want the spotlight
and it finally sunk in that in order for
me to get my message out there the more
known I am the more people hear the
message and so how does an introvert
become famous well we'll see join me on
my journey we're on we're in this
together we'll find out together
but the thing that gets me through all
of it is one going in on the strength
and and turning that introvertedness
into not an excuse but into something
that's empowering I think as introverts
we listen better
I just came back from an event in
Florida where somebody at the dinner
table was saying Evan it's really
surprising how well you listen
yeah because that's all that's all I do
I focus on the person I'm talking to I'm
introverted it's not about me talking
it's about you trying to get a result I
want to help you get a result
and so introverts are fantastic
listeners
and so you actually want to help people
make a change you want to help be a
great salesperson you want to help be a
great speaker you have to know your
audience you got to know who you're
talking to you got to be a great
listener I think that counts from being
introverted
and the second thing is having the
passion and the purpose behind what
you're doing gives you the strength and
courage to do things that are scary
getting up on stage and speaking is
scary for me my biggest fear is is
letting people down my biggest fear is
I'm going to disappoint somebody and so
when I go on stage it's always a fear in
the back of my head is that I'm going to
disappoint these people that they're not
going to feel like they got their
money's worth
when I did my tour earlier this year
that was my biggest fear is every four
days I'd be taking a new stage in a new
city and I would just let people down
and I got to face that fear every day
every four days why because the purpose
it means something and so yes you might
be introvert yes you might have a whole
bunch of reasons why you can't win but
the people who win look at your Heroes
look at you look at the people who you
love when you look up to look at who you
respect look at who you want to be be
like look at their store look at where
they came from
chances are they came from a worse spot
than what you currently have right now
the opportunities of resources the
connections they had was worse than what
you currently have at your disposal
right now the only difference between
them and most people is they focus on
the eight reasons why they could win and
most people focus on a million reasons
why they're gonna lose you're afraid of
experimenting because you tie yourself
forth to winning instead of trying if
you base your self-worth off how much
you win then you're only going to try
things that you have a good chance of
winning that thus you play small for
life but instead if you base yourself
forth on trying on the effort that
you're putting in you will fail on most
days but you'll end up accomplishing
more than you ever thought was possible
so every time I go to our YouTube event
I'm always being praised by my
thumbnails people always say Evan's got
the best thumbnails go look at his
thumbnails model his thumbnails use them
as an example for the best practice and
I I internally am always saying our
thumbnails suck we need to get better
sure we might be among the best but we
need to get better better we could be
way better than we are right now
why have we become the best
because I'm experimenting constantly
most of my tests do not work I use a
tool called tubebuddy shout out
tubebuddy huge fan we've done over 1100
split tests on our thumbnails where we
want one thumbnail against another and
one against another and one against
another trying to beat our best and most
of the experiments don't work they just
don't work I recently ran an experiment
of on my main Channel putting my face on
the thumbnail with the Youtube white
border against Tony Robbins and a tank
it was like 80 percent worse than our
current thumbnail and that's okay people
don't like my face next to Tony rhones
that that is okay I'm fine with it I
expect to lose I expect everything I do
not to work but I'm willing to test it
to see I just recently came up with one
thumbnail design where I made the
background purple instead of black
purple instead of black and it actually
did better it did significantly better
and so now I'm testing it out on five
more thumbnails to see does the purple
one do better than the black one if that
works out maybe I roll it out across the
entire Channel but it's very rare that I
find the win out of the 1100 experiments
that we've done most of them will not
work will never work even from the
beginning I'm thinking this is probably
not going to work but I'm willing to
test that's okay even if the most likely
outcome is failure it's worth the test
to see you need to make the big
decisions in life with your heart and
the small ones with the head big
decisions with the heart small ones with
your head why because your head only
understands a world that currently
exists it's logical it's practical it
keeps you safe but your heart can create
something new that hasn't existed before
it's why the number one rule for success
is Follow Your Passion all progress
depends on what your heart tells you to
do and then you use your head to figure
out how to execute it so I just got back
from an event that I was keynoting in
Florida and I was meeting these two
entrepreneurs and helping with their
YouTube channel and one of them is a
really logical head first guy and the
other one is a more heart-based
passionate guy and they were they're
asking me so that their Partners in the
same business and you ask me what's more
important logic or emotion logic or
emotion and there obviously the guy
who's logic base thinks logic is the
most important and the guy who's
emotion-based things emotion is most
important right you want to think that
what you're great at is the most
important thing and I told them it's
macro emotion micro logic macro emotion
micro logic you need to do both so as
I'm looking at their YouTube stats I'm
going deep into YouTube I'm telling them
all the data they need to know I'm
looking at the numbers and explaining
your audience retention sucks here we
need to fix it the percentage of
subscribers coming to your channel is
too low all of this stuff we're going
we're going deep into all their
analytics I can talk numbers for days I
love numbers I love making data-driven
decisions but it's not the macro the
macro is the heart the macros why are
you on YouTube right why am I on YouTube
why am I making videos that's the macro
and then you use your head to figure out
the how the science of the thumbnails
and the audience retention and the
playlist and the titles and all of the
micro strategies that you can use on
YouTube to grow but it's macro motion
micro logic and so as I was explaining
it to him as I said it was listen it's
macro emotion he said but but I was
listening to you as you were explaining
things to me it was very logical
yes
the tactics were very logical but the
delivery so that you would understand it
and then go home and actually apply it
is emotion it's not logic it's emotion
because logic can be everywhere the
answers can be everywhere you know how
to lose weight you stop eating junk you
know how to get fit you'd start working
out you can find it but why are people
not doing it
because you haven't connected
emotionally the reason why you
understood what I was saying and you're
willing to take action is because of the
way that I delivered the information to
you because I had you control the mouse
and go through and do it yourself
because I was encouraging to you when
you needed it and I hit you in the face
when you needed it too not with my hand
with words
right it's macro emotion micro logic you
need both to win but just recognize the
situation you're getting into your big
decisions with the heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to do it
so it's common when you come with a new
idea for something you make a list of
pros and cons right and that's your
heart often talking against your head
where you have this giant list and you
say well these are all the reasons not
to do it but there's only one reason why
I want to do it and so if it's 10 con
and one pro what do you do if you just
look at numbers you go for the con but
maybe the one reason why is you just
love it
when you're ahead and you're harder
working together it's easy when you're
heading your heart or opposite that's
when it slows momentum that's when
nothing happens because you want to do
it but it doesn't make sense to do it
you really love it you have to do it but
it's no There's no practical logical
safe sense to do it
you need to get them aligned your heart
needs to say listen to me brain we're
going now help me figure out how to get
there we're jumping now let's figure out
how to make our parachute on the way
down that's how it is big decision with
the heart spawns with the head you have
no idea what you're capable of you have
no idea you have no idea the person you
could be the thing you could accomplish
the things you can do the people you can
serve you have no idea that's why I
don't like 10 year goals 10-year goals
think about who you used to be 10 years
ago you know could that person
accurately with any with any degree of
certainty predict where you could be
right now now like if you're growing and
you're learning you're improving and
you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
and what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of crew
you should go into right we're told we
should do all these things you're told
you're like who you know nobody ever
thought to ask us what we want for our
lives and you may not even know and
that's okay like you may know where you
want to go next but you may not
ultimately know the Final Destination
it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in in a
year nope
am I still making videos probably but
who knows like question everything I
wanna I want people to believe in
themselves more what's the best way to
do that right now it's through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
plain small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know have you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and it's a group
of super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
the biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them trying to
fit into my box I'd rather fit into
theirs because in trying to understand
how they process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn and I'm probably going to get
a better result because they're going to
see something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no no
that's not going to work for me you know
even boom got a B
I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh
only time in my life I've been sung by
bee and it I was on the floor and my my
back just swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway
maybe question everything except bee
stings how about that there's been times
when people giving me advice and it made
sense and it really fit and sometimes
when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about it if you're really opposed
to somebody's advice or feedback for you
if somebody gives you great advice like
oh wow that's really cool I should go
and do that cool they they met you where
you're at and you understand it but
there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know Gary B had a life coach and
so I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan
and I wake up every day and I just do
the plan because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I'll end up doing is making
a new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
following so in creating a new plan then
I have certain thing in the plan again
and I'm fine and I'm rock and rolling
but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe in anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come with
a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be a downward spiral like
if I believe in the plan and the plan is
not working I can't come with a new plan
then I don't know what to do with my
life and that would create a downward
spiral I've never gone anywhere close to
depression or suicide but that would
lead to some dark that could lead to
some dark places and so the way that I
come out of it is just say great things
will happen to me great things happen to
me they already they always happen to me
great things happen to me and I'll
figure this out and that gives me the
Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in anxiety
filled that I couldn't come with a new
plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change and the change starts with not
just questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen so I love
seeing how people do their daily
routines I love I love seeing how they
start today I love seeing what their
workout routines are mindset routines
are because
hopefully you can pick up one little
tweak one little hack one of the things
that you can try out on your own to be
able to make your life a little bit
better I'm sitting here outside genius
Network we've just been having some
amazing meetings I spent the past two
days in a group where you pay 25 000 a
year to be in and the next two days we
have to pay a hundred thousand dollars a
year to be in and
um I'm grateful to be able to meet so
amazing humans we've built some amazing
businesses so this video leads to a
couple of thoughts for me the first is I
think it's great to have a
healthy balance of ordering chaos most
days you live in order most days you
should have a morning routine most days
you wake up and you do the thing you say
you're gonna do most days whether it's
working out or for your business for
your mindset feeding information into
you I go on my believe walks every
morning some of the things I do right
somebody asked me yesterday how do you
say so positive well I go and I believe
walk every morning I go outside get some
sign it's nice here in Arizona let me
show you let me show you I'm it's
snowing right now in in it's I'm feeling
this uh the end of April and it's
snowing in in Toronto but I'm here
crazy crazy Sun you know super grateful
we got palm trees in the back I'm gonna
get some of the Sun out of my face but
I go for my believe walk pretty much
every morning and I believe walk what
that is is just help me set my mind for
the day what do I want to accomplish
today what what am I doing today I
forget you know I forget what my
responsibilities are and why I'm doing
it because no matter how great a day I
had yesterday
today I wake up and feel like I'm
starting over and so having something in
the morning that helps you remind
yourself of the intention that you've
got for today I think is really valuable
it's really helpful at least it is for
me having music on you know putting
music on that makes you bounce makes you
go up and makes you makes you move
because when you move it transforms your
mind as well when your body's moving
your mind starts moving when your body
is slow and lazy and tired and your mind
is slow and lazy and tired as well and
then feeding my brain with with
knowledge with inspiration with it's why
I make all these videos because I want
to learn from the being Gene I want to
learn from Oprah Winfrey I want to learn
from Elon Musk I want to learn from
people who are thinking just way bigger
than me and so I think
back to the idea of order versus chaos
most days you should wake up and and be
in order most days you should wake up
and do your routine most days you should
wake up and do what you said you were
going to do because these are the things
that you know works for you every now
and then though it's great to inject
some chaos because entrepreneurs we love
chaos and it's great to challenge the
order and it's great to see is this
thing that I was doing this is still
serving me does it still work for me is
it still something that I want to be
doing and so that's we're going to an
event going to a conference going to
meet other people right so I'm hanging
out with all these successful
entrepreneurs here in Arizona and
and it's great and a lot of it is a
reinforcement of what I'm already doing
is working and you hopefully pick up
some nuggets this is what in a 10-day
trip 11 day trip something like that on
my first two days here they gave us uh
free breakfast at the hotel and so my
wife Nina was here with me and we went
for the breakfast the first two days and
I don't usually eat breakfast I don't
usually eat until at least two o'clock
so uh I'll eat between two and six
o'clock every day
sometimes I sometimes I start at two
sometimes I start at six or somewhere in
between I'm usually done by eight and
that's what I do on a daily basis but
since I was away you know you know what
let's have some breakfast and I wasn't
like junking out on every sweet cereal
and syrup all over the place but I
intently kind of went off my routine
still did my bully walk still the music
um and then after two days like you know
what if I keep doing this for the next
10 days 11 days I'm gonna be uh I'm not
gonna feel right you know and so I'm
right now back on my my routine and the
little bit of chaos every now and then I
think is good
it helps you identify is the things that
I'm doing is it working is it helping me
do I want to keep doing it or not what
what does serving me ongoing and so
sometimes you need to get out of your
your environment to to get that shipped
so going to an event going to a
conference meeting other people being
around more ambitious or equally
ambitious people as you can help you
come back with some new ideas even if
you go on vacation like you ever go on a
vacation you come back I want to do this
this this and this you feel you feel
rejuvenated you feel energetic you feel
alive you feel ready to go off and just
make some big change right because you
change your environment and so
that will force some chaos into you that
can hopefully lead to some positive
results so I think most days you should
live in the order you know here's my
routine and I think it works and I'm
sticking to it and then every now and
then you need to inject a little bit of
chaos into it and hopefully in that
chaos it's something positive that
you're injecting into yourself that
makes you pause makes you reflect and
makes you see is this order that I set
up for myself still lead me to the life
that I want one of the things that I
have taken away from the past two days
of hanging with the 25k a year members
is the importance of tracking and right
now what I've done then is started
tracking
what time I eat every day
and what how many uh push-ups Jumping
Jacks and squats that I'm doing every
day and one of the speakers was talking
about in in general as entrepreneurs
what we're always trying to do is go for
new highs what's our new high breaker
and break a break a new record right go
for new highs where
a great way to think about it is instead
of always trying to break new highs
because that's
almost impossible to do
just work on your bad days work on
lowering the raising the lows so if
you're thinking about a health goal for
example and you want to you want to hit
a certain weight well you're the average
of what you've done for the past year
right if you if you eat like crap half
the time and eat super healthy half the
time you're gonna get a certain weight
outcome if you eat or fast some days but
then eat super junky other days you'll
get a certain weight outcome so you're
the average of all your highs and lows
and we tend to focus only on the highs
and we don't focus enough on the lows
where if you can just instead of always
focusing on getting better highs just
lowering the impact of the lows then you
can get a better average result which is
what your end result ends up being and
so
you don't know until you track it so if
you're on a health Journey there may be
days you eat super clean awesome and you
can eat cleaner on some days great but
you'll probably get the best results by
those days where you fall off the rails
where you cheat where you make yourself
not so proud where if I'm having
breakfast at the buffet at the hotel on
the bad days you don't let it go too bad
the concept of bumpers like in a bowling
alley you have bumpers down the side and
so you don't let it get too bad and so
if you cheat or you eat then you're not
having all like pounds of syrup and
everything else that you minimize the
impact or if you're gonna if you're
gonna work out you're gonna make your
calls you're gonna make some videos that
whatever your worst days are just making
them not as bad
and track so by tracking you can see how
well you're doing and so I started
tracking what time I ate so yes it was
the first day so I ate at 6 15. I didn't
eat anything all day it is 6 15 at night
and ended up doing I don't know 50
push-ups 100 squats and 200 jumping
jacks something like that and then today
I'll start tracking again and it gives
you a baseline for where you're at and
so that's a new thing that I'm gonna try
and right now my plan is track those
metrics what time I ate how many
push-ups Jumping Jacks and squats that I
do every day those four things that I'm
measuring and track that every day just
on a piece of paper and then on the
weekend transfer that into a Google
sheet and so I have historic data now
here's the thing it's an idea right now
I'm super excited about the idea I'm
away from my environment of injected
chaos into it and I got inspired to do
this so immediate action I'm doing it
right you don't have to wait to go home
to buy a Fitbit to buy a fancy tracker
to XYZ right this is what we tend to do
you get inspired by something and then
you go off and
you playing and playing and playing and
when when I get home or next week or
next month or on my birthday or New Year
I'm going to do it I said just do it
just get started just just immediate
imperfect action is always the answer
and I'm excited by it right now and it
might be that might make a huge
difference to me it might be a big game
changer might be all like talk about you
know to to give you advice for the next
10 years of my life or maybe it Fizzles
out you know or maybe I try it for three
days and I leave here in a couple days
and then that's it and I don't do it
again it's still worth the experiment
and that's what chaos brings the chaos
brings new ideas and the newness is not
productive the newness is creative but
the news is gonna fail a lot the newness
is not going to be efficient again it
won't be productive and we judge
ourselves that every new idea has to be
the perfect idea it's that's it's the
exact opposite
you know like new ideas most of them
will fail it's not that it's a bad idea
it just made it be the right idea for
you at this moment in your life right
now
and so I'm trying it but in general back
to the idea of ordering chaos I think
most days you wake up and have a
schedule
I think most States should wake up and
do the thing at least talking to myself
Evan Carmichael Evan most days you
should wake up and have a schedule
mostly she wake up and do the thing that
you said you were going to do and have
your routine and stick to it because
that has consistently gotten new results
and if you keep doing that you'll keep
getting more results
and every now and then you need to
inject a little bit of chaos into it you
need to be around other people who are
doing big things you need to question
the order and question the structure and
ask yourself does this structure right
now still serve me and is there a better
way
and it's in that combination that I
think you ultimately find your happiness
your success your purpose and
um yeah you get the life that you want
you are where you are because of you
because of the choices you've made
because of the mindset that you have
because of the lack of accountability
you are where you are because of you and
that is a very tough message to hear but
it's also a very liberating and freeing
message to hear because it's so
comfortable and so so easy to blame
other people we just we would love to
blame other people you know we would
love it's so easy to say well I'm here
because of my parents you know or I'm
here because of the country that I was
born in or I'm stuck here because of the
president and the and the policies that
the president put into place I'm here
because of XYZ whatever story happened
to you right it's so much easier to stay
stuck in blaming other people
because it means we don't have to do
anything
because it means that it's not your
responsibility to fix it like it makes
sense this is why you're stuck right oh
well this is why if I had this set up
for me then then of course it'd be more
successful you know if my parents were
like this and of course it'd be more
successful
it takes the accountability and the
responsibility off of your shoulders
and that's a very comforting message but
it keeps you stuck
[Music]
it keeps you staying exactly where you
are it keeps you in slow growth or no
growth mode
where when you can flip it to I'm here
because of me
and I will end up in a different spot
because of me that where I start right
now is not where I'm going to finish
that where I am right now
is not going to be where I end up
because of the actions that I'm going to
take
one important
thought that I want to get across in
this video is there is a very big
difference between taking accountability
and placing blame
what want to do is blame we want to
blame others
and we don't want to blame ourselves
I'm not asking you to blame yourself
blaming doesn't do anything
blaming is still negative thinking
blaming is still
being stuck in the past
you're sitting there even blaming
yourself you're stuck in a power I
should have done this how many times
have you done that how many times have
you done that I should have done this I
should have been more proactive I should
have taken that chance when I had when I
had the opportunity I should have asked
that question I should have started that
business three years ago I should have I
should have I should have right you're
blaming yourself that's not what this is
taking accountability is not blaming
yourself for all your past mistakes
because if you're stuck in blaming
blaming others or blaming yourself you
stay stuck still too you're in a really
negative
mindset and you say stuck and don't do
anything that's not what this is what
this is is saying I don't want to stay
stuck here and the difference is going
to be me taking accountability for my
life
so how do we how do we start to get
there
let me share a couple pointers okay
number one
find some Heroes
chances are wherever you look up to
whoever your hero is
whether it's Oprah Winfrey Kevin O'Leary
Richard Branson Steve Jobs whoever your
hero is
your hero probably started with less
than what you have right now
less money
less support less Freedom less
opportunities
they started with less than what you
have right now
so how did they break free like how did
they get out of the situation that they
were in the bigger hole that they were
in compared to the hole that you're in
how did they get out
[Music]
because that not only gives you strategy
but also gives you the hope and
motivation to recognize well if this
person could do it from a worse
situation to what I'm in right now
the difference is they didn't stay stuck
in the blame game
they took responsibility and they got
out you can too
surround yourself with Heroes
whether that's watching YouTube videos
whether that's reading books listening
to podcasts but be around your Heroes
because they have a different mindset
most people do not take responsibility
or accountability they don't we don't
want to because it's the harder path we
want to take the easy way out so the
people you're listening to the people
who are around you the people who are in
your life right now likely are not the
ones saying I'm responsible for my life
and I'm gonna go fix it right
people around you are doing the opposite
to say no I'm this this person's fault
so we have to start to shift that you
have to be around your Heroes more
so who are the people you look up to you
respect you love the most that has the
mindset that you want to have the belief
that you want to have the confidence
that you want to have who are those
people
and then surround yourself with them
more subscribe to more YouTube channels
the right YouTube channels follow more
people on Instagram the right people
like do a real audit of the people that
you're hanging out with even virtually
right garyvee or Elon Musk might not
come and Mentor you personally but you
can learn a lot from them from their
content from their interviews from their
books from their podcasts from their
shows you can learn a lot from them if
you choose to surround yourself with
them so do an audit of who you follow on
Instagram of who you follow on YouTube
do an audit and see how many of these
people make you feel better about
yourself give you hope ambition courage
that when you watch their stuff you
consume their stuff you're around it you
leave feeling better if you're scrolling
through Instagram and you close it and
you feel worse about yourself it's your
responsibility to fix that because
there's lots of people you could follow
who give you motivation inspiration hope
courage momentum action
YouTube as well you could die down and
watch eight hours of YouTube and then
feel terrible about yourself because you
just got distracted we're entertaining
yourself you were consumed by negative
content you can switch that unsubscribe
from all those people
and start to follow more channels that's
why I make so much content holy cow how
much content do I make every day I don't
know I'll cross all the channels there's
so much content but you know what it's
always positive it's always spreading
belief it's always healed with hope
you'll never see videos on my channel
talking about how terrible somebody is
or how we should cancel this person or
how bad the world is right and whether
you love my content great or somebody
else is awesome but most important is
the feeling you have about yourself
because when you're filled with hope
confidence courage Your Life totally
changes so step number one is you have
to be around your Heroes step number two
to starting to take responsibility is
what's the action that you can do today
you know what can you do today to start
building some momentum if you accept
that hey
it's not my fault where I'm at but it's
my responsibility to fix it right it's
not your fault
it's not blame
but it's your responsibility to change
it for yourself and for others that you
can change it that you could be the one
you could be the Difference Maker where
this all starts to change
right what is that immediate momentum
you need to take do you need to launch
your own YouTube channel do you need to
start writing your book you need to
create your program you need to get on
stage and speak you need to launch that
service or product you need to do that
collaboration like what's what's the
what's the next step
because the biggest thing that's missing
for most people is just momentum
you've got the ideas and the hard and
the drive and the and the love and the
care and the desire to do good and you
want to serve and you want to make money
and you want to build it but you want
all these things great but what's the
momentum that's happening
what's the next step
to get you out of the hole
and then number three is just scheduling
that in because no matter how bold and
confident and ambitious you feel right
now this is a process that takes time
and you can do
a lot in one day but we tend to
overestimate what we can do in in a day
and underestimate what we can do
you know in a year or in two years or in
five years
so the difference is going to be the
actual momentum that we start taking
consistently so you have one great day
today amazing what's happening tomorrow
what's happening the next day and it's
creating a calendar that you can stay
consistent on
you don't have to stay stuck
where you are in one year can be a
totally different spot than where you
are right now
the difference is not beating yourself
up not blaming yourself for the people
around you not saying how much people
screwed you over and just keep on
thinking about the negative things that
happen to you growing up
and instead saying you know what
it's my responsibility to fix this
I'm taking accountability for my life
and I refuse to be stuck in the same
spot one year from today my biggest fear
is disappointing people my biggest fear
is that people will watch one of my
videos will buy my book we'll come to
one of my
seminars or speeches or whatever and
feel like well that was a giant waste of
time I don't know um
ultimately where it comes from but
that's my biggest fear and it's and it's
honestly
made me play small
in my whole life and the the trick that
I found is that I just need to when I
can recognize it I can do something
about it I think most of the time we
play small by default most of the time
we find a reason why we can't do
something and we justify the reason we
believe the reason so for example if I'm
afraid to make videos
in the beginning I was very afraid to
make videos and I wouldn't make a video
until my friend would come and film it
and I looked professional I had to have
the perfect script and if you go back
and watch my first video I did it on
Walt Disney's story and it was filmed
professionally by my friend Mark Drager
shout out to you and uh I had the
perfect script and I was trying to
memorize it and I couldn't memorize
enough and so I was mostly voice over
where I read a script And I memorized a
few lines and then we did b-roll over
over my talking points because I was so
concerned that if I said the wrong thing
then people might be disappointed that's
taken a lot of unwinding to do I used to
with interviews I used to want to know
what the questions were going to be in
advance
because I felt like I want to be able to
give good answers I didn't want to
discipline the audience of whoever you
know if I'm being interviewed on
somebody's show I want I want them to
have a great show I don't want to be a
terrible chemist
you know I want I want them to feel like
this was really valuable and that I
shared my best information and knowledge
and gave Great Value to Their audience
and so I I always wanted to know what
questions do you want to have Evan
answer or have me answer that ended up
being a
mistake because when I knew the
questions I could give good information
but it it was almost robotic because the
answers were rehearsed
where what I've learned is it's much
more about the emotion than it is about
the exact words people remember how you
make them feel Maya Angelou right people
will remember how you make them feel and
if everything is memorized and perfect
and scripted then the feeling isn't
there because you're so worried about
memorizing and seeing the exact right
word that then there's no emotion there
there's no emotion in what you're saying
and what you're creating what you're
producing then it's not going to move
anybody to any kind of action
and that took a lot of unwinding to do
to be honest and it led me to the point
where whenever I can catch it it's like
how do you get through it whenever you
can catch it
take the action that would make you
proud
so this is you know a decade plus of me
unwinding this and taking slow progress
in action and hopefully you can get
there a lot faster by even just
recognizing that is a problem and
watching videos like this but I did a
couple things so anytime you can catch
it you take the action to make you proud
so
why do I want to have all the questions
in advance of an interview well The
Logical story in my head is because I
want to give a lot of value to the
audience underneath that is the fear
that I'm going to disappoint them oh
it's showing up again okay so now I have
to take corrective action which is I
don't want to have any questions in
advance
which freaked me out right like but what
if x happens
it freaked me out because it freaked me
out I had to go off and do it you know
you start to teach yourself are you the
kind of person who does the things that
freak you out or not
I don't think I had any total train
wrecks or total disasters
but I end up making everything so much
stronger so much better and so much more
fun too that I could just be myself and
show up and answer questions and have a
much better time with the host than than
otherwise than me being stressed out
about getting the right right answers
done all the time on the flip side for
doing interviews
I would always stress out too about
disappointing the guests and
disappointing the audience and feeling
like I I mean I would stress out I think
about having 20 ROMs on the channel or
Matthew McConaughey on the channel or
all these people that I've interviewed
on the channel
honestly the beginning maybe a week
leading up to it I'd be I'd be stressed
out
researching memorizing asking myself
what questions I want to ask running the
story over and over and over and over
and over and over again in my mind in my
head just a wreck I was a total wreck
that's all I could focus on because I
was so stressed out about doing a good
interview and getting their story out
and giving value to them and to you guys
and not you know the fear underneath
that is disappointing anyone's
disappoint Tony I didn't want to
disappoint you guys in the audience and
the breaking of that came down to you
know what it's going to be a lot better
if it's more natural it doesn't mean I
stopped doing research but my solution
has been
I find an angle that I want to pull on I
find the thread that I want to pull on
and once I find that thread I stop
stressing and worrying about the
interview
so yesterday I had Alex hermosi on my
channel and within Instagram live and
I don't know Alex super well we've
connected a little bit on on DMS on
Instagram but I've never done a
interview never haven't met him yet in
person at least at the time of this
recording and I watched some of his
videos and I looked at his story and I
found the angle that I wanted to to go
down I wanted I found the thread I
wanted to pull on and once I did that I
stopped researching the story
and now I can get to within a couple
hours
of researching somebody knowing what I
want to talk to them about
and where we can find our conversation
will be different than others and and I
still I still stress out before an
interview
I'm I'm interviewing somebody
but it's now maybe an hour you know it's
it's 45 minutes or an hour of stressing
out as opposed to a week
I've played small my whole life based
off of this fear of disappointing other
people who's gonna see me fail and and
are they gonna feel like they wasted
their time or money and as a result
it's led to a much
smaller life and lower impact and what
I'm capable of doing
and similar for you you know you've got
fears and insecurities and doubts and
worried about judgment or losing love or
whatever it is and it's keeping you
small and the point of that is not to
beat yourself up it's not to beat myself
up and say oh wow I suck now because I'm
not I'm not doing it it's to realize hey
I've still got a long life ahead you've
still got so many years ahead of you to
live the life that you wanted to have a
big impact and to build the business
that you want to build you you can still
do all of that and recognizing what your
biggest fear is
will allow you to tackle it will allow
you to stop listening to the reasons
right reasons in your head as to why you
can't do something but underneath that
is just fear you're not going to believe
a stupid reason right you're a smart
person so you're going to believe really
smart reasons so our brain comes up with
really smart reasons why we can't do
something right oh I can't make YouTube
videos because I don't have the right
gear and the right camera and the right
phone and the the Right microphone and
the right speech and what's my topic
going to be and what's the thumbnail
going to be and I don't know editing yet
and I don't know what to call it I don't
know the description and do tags still
work and you spend all this time
researching and over analyzing over
stressing because you want it to be
perfect and you've trained yourself that
these are all really value valid reasons
until you believe it but underneath all
of that is really just fear
your fear of it not working you're free
you're afraid of that it will work and
who will see it you're free that it
won't work and people won't see it
you're afraid of being judged you're
afraid of looking a certain way it's
just fear it's just fear the reason why
you're not doing the thing that you want
to do you have you have goals you have
an ambition you have a mission you have
a vision for what you want to create and
the reason why you're not doing is
because you're afraid you're afraid of
something
and we've convinced ourselves with
logical reasons why you can't do it but
really you're just afraid underneath all
of that is just fear and if you can
tackle the fear all of a sudden the
logical reasons go away
because underneath it was just fear you
could start your YouTube video you could
I mean I'm sitting here in my car on my
phone while Nina's in Costco look
you see
Nina's in Costco I'm sitting in the
parking lot
making this video you know it's
and so when you can catch what the thing
is that you're afraid of
that fear
I don't think that it goes away it just
shows up in in bigger versions of it so
I'm still afraid of disappointing people
but it's just now on a bigger scale the
things that you know doing an interview
I'm not as afraid of anymore
interviewing others I'm not as afraid of
anymore even this like filming in public
I used to be terrified of doing this I'm
filming in public like there's like
people well
there people are packing up their cars
and unloading their groceries and I
would always judge and worry like oh if
I'm gonna do something outside it should
be like we're at the back of the parking
lot because what do people walk past me
and they're judging me and they're
looking at me I could never have done
this you know however many years ago and
now we're here so once you conquer that
fear it allows you to keep doing that
same thing but the same fear shows up on
a bigger scale
so I'm not as afraid to do an interview
but I'm afraid to do interview on a on a
bigger show or I'm afraid to go off and
and speak on a giant stage and the trick
is to catch the fear not believe the
excuse or the reasons why we can't do
that thing
and teach yourself that you become the
person who does the things that are
scary
your entire great life is on the other
side of your fears everything that you
want out of life and the impact you want
to have and the business you want to
build the money you want to make goes on
the other side of you taking on those
fears because you've got the heart
you've got the passion you've got the
soul you've got the desire to serve
you've got it you've got it all
you're just afraid and that's normal and
that's okay
trick is to not succumb to the fears to
rise up to them to meet them head on and
go build the life that you want you
don't do you because you're afraid of
negative judgment you're afraid of what
your family will think you're afraid of
what your friends will think you're
afraid of what total strangers will
think you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing outside walking down the
street why it's not because you're
afraid of failing it's because you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people until you crush that fear of
judgment from other people you will
never accomplish the big goals in your
life and today I'm going to show you how
so last weekend I was in Dallas I was
doing a speech at video marketing World
which is a fantastic event put on every
year in Dallas where some of the top
video creators come to try to help other
people are trying to get started in
video marketing build their business and
I had a really important session at the
front
and I was nervous going into it because
I just made a big move on my YouTube
channel my main Channel I split into
eight or nine multiple different
channels so now instead of just running
my main Channel we got channels like
this which is dedicated to its own
channel now when I was thinking about
doing a move it was recommended to me
by Matt Gillen who's one of five people
who who I would really listen to for
YouTube advice there's five people in
the world who said Evan you suck on
YouTube here are the things that you
should do to get better right I'm at The
Cutting Edge just five people who had
listened to one of them is Matt Gillen
and he told me to split up my channel
another one of the five is Jeremy vest
and he told me don't do the split up
I've known Jeremy for a number of years
he's helped me a lot I've helped him a
lot I really respect his opinion he said
do not split up the channels it's better
to keep them all on one channel and so
I'm faced with the Dilemma of which one
do I do and I decided that I'd rather no
one fail than not know that I would
rather do it because I know what my
channel looks like now having all the
videos on one channel I know what that
looks like I didn't know what having
multiple channels look like and so I'd
rather no one failed and not know but
here's the thing why do I tell this
story because when I'm in Dallas
the person who is putting on the event
was Jeremy vest the guy who told me not
to split up the channels the guy who
said this is a mistake you shouldn't do
it you should keep all the videos on one
channel and what did I end up doing I
did the opposite right I did what Matt
said and not Jeremy and so I knew this
question would come up when I was on
stage because everybody there knew that
I had split up my channels and was
wondering how it would work out
and my default response as I thought
about it was I don't want to go deep
into the story because Jeremy is here in
the room and this is his event he's not
just attending he's hosting it this is
his event I don't want to make him feel
bad I don't want to make it seem like
he's on a spot or that I wouldn't want
to listen to his advice because I love
him and respect him and I love hearing
his perspective
but the fact that I was afraid of it
meant that I had to do it that's
something I've trained myself to do that
I want you to train yourself to do as
well that the fact that you are afraid
of what somebody else is going to say or
think means you have to do it you have
to step into it you can't teach yourself
that when you think of something and
you're afraid that you play small it's
better not even to think about it's
better not to catch your insecurity when
you catch it you have to train yourself
to go off and do it
and then I default to thinking okay well
how can I do this in a way that is
respectful to Jeremy that is loving to
Jeremy that that I I can show people how
much I appreciate his feedback that I
don't make him look bad at his own event
how can I do that and then that question
asking leads you to better answers and
so it came up just like I thought it was
gonna come up and I talked about it and
Jeremy wasn't offended and Jeremy did
not look bad and I accomplished my
objective
and I did it made myself feel proud
because I was nervous because I was
afraid and so that's what I want to
teach you that the next time that you're
afraid that the next time you're feeling
small the next time you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you that you
go and you take action that you do the
thing
because you cannot play small for life
if you are worried about what people
think of you you will never accomplish
the big goals in your business because
you have big goals you're an
entrepreneur you want to do amazing
things you have big Ambitions that will
never happen if you're afraid of what
one person is going to think of you stop
focusing on 10-year goals and worry
about what's in front of you right now I
think people spend too much time
worrying about their their life plan
about their five-year goals their
10-year goals think about where you were
10 years ago who were you what were your
goals what did you think was possible 10
years ago you know I'm I'm 40 hold of
money
41 am I 41. I'm 42 soon wow so 42. when
I was 32 did I predict that I'd be here
no think about where you were 10 years
ago could you with any
degree of confidence say this is where
I'm gonna be in 10 years and and this is
what ended up happening there's no way
like you from 10 years ago has no idea
what you're capable of and and that's
the point like if you're growing if
you're learning if you're improving if
you're getting better then you have no
idea what you're capable of doing in a
10-year window
you just don't all you can do is the
best guess if you're going to project
forward 10 years it's the best guess of
where you're at right now and that can
still be a useful exercise
to come up with a list of ideas and
goals of where you want to be in five
years or ten years can still be a useful
exercise for where you are right now the
challenge with it why I'm not a huge fan
of it is because it often then leads to
you locking yourself in because if you
are growing and you're learning and
you're improving and you're getting
better you're watching videos like this
you care about you know improving
yourself
then you honestly should jump off your
10-year goals two years in
16 months in maybe three months in
because you've learned something new and
now this is a better path for you
if you can with precision
hit your 10-year goals then I think
you're thinking small
you're thinking small you're living a
boxed in life you know you're uh your
at a very boring job and you know the
path up and that's where you're going to
be in 10 years I think if you love your
life and you're learning and you're
growing you have no idea what you're
capable of in attending your window
okay so if 10-year goals aren't the
answer then what then what's the answer
how do I get some kind of Direction and
Clarity for what I should do with my
life well I divide into two things one
is you've got your purpose and then
you've got what's in front of you so the
purpose is something that will will
never change your I believe your purpose
comes from your pain so two of the most
important exercises you can ever do is
to figure out your who and your why and
I go through this and build to serve my
book but your who is your single most
important core value mine is believe
figure out what yours is that gives you
Clarity for the rest of your life what I
want to create is things that help me
believe in myself more and then I can
spread more belief to the world as well
right what is your single most important
core value if you feel lost you're
struggling you feel like you've pulled
in a million different directions
everybody's got some agenda for your
time your challenge is you don't know
what you stand for so figure that out
your your single most important value
you're who your why is your purpose your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled with the most is the thing
you want to help other people through
whatever challenges hurdles that you
overcome the most important ones at the
times when you felt the most useless as
a human there are other people right now
millions of people right now who are
struggling with that same exact thing
and your purpose is to help them not
feel as isolated as a loan and help them
not struggle as much so for me it was
helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur so
belief
plus entrepreneurship right because
that's my who and my why so for you what
is your single most important core value
and then what is your pain that you you
experience the most and in that
combination is what you'll love doing
for the rest of your life for the rest
of your life they all be I'll be 120
years old 200 years old who knows how
long we'll be living and I'll still love
believing in entrepreneurs forever it
never gets old it doesn't go away if
anything it only gets stronger and
that's why I think it's one of the most
important exercises not the most
important two exercises you can ever do
in your life because it helps you
understand your life going backwards but
more importantly that helps you plan a
better life going forward
who do you want to be what do you what
is the work that you want to do that
will be of service and in helping others
and make you feel like your life has
meaning
and allow you to be proud of yourself
that is a high level
of what you want to do for the rest of
your life figuring out your who and your
why right most important value and your
your purpose
okay it doesn't really give a lot of
guidance of like what exactly to do
right it doesn't dive into a lot of the
tactics like okay well what do I wake up
and do today if I want to believe in
entrepreneurs it's still pretty big it's
still a pretty wide uh purpose a pretty
wide Mission what do I wanna what do I
actually want to do today well that's
where you connect to
whatever's in front of you right now
what are you most attached to what are
you most emotional about what is your
heart telling you to go off and do and
less about 10 in 10 years I want to have
a New York Times best-selling book or
insert whatever you know goal that you
think is Meaningful to you and much more
about what would make me come alive
right now
and Trust in that instinct so right now
it's making YouTube videos so we're in
the car we're on the way to Costco he's
got some stuff to buy and
I'm making videos because I feel like
this matters this is going to reach
somebody because not just all my videos
but this video right now this one
specifically maybe for you this is this
is the moment where things shift and
change maybe this is the one that gives
you the permission to go and do
something bigger maybe it gives you the
confidence or the courage to say yes to
the idea that you've got in the back
your mind that you've been delaying a
little bit too long on procrastinate a
little bit too long on fearful that it
won't work out and this is the video
that helps you push forward and do it at
least that's what I'm telling myself
that for one person this is going to be
the video that makes a change that's how
I am able to to get up and do these
things otherwise
you land in the land of what's the point
and if you're stuck in what's the point
line then you don't make anything that
that's that's the breaks on everything
that you want out of life and so you've
got your vision and you've got your
purpose what are you trying to
accomplish right you've got your most
important core value and then you've got
what's in front of you what do you work
on right now and how excited are you
buying a lot of times people come to me
and they've got their list of all the
things that they could do I could do
this or I could do that or I could do
this what are you most excited by how
many of those things on your list are
because you think you should do them or
because somebody told you that you
should do them versus you're actually
jazzed about doing it when I first
started doing videos I sucked at it
being introverted and shy and not
knowing any of the technical stuff and
the gear and I really struggled at it
and and there was nothing on paper
um that would have led itself to me
being a content creator right of the
career tests or whatever would never
have pointed towards something like this
but I made a video because I felt like
it
and I liked it I wasn't very good at it
I wasn't getting any results from it but
I liked it I enjoyed it and that is the
thing that allowed me to keep going so
out of all the things that are on your
list or ideas what do you feel most
attached to what are you most energetic
by what would get you going that it
doesn't feel like work to show up and do
these things but it's actually fun the
process not just the result of helping
somebody but the actual process of doing
the the work feels good to you it's
exciting to you what is that thing and
then go do it and if you can match those
two things
setting setting goals is relatively easy
saying you want to have a New York Times
best-selling book in the next 10 years
it's an easy goal to pick the problem
with it is that you're not emotionally
connected to it enough it doesn't mean
enough to you what does that actually
mean
and it's still set by a person who's not
capable of thinking on the 10-year
Horizon because you're going to be a
different person 10 years from now
you'll still have the same core values
but you're going to be stronger you're
going to know more you have a lot more
experience the world will be different
the opportunities will be completely
different right where was I 10 years ago
on YouTube
uh not very far a couple hundred
subscribers would I say I'm gonna have
three million subscribers on my YouTube
channel no I didn't think that was
possible with being a YouTuber wasn't
even a thing
so you don't know what the world holds
for you so you've got your most
important core value
you're who you've got your purpose which
is your why that comes from your pain
and then you've got what's in front of
you right
and don't over judge and over analyze
you don't have the next 18 steps lined
up for yourself or what you should be
doing with your life because nobody's
got that and if you've got that then
you're thinking small because you don't
know what you're capable of so don't
over stress Don't over analyze and the
most important thing is take that if
you've done the work on the high level
to figure out your who and your why
then what's in front of you right now
that you're excited about that you could
do that is of service to other people
and get going
because you've got the heart you've got
the energy you've got the capability
you've got the passion you've got the
desire and the willingness to serve
you just gotta get out and start doing
it
get going believe I feel sometimes like
okay one one piece of the puzzle is for
example going and it's kind of slowing
down and I'm I'm feeling a little bit
exhausted so I want to like turn and
pivot into something that also excites
me and it's a different kind of hobby
different interest different excitement
right so it's like one thing I'll be
talking about you know leadership
development or the other and then all of
a sudden I'll be curious about fashion
and want to like navigate those two
polarities so that I'm constantly
feeling like I'm adding value in
different Industries
well here's the thing I would I would um
encourage a perspective shift for you to
see that those are not actual polarities
okay so inside but this is the challenge
we have so inside of leadership and
fashion
what actually connects them like what's
the core value that you have the
expression for me
but yeah so so expression Eric is all
about expression yeah and and it's how
do you express yourself better and and
how do you allow others to express
themselves better like if somebody said
Eric man I listen to your show or watch
you or I had a conversation with you and
you gave me the permission to express
myself fully
that's like the greatest thing you could
hear from somebody I love it right yeah
so yeah to me this but it's the job
though for you then becomes to be able
to communicate expression through the
work so it's not if somebody just looked
at the content he's talking about
leadership over here he's talking about
fashion over here it feels like it's all
over the place
because you haven't done the job and I
mean I haven't seen all your cons so I'm
just you know putting that on but when
you can do the job to explain that it's
expression
then it all makes sense then I'm
watching Eric not just for leadership
tips I'm watching Eric to figure out how
can I express myself better in all areas
of my life there's this great interview
with Jay-Z where he was talking about
somebody asked him reporter asked him
like how do you how do you move from
from rapping to Fashion to being an
entrepreneur and he's like it's all it's
just all about I think expression might
have been is either expression or
creativity it was like it was it because
it is focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not
that one sentence is at the core of how
I've been able to stay so consistent to
keep making content to not give up to
not get too discouraged and to get back
up every single time and keep going
because I focus on who I am serving
instead of who I'm not
I just recently spoke at Brandenburg
shards influencer Summit and I shared my
graphic of how I've grown over the years
on my channel every time I show that
graph they always ask me how did you
keep going in in the first five years
when you had no subscribers when you had
no comments how did you keep going
and how did you make so many videos how
did you not burn out how have you made
12 000 videos over 12 years how how do
you keep doing it and I don't think I'm
superhuman I don't think I'm I'm extra
special uh I think I had actually more
problems than most I'm I'm shy I'm
introverted I was afraid of the camera I
felt like only egotistical people put
themselves on camera and told their
story I had lots of limiting beliefs and
struggles in getting
my channel and just belief in myself to
put anything out there I hated my first
350 videos I couldn't watch anything
back totally embarrassed by everything I
made
and it was 750 videos before I inspired
myself before I finally liked one of my
own videos like you know what I'm
starting to get decent at this that was
a good video 750 videos in before I did
that so how how do you keep going how
does that make any sense
because I always focus on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't
most of us just focus on who we're not
serving think about your girl think
about if you've made any kind of content
you know at the beginning you get
nothing right there's no reaction
there's no comments and then maybe you
get one comment and then maybe you get
five comments maybe you get 10 likes or
maybe you get however many views on your
videos right you got 100 views on your
video now that's kind of the standard
now if you get 20 views again on a video
oh that that doesn't feel so good right
or if you get a thousand views on a
video or 10 000 views on if there are a
hundred thousand views on a video I
remember the first time I got a hundred
thousand views on a video it's like wow
I've made it
[Laughter]
and then it's easy to feel like oh the
next video got ten percent of that and
you feel like oh I I suck it's not
working right
instead of focusing on that because
that's a losing game
focus on who you are helping and assume
that it is serving people
I've always felt I think some kind of
responsibility or
just gratitude that anybody would care
about what I had to say and that you
were spending your time with me uh I
remember my first speaking gig was at
the YMCA in Canada was at the YMCA and
three people showed up
you know three people showed up and I I
just did my best to give a great
experience to those three people
and then I kept doing it and and the
next time we had four and then we had
seven then we had 12 and then we had 15
and then we had 20 and then we outgrew
the space and so then I went to the
boardroom of a bank uh Royal Bank of
Canada and took over their boardroom at
night for entrepreneurs the free events
I was putting on just to help
entrepreneurs that no business model or
pitch just serving and then we got too
big for the Royal Bank so then we went
to Indigo which was a bookstore it's
like a Barnes and Nobles of Canada
we had you know people coming out and
then more and more and more every every
two weeks I did it again and more people
came and at the at the height we had the
second most number of people to ever
show up at at the bookstore number one
was Sting when he launched the
musician's sting when he launched his
book he came when he did a little
concert and that was the number one
event in terms of number of people that
came out and the second one was my
little entrepreneur
speeches
[Laughter]
that's crazy
when you focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not it does a
couple of things okay
number one it makes you feel so much
better about what you're doing
it makes you feel so much better that
what you're doing matters right we all
want to feel like what we do matters and
if you're used to a thousand views on a
video and then you get 100 views on the
next one you feel like you don't matter
right you feel like you're losing your
value because it didn't reach as many
people don't think like that 100 people
saw it
be thankful and be grateful for the 100
people doesn't mean that you stop caring
about growth and Improvement right
somebody asked me about satisfaction and
happiness and they said I'm I'm always
always happy but I'm almost never
satisfied
I always want to be getting better to
grow to improve and it's more personal
thing if I want to put my best effort
out there today this video I want to be
one of my best videos ever and maybe
accomplish that maybe I don't but it's
the intent because I'm never satisfied
with where I'm at but I'm happy
I'm happy as a human because by putting
out great work and by paying attention
to who you are serving I think that's
the key to being happy to being
fulfilled to feeling like what you do
matters so it gives you that by focusing
who you are serving it gives you that
and number two
when you focus on the people who you are
serving here's a secret they take you to
the people who you're not serving yet
right
if you love this video you might share
it with somebody
you might come back and watch another
video or maybe you share that video with
somebody
when you focus on loving on your
community it's that it's that double
whammy in a positive way of you feel so
good that what you do is having a
meaningful effect and when you love on
your customers when you love on your
audience
they're going to take you to more people
because they're going to feel the love
and they're gonna spread it for you you
don't have to tell them to do it they'll
do it on their own
because
they get Good Vibes by being around you
even if it's just virtually
I think it's really critical
people really struggle with mental
health
in creation right now in
entrepreneurship right now it's a giant
struggle and I see a lot of my
contemporaries a lot of people on
YouTube giving up after a couple months
saying I need a mental health break I'm
burnt out and I've made 12 000 videos
over 12 years and we're still going
and it's not again that I'm superhuman
it's just a shift I'm I'm focusing on
who I am serving and who I am helping
not all the things that I suck at and
how I'm not growing fast enough because
that game never ends right it's a
never-ending climb
so some years I do better than others
and some months I do better than others
and do I want to have bigger numbers of
course
but it's not the reason why I do what I
do
one other little trick that helps a lot
is
assume that for somebody
at least one person what you're going to
create today is gonna be life-changing
assume that for somebody at least one
person what you will create today will
be life-changing that if you're making
content and 100 people see your video
and you might think that's a failure
because you're used to a thousand views
on your video
that for one of those hundred people
it's a life-changing video
my hope my intention is that this video
today is a life-changing video for
somebody for for some of you watching
for most you watching maybe it's just
another good videos okay thank you good
good shot of espresso in the morning
here we go thank you awesome or you're
having breakfast or you're doing
something else you're driving in your
car on your way to work and you're
you're listening to me awesome amazing
but I hope
that for one person it's it's a
life-changing video it's finally going
to give you the permission to go off and
do the thing that you desperately want
to do that you know is in your heart and
has to come out I I just feel that and
I've seen it enough over the years of
people telling me
that my videos have had an impact on
them
only years later yesterday at Brandon
burchard's influencer event that I spoke
at
people were commenting and then dming me
on Instagram and sharing stories of I've
been following you since whatever year
and this is the first time they're ever
telling me right they never left a
comment on a video they never message me
they never emailed me they never they
never tweeted they never sent anything
it's the first time I've ever seen their
name ever and they've been a hardcore
follower for a decade
and I've had a huge impact and I'm part
of their daily life and it's only now a
decade later that I'm finding out about
it
right
there are people who are like that for
you too
and we just assume that we don't matter
and we assume because you might get a
few less views on a video or post that
it's not having an impact and not having
a reach and then you take that person
and feel like you suck assume that it's
making an impact on somebody assume that
it's life-changing for somebody that you
are giving hope encouragement motivation
permission for somebody else to go and
become their best selves
when you tie your self-worth to the
results that you're getting
you ultimately are going to lose
because how some days where you don't
get results
and it's gonna defeat you it's gonna
lead to stress it's gonna lead to
anxiety it's going to lead to what in
the quit it's going to lead the burnout
the key to fulfillment the key to
momentum the key to sustained activity
and the key to actually loving the work
that you're doing
is reminding yourself
the focus on the people that you are
serving instead of the ones that you
aren't because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some incredible Alex harmozi
inspiration check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there priorities mean two things cannot
be equally important when you work on
something if I spend 30 minutes on both
things and I say this one's more
important than this one I can say that
but that's not reality